thank you
order a lot
foreign
the public order emergency commission is
now in session Albert
good morning
today we have a new Witness
we do okay
go ahead
good morning commissioner it's Frank AO
senior Council for the commission
our next witness is uh deputy chief
Ferguson
sorry commissioner if I could inject
there's that there's an echo here that's
quite distracting I don't know if
there's a difficulty with the sound
system
okay
not sure there is a bit of an echo
okay
okay is that better
okay
deputy chief Ferguson will you swear on
a religious document or do you wish to
affirm I'd like to swear in the Bible
please
take the Bible in your right hand thank
you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Trisha Ferguson
p-a-t-r-i-c-i-a-f-e-r-g-u-s-o-n
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do so
swear
Good morning Deputy Chief good morning
it's actually acting deputy chief acting
deputy chief we met in the summer when
you attended an interview with the
commission yes I recall and after that
interview we prepared a summary for you
to review yes and I understand that
you've adopted the contents of that
summary yes I have is there any
corrections that you'd like to make to
that summary no none
um commissioner would that be the
evidence then
now um
I'll just call you deputy chief in uh
for sure for the record maybe do the uh
the number yes uh it's WTS
zero um five zeros
sorry WTS six zeros and two three
now um deputy chief uh during the
freedom Convoy protest back in January
and February you were the executive
responsible for community policing
that's correct and in that role you
supervise these specialized policing
directorate yes I did
and that directorate includes the
special events unit which was
responsible for planning before the
arrival of the Convoy that's correct
and
just to get a sense of the top executive
level at the Ottawa Police Service at
the time at the top there was the the
former Chief slowly yes and then he was
assisted by two Deputy Chiefs that's
right you were one of those yes and the
other uh who was the other deputy chief
a deputy chief Stephen Bell and he's
he's now the interim chief of the auto
Police Service yes he is what portfolio
was he responsible for back in January
last uh well last last winter we refer
to it as the three eyes information
intelligence and investigations
so whereas you had strategic oversight
over planning as part of the community
policing deputy chief had strategic
oversight over intelligence that's right
now you've told us during our interview
that you first learned about the freedom
Convoy the fact that they were traveling
to
Ottawa at during the week of January
17th is that right that's correct and
yesterday the commission heard evidence
that the opp started sharing
intelligence reports related to the
freedom Convoy with the Ops as early as
January 13th that's my understanding so
I want to explore with you the extent to
which that intelligence was shared
within the Ops
so the initial sharing of that report
went to our intelligence section or our
intelligence superintendent and I should
lay the groundwork in that uh in January
of 2022 so January 3rd a number of our
senior officers uh change portfolios so
the person who received that was
superintendent Rob Drummond however he
had moved portfolios at that point in
time I do know it was shared with him
with our special events section and with
former Chief slowly
and when did you first learn about those
hand-in reports
I believe the first one that I was privy
to and actually received was on the 27th
of January
okay the 28th of January and around then
so after the Convoy was was well
underway
um can I call up the document number Ops
three zeros 14479
if we go to page 26
now uh deputy chief uh
so this is a your notes
there's some reference I believe to
February the first
so during the interview we had in the
summer I I I believe you said that the
first time you learned about project
Hendon was after the arrival of the
Convoy do you recall that
um so I would have received it on the
27th or 28th but those were a hectic
times so I can't say for sure that I
actually saw the report at that point in
time I just know that that's when it
landed in my email inbox
um so I I my recollection was as I
mentioned when I spoke to you in the
summertime I had not been aware that
this uh project was underway with the
opp okay and uh
if you received the report as of the
27th what did you do with it since you
first learned about it
I don't recall I I expect I probably
would have seen it at some point in time
in my in my inbox but it was a chaotic
time so many things were going on now
you had your team started planning for
project hand as started planning for the
arrival of the Convoy sometime before
the 27th do you know the extent to which
they were privy to those intelligence
information
uh the special events planning team I
can't say I believe that our
intelligence some of our Intelligence
Officers would have seen it prior to the
Convoy arriving but I don't know the
exact date of that and my role was
really at a strategic level so the plans
were were being developed and I you know
they normally they're developed with
intelligence open source information
police liaison team information tell us
about the usual process for the Ops in
planning for a major event like these
Convoy protests what's the expectations
in terms of information sharing as
between the intelligence unit and the
planning unit
it's generally fairly fairly smooth
um
I would say that the bulk of the
information for demonstrations prior to
the Convoy was not intelligence based it
was information and so it was you know
open source whether that is you know for
an example if we have a concert coming
into town the special events unit will
look at what kind of you know music it
is what kind of crowd it draws they will
speak to places where that that band has
played before and they will develop a
plan that is you know commensurate with
what they've seen in other places and so
for the Convoy they did their usual
where they look to you know determine as
much as they could reached out to other
police services where the Convoy was
traveling through getting information
from them trying to get an assessment or
an idea of numbers that we were looking
at
um and what kind of behavior they were
engaging in along the way in their
cities and up until that point we were
hearing that you know they were
Cooperative they were providing Lanes of
traffic uh across the Prairies
um and so our special events team was
alive to those issues and continued to
gather that right up until the day they
came into town
now yesterday we heard from
superintendent Morris that the the
intelligence that was available uh
strongly suggested a long-term event
meaning weeks not days or weekend did
your planning team take that into
account
I believe what our planning team did was
assessed all of the information that
they had and perhaps there was some
information saying that some factions of
it would be staying for longer I think
what they did was they they developed a
plan uh commensurate to the experience
that we've had for over two and a half
decades in this city as far as I know
um on what demonstrations generally look
like how long they last and the type of
behavior we see and so I believe they
planned uh taking into account all of
that information
and developed a plan that we had now
were there not signs that this protest
was going to be different in the days or
weeks leading up to the the arrival
um I believe
what was fluctuating for us was the
numbers the actual volume of trucks and
as and and the money that they were uh
collecting I think towards the last few
days we were seeing that there was a a
big spike in the GoFundMe money being
raised
so that was different than most of the
demonstrations that we see
um did that tell us specifically that
they were planning on staying for a long
time and that when they got here they
would engage in the behavior that they
did it did not and I think what we've
learned is that there's a lot of
misinformation disinformation and false
information surrounding this group and
so they were trying to assess as best
they could but they relied generally on
the experience that that season planning
team had
now let's take a look at some of the
documents that we know were available to
your team first of all the initial plan
that was developed by the Ops that was
written by staff sergeant Kevin Kennedy
right yes and uh it was then approved by
uh inspector Lucas that's right and they
both reported to you right they reported
to superintendent rayon and then to me
yes right they reported to you through
uh superintendent review
so if we could uh call up please Ops
four zeros two eight seven eight
so deputy chief I'm showing you uh an
email
from Sergeant Sean K to Staff Sergeant
Kennedy dated January the 21st it was
forwarded to you at the top as you can
see we go down to the
bottom to the to page four
at the top of page four
you see that it's written there that the
goal of the Convoy is to remain in
Ottawa until the restrictions are
repealed
yes right
um and there's no expectation at the
time that those restrictions would be
repealed anytime soon no
um so didn't that suggest to your team
that it was going to be a long-term
event not a weekend event I think it
suggested there was the potential for
that
um there were no guarantees I don't
think any information that we had or the
intelligence even to say that it was
going to be here for the amount of time
it was
all right let's call up another document
um Ops 4002932
foreign
I expect this will be an email dated
January the 24th
from Sergeant Louis Cavallo and it was
forwarded to you if we go to page one
near the bottom
sorry uh page one maybe we go up
oh sorry I
let's find it I'm looking for the
reference where it says
different groups now getting on board
let's go down again
oh there that's right
um do you see the the cursor here
different groups now getting on board
such as the farmers and right-wing
extremists calling for major disruptions
I do see that
and uh
what does that suggest to you
um so it suggests that there's there's
interest in this
um a lot of times some of the
information that we will look at are
things like you know if there's a
Facebook live group and we'll see that a
whole lot of people like an event and we
have used that to sort of assess our
level of Staffing needed for an event
but it doesn't always translate to
actual numbers and so when they say
getting on board that could be a number
of different things that could be that
they are contributing to it that could
be that they are supporting them that
could be that they're standing on a
highway overpass you know honking horns
uh in regard to that now the commission
heard evidence last Friday from a
businesswoman a miscarrier
she's a layperson and she said it was
clear to her that the trucks wouldn't be
traveling all this way to Ottawa from
the West to stay a day for a short
protest it was obvious to her
um
she didn't have access to any police
intelligence why wouldn't it be obvious
to someone who's trained to analyze this
kind of events well I think we're
trained to analyze a lot of information
and so that was part of the information
that formed the planning that was going
on but as I said with this campaign
there was a a lot of information coming
at us from different sources some
sources are more reliable than others
and I think even the Hendon reports were
left it quite open that this could be
um you know a prolonged event but then
in another sentence indicated that they
were expecting they would be leaving
town by the end of the weekend or by the
middle of the following week so when we
address the community preparing them for
this we set a prolonged event and for us
the experience in that was over the
three days you know of the weekend so
did we air in in our assessment of this
clearly we did
well in addition to the the Hampton
reports
um there were also other sources of
information
um uh being provided to the city and to
the Ops corroborating uh those
intelligence reports such as the the
email from the hotel association
suggesting that people were booking some
somewhere upwards of 30 days to stay in
the hotels lots of people doing that why
wouldn't that strongly suggest an event
beyond the weekend
well we did work to track down some of
those sources of information
and
we were getting misinformation I said
and disinformation and I think that was
one of those things that they weighed an
assessment we followed up with
um Steve Ball of the hotel association
to determine just how many rooms have
been booked and over the course of the
the Convoy that piece of information
came up on a number of occasions and the
reality was that our hotels were not
able to be booked to capacity because
they did not have the staff we were
still in the sixth wave of covid and
they were working at very limited
capacity at that point in time
now the truck started to arrive on
Friday the 28th right and you gave a
immediate briefing on that day at 11 A.M
so let's go to Ops four zeros3851
so you'll see uh deputy chief that these
are your speaking notes
yes um so if we go down a little bit
you said over the last few days our team
has been finalizing operational plans in
anticipation of the demonstrations
planning has involved coordination
without policing intelligence Partners
at all levels of government
and the other police would like to thank
them and so on information gathered
continues to indicate this will be a
large and significant event that is
expected to last through the weekend
there's no mention that there was any
expectation it would go beyond the
weekend
there was none why was that
um as I said we weighed the information
intelligence we had and that was the
plan that was developed
based on what our our best assessment of
that was wouldn't it have been helpful
to notify the public the business owners
and the residents that at the very least
there was a strong possibility of the
event going beyond the weekend
yes it may well have been helpful
now uh you agree that the planning was
promised entirely on the assumption that
this was going to be a two-day event
right yes
um commissioner commissioner
I mean I I just raise one issue
um I appreciate that the commission
Council has control of the presentation
of the evidence in the hearing
um and also that given the number of
parties each of us has a limited time
with each of the witnesses call
um
may I ask through you that that
the witnesses and this is a good example
um be taken to the parts of the record
that might balance the the
premise of some of the questions that we
have heard so far and I've raised that
because with this we have 25 minutes I
know my friends have some of them have
less maybe some have more it's not
possible for us in the limited time that
we have to put each of the pieces of
information that might for example put
into context the questions that my
friend Mr Owl has raised so far
um about the premise of his question of
strong possibility that it was going to
be longer well there's evidence that it
was going to be a weekend
and we could draw it out but I would be
grateful if I could raise through you
that that the commission's time with the
witnesses be be perhaps more balanced in
present in presenting the information
that that in this case deputy chief
Ferguson had at the time
um rather than counting on her to
remember all of it
um
thank you okay well I think that
certainly you're correct in terms of the
the commission is to bring out the
evidence
either way and to bring the all of the
facts uh to the public eye and uh I to
the degree there is material that goes
the other way I'm sure could the
commission Council will refer to it and
if they don't
I'm sure you will but uh I can assure
you our objective in this hearing is to
provide the public with all of the
information
pro and con of course as you point out
and uh
can't guarantee we're always a hundred
percent correct in what we do we do the
best we can and of course you also know
that there is always enough
cross-examination time to equal the
amount of time commission takes uh so in
total we hope that all of the different
perspectives are brought out and and
yesterday I think was a good example
where there was some very useful I
thought information brought out by the
various parties participating so
certainly
I'm grateful for the contribution of all
the parties so your your question is
noted your concern is noted and I'm sure
Council will take it into account thank
you commissioner
now um
when you spoke to us in August you
mentioned uh that the Ops had standard
plans that it used for parades and other
major events like Canada Day right yes
now the initial plan for the freedom
Convoy and by the way the document
number
is
opp404262 we don't need to call it up
right now but just for the record that's
the plan I'm referring to at the January
28th 29th plan
um
do you agree that that initial plan was
largely a boilerplate plan that followed
the standard template
yeah I believe the components of the
plan were the standard components that
we um that we employ so yes
and according to this initial plan
the Convoy Convoy Vehicles would enter
downtown
Ottawa and the plan was to stack those
Vehicles along Wellington between Kent
and Elgin am I right I believe we had
four areas where we were going to be
stacking vehicles but yes that was one
of them
now um was this plan then this traffic
component uh was it premised on this
being a two-day event yes it was and so
here's something perhaps you can help me
understand because we heard from
counselor McHale on Friday that even for
an event like Canada Day there would be
road closures in the downtown core and
barriers set up to control the mass of
vehicles that might otherwise cause a
problem so why wasn't this done here
well I believe we had officers in who
were our Traffic Unit was uh
leading the uh the trucks to where they
were supposed to be uh so I believe that
was you know barriers and and road
closures impede our ability to get
around and so I think that was what they
were doing was that once the the
um the vehicles were in place and we've
had a number where uh people have stayed
for two days uh on Wellington
um and that is you know it's obviously
the place where they want to be that's
the whole point of their protesting the
federal government
um and so that was what happened uh in
this case and in terms of road closures
and barriers I'm not sure that that
would have been helpful if people were
wanting to leave the barriers would have
impeded them from being able to do that
was any consideration given to for
example
um taking the trucks somewhere beyond
downtown and have transportation
arranged so that people could protest
downtown so the people could be there
yes there was in fact uh the area
designated
um I noticed Coventry wrote I can't
remember the the full name of the
baseball park but that was an area that
was designated somewhere where they
could go and in fact some people did
carpool from there and come downtown but
my I guess the intent of my question was
to move all of the trucks away from the
downtown not just some of them
I think realistically a number of them
really wanted to be in front of
Parliament Hill
um
if if we could have done that if we had
gotten cooperation that certainly would
have been our goal
um but there was an we didn't know the
size of you know of the Convoy how many
trucks we were dealing at and how big an
area we had to uh to work with so we did
our best I think to keep them out of
residential areas and that was why you
know Parkways were chosen Sir Johnny
McDonald Parkway in order to make sure
that you know we we could afford losing
that road for the weekend uh and and
limit the disruption for
Ottawa citizens that was the intent now
in hindsight what would you have done
differently in this planning phase
um
I suppose we would have given more
credibility to the information and
intelligence telling us that there was a
faction that we're planning on staying
for a much longer period of time
all right now so far we've been talking
about the Ops planning before the
convoys arrival I'm going to turn now to
the Ops response after they've arrived
okay but before I do that I want to ask
you some basic questions about uh what's
known as the incident command system
okay now I understand that in responding
to incidents including protests and
demonstrations the police sometimes use
a model called incident command system
and
within the system the role you played uh
back in January February uh was the role
of a strategic Commander that's right
um now there are three different levels
to the command yes um strategic
operational and tactical yes
um what is the Strategic command do
so strategic really informs the goals of
what it is we're trying to achieve
um so in this case you know to to safely
um you know manage this event
um and and ultimately once they had
arrived and
you know not left our goal became to
encourage them to leave uh and so that's
the Strategic level and that really is
what what you know where I was sitting
at the event commander who was
superintendent rayon sorry before we get
to the next level so we're going to talk
about the operational right so before we
leave the Strategic so just to clarify
you'll be setting the Strategic
objective and would you be also
responsible for appointing the
operational Commander yes
um
so once the objective is set and you've
appointed an operational Commander is
there some expectation that you'll give
autonomy to the operational Commander
absolutely that's the only way it works
and why is that important well because
they're the ones who have
um you know much more connection with
what is happening in the different areas
and so they are much more aware of you
know from the ground what is going on
and they're able to take in that
information measure it against what they
know what's going on in another area and
be able to make a decision an event I'm
not always privy to those and would it
also be the role of the Strategic
Commander to ensure that the operational
Commander had the requisite resources
yes to see to the end of the situation
absolutely okay now let's talk about
these the operational Commander the next
level down uh what what does that
involve okay so that would be the event
uh commander and that is somebody who
takes in as I alluded to a little bit
already
um the information that's coming at him
he's got a variety of different people
who are reporting to him and providing
him with updates uh and and he is really
sort of the quarterback I guess if you
will
um making sure that resources are being
sent to the right places in order to
assist achieving our goals here in this
um and then we would move to the
Tactical level
so is it the responsibility of the
operational Commander to develop a
suitable plan to address the incident I
think he assigns that task to his team
to do that and ultimately he's the final
approver of the
um of the plan
and uh depending on the severity of the
incident uh perhaps the operational
Commander is sometimes called an
Incident Commander sometimes a critical
incident commander and I guess with the
Ops they also call the event Commander
right yes yes
um and your role uh as the Strategic uh
Commander is also known as the major
Incident Commander that's right
all right uh now the you mentioned that
uh the operational Commander uh may get
other people to help them yes
um would these be like subject matter
experts in specialized policing areas
yes and he would work at his level so
with other superintendents so let's say
the intelligence uh superintendent or
the investigation superintendent to make
sure that they are feeding into that
their people are involved in uh in the
plan in the aftermath
um and carrying out whatever needs to be
done at the time the tasks and some of
these specialized areas that I expect
will will hear about uh include the
public order unit that's correct and the
police liaison team yes
um okay let's talk about the next oh
actually before we leave this um
we're going to be hearing uh from
inspector Lucas and superintendent
Bernie next week uh would though would
they be operational Commanders
so uh inspector Lucas was The Incident
Commander and uh superintendent Bernier
was the event commander and they would
both be at the operational command level
right
uh no superintendent Bernier was at the
yeah sorry operational
um and I believe that uh inspector Lucas
was more in the um
you're right sorry he would be in that
operational
phase and the Tactical one is more the
p-o-u-p-l-t traffic right so they would
both be reporting to you back in January
February
uh so finally the Tactical uh level uh
what does that involve so that involves
the specific units and their tasks are
very focused on
um as I said the Traffic Unit they came
up with their plan uh too on how to and
this one was very much a traffic
um related uh incident or event but we
also had our public order teams our
police liaison teams we had intelligence
teams we had investigations we had our
Communications team we had Logistics
Staffing
um and and as the event grows you you
build out
um the pieces that you need Finance for
example HR was involved we were swearing
in other
officers from other jurisdictions so as
that progressed and grew so did our uh
our table
would it be fair to say that the
Tactical level of command is responsible
for executing the plan that is developed
by the operational Commander yes it
would
um let's talk about uh the two
specialized unit that I I put to you
before
um the PLT or police liaison unit what
are they
so that's a group of specially trained
officers who
um when we have demonstrations uh
before during and after they're engaged
in reaching out to organizers to build
rapport with them to find out what it is
that the the group is trying to achieve
to work with them to help facilitate
what they are looking to to achieve in
town and so
um
you know part of that is if a group
would like to you know have a March down
Albert Street at eight o'clock in the
morning we might try and speak with them
and say maybe how about we did it at 10
o'clock that might be so those types of
conversations happen
um they look to as I said build rapport
and and relationships with the people
who are involved so that when they get
here uh that relationship is already
established and they can have
conversations with them about
what is acceptable behavior by the
people of their group where
um you know their Charter of Rights and
and perhaps criminal charges could be
um or you know
Disobedience and Civil Disobedience type
of things will occur
um and
in the event that something is going on
during the event where there may be an
agitator or an antagonizer then they
would speak to that person that they
already had the relationship with and
let them know what the consequences are
or that that this behavior is
problematic and we'd like for that too
to cease uh in so much as it really is
about negotiating and trying to change
Behavior through conversation so if
disruptive behaviors occur during an
event would it be the role of the PLT to
engage in order to try to de-escalate
this yes it would
um what about the public order unit or
Pou so public order unit we refer to
them you might see in some of the
documents as ESU Emergency Services Unit
um they they have a two-fold
um
sort of when we have a missing person
they will go out and search an area
they're trained in those types of things
again we have about a hundred officers
both sworn and civilian mostly sworn who
are trained in being able to whether
it's crowd control
crowd management those types of things
so they are the ones who ultimately we
saw uh take the streets on that weekend
that moved forward with the
with moving people out of the street so
if you think of it in the way of a
triangle The Incident Commander is at
the top of the triangle and on both
opposite Corners you have the ability to
use Force should you your PLT and
negotiations break down right so in
responding to the freedom Convoy after
they've arrived was this the model that
the Ops used to address the the incident
yes to a certain extent
um I think we failed in certain areas
regarding PLT and I think they struggled
as a result but that that was what we
were hoping and you saw one of those
Louis Carvalho was on our PLT team he
was a sergeant there and he was working
also with going out to businesses and
letting them know and doing that
engagement piece as well so not just
with the Convoy organizers but with the
areas that they believe are going to be
impacted and affected ahead of time
right so with that background let's
start talking about how the Ops
responded to the freedom Convoy and now
we know that they arrive the weekend of
the 28th and they and the incident was
not resolved until
um
until about three and a half weeks later
yes um so let's break down the time
period and let's talk first about the
first week after they arrived uh so
let's say from January 28th to which is
a Friday to February the 4th okay okay
um now during that period
um
well first tell us what happened on the
first weekend
so uh as they arrived in the town
um you know we we were monitoring
numbers where it was safe you know
safety obviously is always our first
priority
um and and so we were monitoring that
that with that lens for sure uh and we
were starting to see
um you know they were they were pulling
into the areas that they were sent to or
or steered to
um and then we started to see was it was
I was
qualify it as a bit of a party
atmosphere sort of festival-like people
were very excited to be there myself and
Deputy Bell walked around in the
downtown core and saw some of the you
know the people that were there
um and
it wasn't those first few days not as I
would say as disruptive as it got to be
[Music]
um
when the weekend came and went and
Monday morning arrived and they were
still in our streets at that point in
time
Ottawa Police was in a situation of okay
we've got to Pivot we have to
reassess what we've got here we have to
evolve our plan so began starting to you
know strategize and brainstorm as to
what what actions could be taken what
did we have available to us I know that
you know at the command level we had uh
considered an injunction with the city
we had spoken to other policing Partners
a lot of those things were going on at
all levels so at the Strategic the
operational and the Tactical level I
know our members were fully engaged in
in those types of behaviors to try and
come up with what our our next plan we
knew we needed to evolve and move into
another stage really so it was
reorienting ourselves to the situation
that we had
at hand now during that first weekend
when did you first realize that this may
be this may last longer than the weekend
I think really as Sunday progressed uh
we expected that a number of people
would be heading back to you know their
home cities
um and I knew that there were some
people from out west we were seeing the
Alberta plates we were seeing you know
Saskatchewan
um but we expected that you know the we
had an influx of pedestrians that came
over from Quebec side
um I think we had some expectations that
that those folks who were in the
surrounding areas would Retreat back to
their homes
um
and I think you know really Sunday is
Sunday night
um carried on we we had been talking
about demobilization plan up until that
point and clearly that was not the plan
that was going to be required
let me take you to a document
um dated the 31st which would be the
Monday uh Ops four zeros four nine seven
six
this will be an email from Robin Milbank
who's Robin Robin is my executive
assistant okay
I expect this email will
is a kind of minute for an executive
briefing at 8 00 a.m is that correct
that's correct we were briefing
um twice a day and Robin was taking uh
notes from those briefings right so if
you take a look at the second bullet uh
you see a reference to starving is
number one risk priority is working on
plan can you explain what that refers to
so sorry why was Staffing the number one
risk
um the state of the Ottawa Police at
this stage was one of very poor Staffing
we had been
um in that state for uh I would say a
number of years prior to becoming the
the deputy of community policing my
position was the superintendent of
Frontline and so it was a challenge
every day to make sure that we had all
the shifts covered
um
the pandemic obviously like any other
Workforce had a large impact on our
people we had some
High sick levels at this point in time
we were in the sixth wave of covid and
so what we had done to try and mitigate
that was and it had been quite
successful in the early days of the
pandemic was to establish a reserve
Staffing so a group of officers who
would be healthy at home should we have
an outbreak where we have an entire
platoon taken out we are able to up
staff another measure that we took was
to limit our or we have six platoons
generally we cut it down to four
platoons so if you think of 30 people
per platoon when we divided one in half
then we had 45 members on each platoon
to up our numbers a little bit to try
and mitigate that and that was going
into the Convoy we were already I would
describe us as being on our knees and
having run a marathon for the last two
and a half years and it felt like they'd
moved the Finish Line 100 yards or
another Mile and given us 200 pounds to
carry to get to the end so Staffing was
I would say our number number one
Achilles heel in all of this and so all
of these people who had worked
for the the week leading up to the
Convoy over the weekend
and long hours you know our Frontline
members were working 12-hour shifts uh
when the Convoy came and we were trying
to manage Staffing and clear posts some
of them were working up to 15 hours uh
and it was they were they were exhausted
so we needed to make sure that our
people had time off
um and and so that I believe is what
we're speaking about is that it's it's a
risk for us to be able to staff all of
this now did Staffing become the number
one risk overnight because there was no
contingency planned within the initial
plan
I think that's part of it
[Music]
um
you know I think we had we had some
extra resources for the weekend we had
uh some additional public order units
from other services that had come into
town but they all had to get back as
well so our contingency plan really was
for the weekend into Monday morning and
um you know Staffing
I believe that that really is what
they're referring to there so to the
extent there was any contingency
planning it only covered up to perhaps
Monday at noon yep I think that's fair
um now uh that bullet also talks about
priority is working on plan so I I
assume this refers to some kind of a new
plan
uh yes uh or evolving the plan that we
have depending on
um what the planners determine if
they're saying it's an entirely new
we're starting from scratch with a new
position now with the the situation we
have on hand so what's the vision now
for the new plan what was that going to
look like
well I think ultimately we wanted to
move the truckers out of the downtown
core uh
and to limit the impact on our residents
and always to keep in mind Public Safety
uh and our officer safety as well
all right if we go scroll down a little
bit
um
go down
okay do you see the bullet the third
Bullet From the Bottom
says no longer a protests but an
occupation now you need to move away
from the operational plan and reset new
plan needed to go forward
um
now whose view was it that this is no
longer a protest but an occupation I
believe this was cheap slowly
and uh
what makes it
an occupation as opposed to a protest
at this point because they they weren't
leaving
um they had you know expressed that they
wanted to protest
protesting you know generally is a
limited window uh as in our experience
and so the fact that they were now no
longer leaving and the behavior that
they were engaging in I think was what
really
upped that temperature to making it an
occupation that they were settling in
they were starting to put up tents and
you know really begin to entrench
themselves
now at around this time uh
superintendent Abrams of the opp was
also in Ottawa he would actually be
testifying this afternoon after you and
we expect that he may say that the Ops
was struggling to develop a new plan
that Chief slowly would give
inconsistent directions and there was
much confusion what's your perspective
on this
I think those are fair statements
um we struggled because we didn't have
people who were strictly planners our
planners were also people who were site
commanders on the ground who were trying
to manage things at the very tactical
level
um and so I think to say we were
struggling uh is fair and accurate I
think
we did on that Monday morning you can
see the conversation in this we're
trying to get our heads wrapped around
what we were looking at
um and in terms of former Chiefs slowly
providing Direction and
[Music]
um
yeah Direction he definitely was uh of
what he wanted to see happen
so who was the event Commander the
operational level Commander at this time
so at this point in time it remained uh
superintendent rayon and I was the major
event commander and in terms of
developing a plan to resolve the the
incident would it be on
superintendent Rion would that be his
job to develop a plan yes yeah what
would have been your role at that time
in making sure that they were aware of
what the Strategic goals were ultimately
to have you know this result safely as
possible but for these trucks to be
removed from our streets why then would
deformity be giving directions
um I think you'd have to ask Chief
slowly but I think you know from a human
perspective I would say that it was a
this was not what he was expecting and
his reaction was one out of concern out
of stress and out of pressure at this
point in time
all right so let's take a look at what
happened a few days later uh on the 4th
of February can we call up Ops three
zeros one four four five four please
and I want to go to page 52.
so uh deputy chief uh this uh these are
scribe notes or minutes
taken and meetings that involve the form
achieved slowly
so I want to scroll down uh to the part
where it says
last Friday
it's page 52 yeah so deputy chief DC
last Friday last Friday's operational
plan is not valid uh if so
then we need to update it
now help me understand here because as
of the 31st there was a recognition that
you needed a new plan but here we are on
February the 4th
three days later and we're still talking
about last Friday's plan not being valid
was there no new plan yet by the fourth
uh we did not have a new plan by the
fourth we had
um
as I said our planners I think were
working on developing it but they were
also dealing with a number of the the
live issues putting out fires as it were
um within their uh their area and again
Staffing I think for for those folks was
as limited as it was everywhere else in
the organization so I'm not sure whose
notes these are
okay
um yeah so I think it's fair to say that
we did not have another plan developed
by that fourth okay so if we go back in
time to the day before February the 3rd
and I want to show you the document Ops
three zeros one four four eight four
so this looks like uh an email
that the former Chief sent to himself uh
with respect to
a meeting that he had
with you and uh deputy chief Bell so if
we go down to
page three
go down
keep going
keep going
okay do you see the part where he says I
advise that I cannot approve a
recommended course of action without
being grieved on all other reasonable
courses of action so the context was a
discussion of Pou plans
um
what's your recollection as to
achieve the former Chief's role in terms
of approving actions
so it was generally felt and and because
of statements like this that he was the
final approver of plans and that became
the sentiment for everybody who was
producing those plans that they needed
to have them approved by Chief former
Chief slowly
now are these not operational or
tactical decisions involving the POU
they are
but at that time it was is your
understanding that he was directing
decisions at this level of command yeah
he was directing a staff sergeant
and did you feel any need to to
intervene and perhaps speak up and say
hey we have the incident command model
here to run uh each one has their role
within the the model did you do anything
like that uh we did speak to him about
not directing operations
um and and reminded him of of what role
he played in it on a number of occasions
throughout the this time because there
were a few uh incidents where
um he would engage with constables or he
would
um
you know engage with the event Commander
outside of the chain of command
um I think you see in this email or
notes to himself I was working with
staff sergeant stool and the group to
try and get a plan
um to and and indicated that we would
like to see them and he uh the former
Chief wanted him to present to him
um he wanted to see specifically a
public Order Plan
and a public order plan it just forms
part of the larger plan but he was
fixated on this one
okay so as of February the 4th there was
no plan let's move to the next week
roughly from February the 5th which was
a Friday to February the 10th which is a
Thursday
can we have the document Ops
407355 please
foreign
so this is an email from the former
Chief to you deputy chief and I'll give
you a moment to to
look at it can we slowly scroll down
so this seems to be about a meeting that
he was having with the command team at 8
A.M and he set out some priorities so
for example here you see uh three
General priorities listed search contain
and enforce the second being uh well
close everything in Brackets roads
Bridges Highway of ramps as early and as
long as possible the third priority
being to shut down
um well shut down number of things shut
down the funds the the fundraising shut
down the fuel shut down the fund the
bouncy castles and so on
um
so these are the general priorities and
then some specific priorities with
respect to locations are set out and we
see four here there's the Confederation
park being one the riddle we've heard
some evidence about the real Sussex
intersection I assume that's what this
is referring to yes Wellington is that
the the Wellington yes okay and then
sjam is Sir John A McDonald that's right
do you recall the the substance of this
uh meeting yes I do
um now was this an outline for a new
operation plan
certainly seemed that way
so who set these priorities
this would be Chief former Chief slowly
so it is not the operational Commander
setting these priorities or developing a
plan no it isn't
um and was this outline developed into a
fully operational plan
we took portions of this The Surge
contain and enforce had been announced
the day before and that was something
that he wanted us to be doing in the
neighborhoods that were most affected
and and he talked about flooding the
areas and having a cop on every corner
um which in concept is a a good idea to
try and address some of that stuff but
in Practical uh reality we did not have
the again the Staffing to do that
um he had some some good ideas
um but to implement them was very
difficult given the numbers that we had
so some of these things did form what we
call the concept of operation plan which
I believe we had dated on the 9th of
February
oh we'll we'll get to that yeah now
sometimes these meetings we have
multiple uh accounts so here we see
um the former Chiefs uh notes to himself
basically yes but you also recorded this
uh in your notes right so uh I I want to
show you the document Ops 144. if I
might interrupt just for a second sorry
uh to my friend but I just wanted to let
you know that deputy chief actually has
a hard copy of her notes on in front of
her so I just wanted to let that let you
know of that and also in case there's a
specific page you could turn her to she
could actually turn it up in her
notebook very good I think it would
still be helpful for everyone else so
that we can look at the same document at
the same time I only unfortunately
recorded the electronic record page
number but uh
so this is uh your note uh the document
number being Ops one four four seven
nine
and I want to take you to page 43 which
is the electronic record number okay
okay so we see that uh you recorded the
meeting starting at around eight or
eight or six if we scroll down a little
bit I'm looking for the part where it
says need to turn the corner there we
have it need to turn the corner
perhaps you can read it to us sure
need to core to turn the corner today
not changing the operational plan uh
need to implement the hell out of that
plan for the next 72 hours plan we have
is excellent nothing has changed with
commander's intent or Mission okay let's
stop there uh
so this is the chief saying that the
plan is excellent right yes do you agree
that it was an excellent plan
don't think we had a plan at that point
in time
now we expect to hear from
superintendent superintendent Bernier
next week as you've described he was the
event Commander later on uh I think it
was appointed on around February the
10th and I expect that he may tell us
that the Ops lacked an overall plan with
all of the supporting components to end
the protests when he took over the
operational command as of the 10th would
you agree with that yes I would
now um
we saw in the previous document the
February 5th email from the former Chief
that one of the priorities was to shut
down fuel right so I want to take you to
what's
um what's been referred to in uh some of
the evidence uh the so-called Coventry
incident
now that happened on February the 6th
right so uh I guess things are happening
according to the outline of the plan on
the fifth to shut down Fuel and then on
a six we saw actions shutting down few
uh tell us what happened on the sixth
so on the sixth um
I should maybe let you know that The
Incident Commander at this point in time
our story The Event Commander was
superintendent Patterson okay so there
was a switch there was a switch he began
on the sixth of
um of February sorry maybe we should go
back because you mentioned that the
first event Commander was superintendent
ryom that's right and uh how long did he
serve in that role he served until the
evening of the fourth so the Friday
evening
why so short uh well he was the de facto
event Commander because this took place
in his specialized policing event
um but he did not necessarily have the
he had the the skills and capacity to
manage
um the initial event but then as it got
more protracted uh first of all I think
he needed some time some rest days
um but superintendent Dunlop was
ultimately engaged and working uh with
one of the the groups Pou and PLT he
also had some you know I felt reasonable
experience and skills to uh to come in
at this stage in our operation and so I
had approached him to uh to take on that
role uh so when did superintendent
Dunlop take over so the overnight from
the fourth into the fifth so the Friday
into the Saturday morning and how long
did he serve that in that role until the
evening of the fifth why so short
um former Chief slowly did not believe
that he was the right person for the job
um he gave us some myself and Deputy
Bell who both
um were part of the decision making into
who would be the best person at this
stage of the operation but former Chief
slowly had uh I would say it's fair to
say a past history with um
superintendent Dunlop and whether it was
a trust factor or whether it was because
um
superintendent Dunlop had I think
challenged him on a few issues that he
he didn't feel he was right for the
position in that stage and he made it
very clear to me that he didn't approve
of that decision and he was going to
hold me accountable for whatever the
results were of that now you told us
earlier that according to the incident
command model it was it's supposed to be
the Strategic commander who was you at
the time to appoint the the operational
Commander how did you feel about the
chief stepping in and essentially
removing the operational Commander that
you chose
uh I wasn't happy with it but I
recognized it was an untenable situation
for superintendent Dunlop to be in uh
and so with further conversation with DC
Bell we determined that
it would be fair more fair uh to have
another person step in and so that's
when superintendent Patterson was
selected and when did he step in he
stepped in on the morning of the sixth
who chose him
um it was a conversation uh with former
Chief slowly and uh I could tell he he
approved of of him as an incident or as
an event commander and so it was a I
would say a conciliatory conversation
and that's that's ultimately it was my
decision that's where we went okay so
back to the Coventry incident February
6th this is when Mark Patterson had
assumed the role of the event commander
tell us what happened uh on that day
so as the event Commander he determined
he was going to start
um
getting some wins I guess would be the
the showing some some
um action and showing some you know
movement on the part of the police and
so he uh determined with as you see
former Chief slowly was very much about
let's interdict fuel let's do what we
can to stop the supply going to them
and so we knew that Coventry Road was
the site where
um the it was sort of a camp for them
they came back and they had a tent where
they ate
um they were pretty well established
there I believe there were saunas and
things
um set up and they had a fuel truck
there so we were aware and I I believe
our PLT team had been working with
people on that site to engage to
establish a rapport and a relationship
and superintendent Patterson set up to
do what we would call an action and
engage the public order team and
um wanted them to go in and
you know seize the fuel and and stop the
source of of uh of fuel so that's that's
what took place uh on the evening of the
sixth now uh when you spoke of
Engagement by the pot team earlier
um are you referring only to the PLT
team from the Ops no I should have
clarified that the opp PLT team was
assisting our team throughout both as
being a backup if you will or increase
in in numbers but also as as being sort
of sounding boards and guidance they had
a lot of experience in dealing with uh
longer term protests
specifically with respect to the
Coventry location what was the pot
team's objective at that time
I think they were trying to reason with
the organizers and there's always a give
and take with the PLT approach so
um if if we you know if we can agree
with something that you get something we
get something that was what they were
trying to establish I I believe without
being in the weeds of that but that was
the the relationship they were working
on they were looking for small wins for
everybody yes
um and now you spoke earlier about this
command triangle with the operational
Commander at the top of the triangle and
then the two sides uh being the PLT or
negotiation and the other one being the
uh the kind of enforcement actions on
um what is the
like how are those two sides
in the bottom supposed to work together
um in concert with each other I mean I I
think uh what has to happen is that the
PLT team needs to be given the time to
actually affect some change and they
need to be given the room to do so and
the authority to make decisions and that
I believe was not happening that's not
in concert that's the The Incident
Commander the event Commander
um the public order team understands
that they have a role to play and so
oftentimes they will be waiting in the
wings until they're given the you know
go ahead we've done everything we can we
have cleared as much as we can and now
these people have been advised that
they're no longer welcome and and if
they don't leave that they will be
arrested that that type of thing right
so because you you when you describe the
role of the PLT earlier you talked about
how they
they were the first point of contact
they were supposed to engage and
de-escalate and to
to show the protesters what the lawful
limits are right that's right so is the
idea then that they will make contact
and then see if
you know
um it can be successfully de-escalated
before hard actions is enforced yes I
think in the in the
Coventry example you know there were
some things that were concerning and
that there was fuel on site
um you know the fire department had a
they have a house right across the
street they were seeing some things that
they were worried about for safety
reasons for the people involved there so
I think that's the approach that they
took was that we're you know we're
concerned about some of these things and
we want to make sure that you're all
safe and and you It's upsetting the
residents in the area so those types of
conversations but they take a while to
to happen and it requires patience on
the on the part of the event Commander
and how important was it then that the
these two arms the PLT and the the plou
kind of the enforcement part that they
coordinate uh a coherent strategy in
terms of the timing because you said uh
you need to time it so that there's
sufficient time for the protesters to
cooperate right yeah it's very important
and and what happened in this case
uh well I believe in this case and I I
am not 100 I think inspector Lucas could
probably provide you with more details
but
um
superintendent Patterson requested that
the public order team arrive at the
location at Coventry and I believe there
was some back and forth that they did
not feel that was
um
that that should have happened when it
did they they felt that PLT should have
been given more time
um and ultimately uh superintendent
Patterson was very frustrated by that
that they were not
um engaging in when he wanted them there
I do believe that they did eventually
attend
um but the resulting action was that it
it really damaged the relationship with
our PLT team with the opp PLT team and
with the event Commander that was a
fractured uh situation after that and
just so we we understand when the
enforcement action started
was the PLT team even notify that this
was going to happen no they were not so
were they caught as in Surprise entirely
off guard as much as the protesters yes
and when you spoke a sense of betrayal
uh what what do you mean is it
I think they had been experiencing
frustration that whole week
in terms of being able to negotiate with
the uh with the Convoy organizers they
had established fairly reasonable
relationships and and open lines of
communication and there was some back
and forth leading up to this event and
they were not empowered to to make
decisions to be able to get those quick
wins uh one example was porta potties
um you know that that the organizers had
asked for those to be delivered in into
the Red Zone and
um the direction from the event
Commander was we're not giving them one
inch so you know they will have to
um
they'll have to try and come up it was
basically a win-lose scenario if you if
you leave we'll let you go that was sort
of where they were given
um direction that there was nothing
beyond that for a period of time and I
think they were really frustrated by
that and I think the opp team
um were
frustrated as well
um and there was some you know I
received emails saying that they're
they're gonna walk they've had enough
that type of thing now before this
unfortunate incident happened the PLT
team actually had some success earlier
that week right with the Confederation
park that's right tell us about the
Confederation part so Confederation Park
is a location that happens to be right
across the street from City Hall and we
were getting information
um I can't recall the exact date but
that people were setting up in
Confederation Park and they had actually
set up a food
preparation area like a little kitchen
and a Hut and they had propane and they
were really you know setting up for uh
being there for a while and so this
caused obviously the mayor and a number
of people
concerned that this was going on they
were concerned for the safety of having
you know Fuel and and those types of
things so our PLT team went in to speak
to the people who had set up in there
and they engaged them in conversation
and and started to try and get some
movement there
um it took several days and much to the
frustration I think of former Chief
slowly as well as as a number of City
officials but we were able to we brought
in uh Algonquin Elder because they had
indicated that that was that they were
um uh from from the Algonquin nation and
that they you know this was a means to
try and engage in conversation and get
to where a model middle ground that we
could ultimately
um they were able to talk people to
leaving that area on their own and
cleared the park and were able to secure
it
so the Confederation Park was one
example where the search contained and
enforce proved unnecessary because the
PLT team did its work that's right now
um I want to take you to uh back to your
notes
um which relates to the Coventry
incident so we're back to Ops
um
three zeros one four four seven nine
page 55.
so uh W Chief if you want to look at
your hard copy I'm I'll be taking you to
the time at around seven
eight Seventeen eighteen so 5 18 p.m I
actually don't have my hard copies in
front of me I left them with the
colleague but then we're all on the same
page okay same electronic page very good
um so page 55
now do you see
um conversation with deputy chief Bell
regarding the operation at Coventry Road
and then if we go down uh weighing oh
it's okay weighing all options
including state of emergency advice we
may lose OPP PLT if we do actions that's
right
um
so that's what you were just describing
to us yes yeah
and uh if we go further down page the
next page 56 please
um I want to take you to the part that
says
PLT is pissed
OPP has left
set up back
could you read it to us is it set up
yeah set us back days or a week on PL or
a week our PLT is demoralized and Mary
is very upset Patterson was not there
okay set us back days
full week on PLT what do you mean by
that
um
any any ground that they had gained any
relationship that they had made at that
point in time had been damaged
significantly and it would take them
days or weeks to re-establish that
rapport
the person who is very upset who was
that
um that was inspector Manning who was
working with staff sergeant Stoll in the
public order team
and what do you mean when you said
Patterson was not there
um that he was not at the scene I don't
believe at the time when the enforcement
action yes I see
now um we've spoken to inspector Lucas
uh back in the summer and uh he said
that the Coventry operation was an
example of the Ops prioritizing a quick
win on enforcement uh without an overall
plan that integrated the role of the PLT
in operational decisions what's your
view on that that's exactly my view on
that
now I want to ask you about the former
Chiefs slowly's attitude towards
negotiating uh with protesters I want to
take you to um
the document I believe these are minutes
of meetings involving him so Ops three
zeros 14479
oh it's the same at page 63
.
I want to take you to the part where he
seems to have asked the question so he
would uh the question why negotiate with
unlawful protesters do you see that
right okay so sorry uh so it's it's
Chief has said he does not know he does
not know
why we would negotiate with unlawful
protesters
do you remember
uh
this kind of sentiment being expressed
by the former Chief I do what can you
tell us more
so I don't think that the chief I know
he he had some former public order
experience but I don't think he had
um used PLT as much as as we were you
know experienced here in Ottawa
um
we we you know had have had people
trained on this for a number of years
and it has served us incredibly well and
a lot of
um
of demonstrations and really taking the
temperature down and been able to get us
um you know longer term wins but wins
where people walk away safely uh where
they feel like they were heard and that
their goal was met and and that is part
of it because we want to make sure that
you know we're we're not creating a
situation that they will be coming back
again
so our PLT I knew had that capacity I
was familiar with the program I was
involved I was a superintendent when we
had a previous demonstration that shut
down a
a major intersection not long before
this and we use the PLT quite
successfully in that but after that
event they came to me and said we need
more people we need a little bit more
um importance placed on this because it
really is an amazing tool and so they
convinced me and and uh they said they
were you know would like to get more
people trained and I approved that and
that did happen and I'm glad we did have
a number uh for this protracted event so
we were able to rely on on them it also
creates great Goodwill with other police
services and so in this case the opp
stepping in to assist us in this
bolstered our numbers that we were
definitely needing
um and and it means that you have to be
able to work in an integrated manner
I don't believe Chief slowly was
familiar with the framework there is a
national framework that has been
developed down on police response to
demonstrations and this is born out of a
lot of indigenous uh protracted
indigenous demonstrations and the opp
obviously have had a number of
experiences with that so what they
brought to the table was very valuable
to our team
and I believe
um as you cited inspector Lucas's
assessment of of chiefs Lilly and I
think superintendent Patterson as well
was on that page was that we were
needing to demonstrate to the community
that we were actually we were taking
actions and I understand the pressure
and stress that they were they both felt
I felt it as well
but I also felt that we were going to be
judged on this and here we are all these
months later on on our
um coming out of this with as few people
heard as possible
um as you know much Good Will as
possible that we haven't burnt any
Bridges with uh our community with other
policing agencies and and and
with anyone really so
I felt that taking a longer term
approach and potentially getting a you
know a bigger win at the end was the way
to go and I you know was receiving
information that
crowds generally 80 percent of people
are law-abiding and they want to follow
laws and if you give them the
opportunity to have a a win
they will often go on their own and so
those were some of the the things that I
felt we needed to give that a really
good try and I don't believe Chief
slowly at this stage in it was feeling
the same way about it
but surely we can understand the the
pressure that the chief was similarly
heard from the residents last week that
they was they were feeling abandoned
basically by the police they felt
helpless
and very frustrated is it fair to say
then that within the Ops there was
disagreement as to the most appropriate
way to approach the situation and to
resolve it yeah I think that's fair to
say
um
yes thank you for that suggestion I
believe this is uh
February
six but let's scroll up uh so we don't
have to guess
going up
oh February 8th
there we have it thank you
okay so um now on February 8th uh the
same day that uh
that uh
as of as this meeting
um a new development
um happened and that's the arrival of
the integrated Planning Group uh led by
the OPP Chief superintendent party and
the RCMP superintendent Lou right that's
correct tell us what that was all about
so at the time it was actually only in
in reviewing and preparing for for this
um that I realized how they came about
at the time I was not sure
um what the Genesis of of them arriving
was
um but my understanding is it was some
non-ops leaders police leaders who had
determined that
Ottawa needed help and assessed that
they could come in and assist us in
providing a plan we had been asking for
resources Chief Sully had been going to
a variety of services mostly with the
RCMP and the opp requesting uh
assistance in in the way of police
resources and I think what they were
trying to this group was trying to
determine how many people we needed and
what was you know what was the ultimate
goal and what was the plan and we
struggled a little bit with coming up
with a plan per se so I mentioned
earlier the concept of operations that
was part of what we were working on
there to provide them those services to
say this is what we are hoping to do and
this is how we would like to do it in in
Broad Strokes not without like a full
full plan
and so
um this team uh I was made aware of them
I was uh spoken to Carson party reached
out to me uh by phone and said he was
coming into town and that they were here
to to assist and uh in helping us to you
know work out the details of our plan
now I understand that there was a
meeting the first meeting between the
Ops and the integrated Planning Group
happened on the 8th that's right at
around 5 35 PM right yes you've referred
uh you've told us about this strategic
concept of operations was that something
that you came up with uh yes along with
some of the points that you saw the
chief
um right you know suggest on the fifth
uh and so this was yeah a loose I would
say framework that we'd come up with
okay I want to show you a one-page
document and see if that's the
that's that's the document that you were
referring to
um OPP five zeros774
uh not Ops OPP
okay
um
can we go down
oh I see um
77 page 77 please
is there a way for us to rotate the view
no okay all right uh then uh
now I wanted
it may be a little challenging but let's
see if we can read the mission statement
as
so it's near the top uh the Ottawa
Police Service
is a club
in a collaborative approach
with other police agencies Federal
provincial and City partners
uh sorry missing the last word on
communal I think help is on the way
commissioner
can we try the rotation button on the
top
I'm not sure
okay
so Federal provincial and City
Partners Community organizations I'm
sorry I wonder if I could interrupt for
a second I don't know about the witness
but I can tell you it's nearly
impossible to read from where I'm
sitting I it may be the case that this
document exists in some other format
elsewhere in the record I don't know if
we could take a minute to try to find it
I just don't want to be unfair to the
witness of course
okay so do you want to take a short
break or why don't we do that okay well
we can take our morning break 15 minutes
and we'll come back in 15 minutes okay
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
are there a lot
the commission is Rick convenient
foreign
[Applause]
thank you commissioner so during the
break we managed to resolve the
technical issue the document that I read
out the document number of uh previously
was an opp document but there is a
duplicate provided by the Ops and the
document number is Ops
four zeros eight five one eight
and uh so we're now showing the Ops
version of the same document and this
one is easier to read
so if I could take you deputy chief to
the mission statement
this is the
strategic concept of operation that
you've developed in the mission
statement says the Ottawa Police Service
a collaborative approach with other
police agencies Federal provincial and
City Partners Community organizations
and event organizers will provide a safe
and secure environment in the city of
Ottawa during the freedom Convoy 2022
event
the primary goal is to end the protest
peacefully this may be achieved through
proactive engagements by all officers
including police liaison teams
facilitating communication de-escalation
and negotiation as means to achieve a
peaceful resolution
so there is an inclusion of the
engagement process and specifically the
police liaison team
here
with that in mind I want to take you to
um now so uh
we were before the break we're talking
about this meeting initial meeting with
the integrated Planning Group at 5 35 PM
right on February 8th yes and was it at
that meeting that you presented this
strategic concept of operations
not sure if it was this document per se
but I believe we had uh the same points
were established now um about two hours
after this meeting
um at 7 30 PM the same day there was a
command team meeting I want and I want
to take you to the minutes of that
meeting this is Ops
three zeros one four four five four
at page 124.
so you see a reference of something that
former Chief said he said people came to
assess my Readiness and if we're ready
to receive their resources
um if we go down further the chief said
enforcement is where we need to be we
need to show teeth and that the officers
it seems to be an incomplete sentence in
the notes
um but do you recall this command team
uh believing
can you refresh my memory as the time of
this was 7 30 P.S yes and I do remember
that uh can you tell us the nature of
what was discussed uh at this meeting
um
so the chief wanted sort of it was a
meeting after the meeting to determine
what my perception of what was taking
place here uh and as I was the only one
who actually was physically at the
location with the other partners
everyone else called in
on the phone I believe I had a scribe
um with me who who took notes for me
um so the chief was he was late to join
the call for a very good reason but was
unable to hear the the initial part of
it and I think he was disappointed
um that we weren't able to be on teams
it was an RCMP facility so there were a
few things about it I think he was
frustrated about it and he wanted to
know what my perception of you know
their their position and and more of
sort of a strategic what do you think
they're they're looking for from us in
order to give us resources what did you
tell him
my sense uh is that they were here to
help and I shared that with him
um I knew some of the the Carson party
for one
um was somebody who had worked on a
committee with before I knew him to be a
very genuine good man and uh and I felt
that they were here in response to the
fact that we needed some help and that's
what they were doing
with without reservation
and how would you how would you describe
the former Chiefs um
perspective on this uh he seemed to be
suspicious of of what the why they were
here
um you know why couldn't they just give
us the resources that we were asking for
I think he was feeling tested and and we
all were being tested I think to a
certain degree uh where is our plan what
is you know what is our goal what are we
what's the impact we're trying to
achieve so they were asking some pointed
questions
[Music]
now um if we go to the next day February
9th early that morning at around 7 10
a.m there was another briefing
um involving the chief
um you and I believe uh perhaps uh
deputy chief Bell as well
um and uh
and I want to show you the the document
Ops three zeros 14479
so this is perhaps your notes okay
um I know it's page 66 of the electronic
records
so do you see at around 7 10 A.M
um there was a reference to the chief of
briefing the team
yes and at the top Mission Hydra
um is that ring a bell yes it does tell
us what that means
um I wasn't familiar with what Hydra was
I guess it's a mythological Greek figure
but he spoke about it you know this
thing having many heads and so you know
we needed to
as I wrote here cut off and cauterize
the head so as we were able to take
control of a situation then we we we
held that position I think that's what
he was referring to as cauterizing it
was a term that I've not used in in
event planning before
um just to help us understand what did
you understand the many heads to to to
be an analogy of so I think this was his
seven points uh strategy
and I think each of them was one of the
means that we would be able to use to
bring this to an end I see
um Carry On okay
um so he had called us all in there I
think in response to the the meeting of
the night before and
um my assessment of of things that I
don't know that he necessarily agreed
with or I I might not have instilled the
confidence that he uh he was hoping to
hear so he he set out to all of us to
meet and then to actually
um
put this plan into some form of a visual
documentation which you saw that was one
of our
our very Adept planners who was our
project manager who was able to come up
with that that visual that you saw that
we shared with them with the uh each of
the the different points and how we were
going to go about affecting those those
uh those actions now you made a note
about
like in the middle of the page very
aggressive posture language throughout
the whole briefing and mission statement
uh what's the next sentence uh asked if
anyone needed clarifications
so uh what do you mean by very
aggressive posture
um so he was very much at this point in
time
um I would say frustrated
um by where we were at uh so many days
into it and I think he was
[Music]
um
I would say having challenges
not allowing that to show and so he had
us all in a room made sure that
everybody came in at seven o'clock and
that we were all going to be part of
this meeting and all hands on deck we're
going to get this written up and here's
what it's going to look like
now the the plan that this Mission Hydra
uh the plan that the the former Chief um
wanted to carry out uh we have
um a document that I believe is the one
he referred to and I want to show it to
you to confirm it uh can we call up uh
OPP three
zeros1889 please
it's a plan that's also been referred to
by various witnesses as 3.0 does that
ring a bell yes it does what does that
refer to 3.0
uh generally what happens is plans
develop and and you have versions of
them and for everybody's sake of ease
when you are sending a plan around for
people to see you put the most recent
version of it so I think that's what the
3.0 uh and I think uh
we dropped the Hydra I don't think that
was necessarily a planned name we wanted
to go with so I think this is what uh
replaced that okay so are you able to
confirm then that this is uh the plan
that the the former Chief wanted uh that
the one that he spoke to you about on
that morning at 7 10. I believe so if we
could just scroll up Beyond maybe the
first page or two
uh yes that looks to be correct okay now
if we can go to page six I believe
that's where the mission statement is
this is a shorter uh mission statement
compared to the Strategic concept of
operations a document that you had
provided the day before
and this one simply says to end the
unlawful elements of the Ottawa truck
demonstration and restore safe and open
neighborhoods and businesses there's no
reference to the engagement process or
to PLT
tell us about any discussions you may
have had with the the chief on that
point
so coming from the world that I had
before my experience as an Incident
Commander when we are engaging in any
event we will give our if you say
commander's intent or mission of what we
are trying to achieve and it always
begins with my training has syndicated
it always begins with to safely
negotiate the unlawful elements of the
you know to and carry on and you start
with that
um
really focus on negotiation as a
starting point
um I think my recollection of that
meeting was he and I
um had some art arguments I will say we
had a discussion we had a disagreement
on on that and
um ultimately he said it was understood
that we were going to be negotiating and
he did not want it to be
in the mission statement so this mission
statement is what was what was put in in
the end right so I want to go back now
to the um to to your notes
Ops three
zeros14479 at page 66 because there's
some subsequent notes that I want to ask
you to clarify
so um Do You See
um at 720
Chief said Chief laid out his plan
omitted negotiations
and when I brought it up he reacted
angrily saying we're not negotiating
it's better that you read it sure then
said it's implicit
I advised our cic mission statements
always have explicitly stated in the
mission statement if it doesn't reduce
the size of the footprint that is not a
good negotiation
so that was the exchange yes and that
was at 7 10 a.m and then later that
morning
at 9 15 A.M
uh there was another meeting with the
chief had with you and deputy chief Bell
this is at the next page page 67.
okay that's that's okay sorry go up
oh sorry uh yeah sorry go down a little
bit
do you see the part where uh the chief
said he said anyone I'll I'll let you
read it sure anyone who undermines the
operational plan he will crush them and
I wrote in my in Brackets that he said
it twice and his I noticed that his chin
was twitching I was kind of aghast at
the the comment and and that anyone who
executes the plan will be supported
uh takeaway was don't bother arguing
with anything that Patterson offers
Chief and he are in communication and
whoever gets in their way will be
crushed
what did you understand uh the chief to
to convey by those comments
that this was the plan we were going
ahead with
um
and that he didn't want to hear any
further dissenting positions on it this
was where we were going
now if we go down further
okay
could you read to us talked about the
plan
talked about the plan for briefing the
embedded cell I think those of planners
and commanders and he spoke of a type of
conspiracy that is happening at
provincial and federal levels
that this team is being handled by their
political Masters and promoted the idea
that they're not really here to help
so before you carry on the cell or the
team is at the integrated Planning Group
that just came to Ottawa yes it is the
one that you met with uh the day before
yes and that we were planning to meet
with that same day around noon with this
plan okay so
um do you remember this conversation
very well
what did you understand him to mean by
um
political Masters and so on
um
I I believe he he thought that this was
all very politically influenced
um and I will you know say at the outset
I was five or six weeks into being an
acting deputy chief at this point in
time and did not have the same view but
I have not lived
um the you know the same number of years
that that Chief slowly had in in that
realm
um
and so I I felt they were simply cops
coming to help cops and he
um had a different view from I guess his
experience in the conversations that he
was having at that point in time right
now so these are your notes right yes uh
but this meeting is also being recorded
uh as a form of minutes by
by other people so I want to take you to
another record this will be
Ops
three zeros
14454
and I want to take you to page 130
please
if we go down a bit
keep going
okay
so there's a reference
Tom C OPP is that the commissioner karik
of the opp yes I believe that's who he
is assessing if we are worthy of getting
the additional asked resources
and there's a note that trishes you
right that's right that you said I want
us to limit politics
and the chief said
last week we didn't have an incident
command everyone was
running around with confusion
now we know our rules as of noon
does that
none of us did our jobs last week in
what our teams needed we need to say
focus and stick to the plan
and then we have the minutes recording
you saying they're here to help
not sure why we're
that's forcing them forcing them to
arrive here
and the chief said uh the last night was
Amateur hour
do we call this I do
um can you give us the contacts and what
was what you you remember was exchange
yeah so
um that morning the chief had said you
know when we were sitting in that
briefing room that they will be coming
down to 474 Elgin and we will be
presenting our plan there
uh there was probably five or six of
them and we had a full team ourself
and I suggested that perhaps a better
option was to go out to where they were
set up they'd come in from out of town
some of them didn't know Ottawa but they
were already out of the um
one of the RCMP stations and that we
could go out there and present there was
plenty of room I had just been there the
night before it was set up and the chief
said something to the effect of this is
a strategy this is a you know I I don't
expect you to understand but this is our
house and we're going to do this in our
house so
I felt that was a bit of a
power move that I didn't think was
necessarily or was necessary in the
circumstances because I really did feel
that they were here to help and why are
we inconveniencing them
um the chief referred to it as you know
having he shouldn't have to drive out to
the boonies
um to go on you know I think he called
it farhaven
um to to go for this meeting so that was
what that conversation was and then when
he talks about last night being Amateur
hour that's what I was alluding to in
that we couldn't get uh the computer set
up we couldn't get teams going it was
you know different agencies different
key fobs and that type of thing so
that's where his frustration was on that
right so you mentioned that you were
going to meet with the group again that
day
and I believe that meeting took place at
12 10 pm am I right yes that sounds
right so uh if I could take you back to
your notes now Ops
3014454 at page 130
6. oh I'm sorry that's not your notes
it's the same document uh
I apologize
um so we just go down a few pages uh to
page 138
uh if we go down further
okay I want to ask you about this
um
so
we're now at the meeting with the
integrated Planning Group
and the chief asked this question
we can add the information
that was provided by the RCMP but we
haven't agreed not to proceed with our
plan for tonight
yes do you remember this yes what was
that about that was the plan for an
actions on at Rito and Sussex
um that
um
superintendent Patterson had proposed
and was working towards executing
okay tell us about Rito Sussex the
commission has heard some
evidence about why that intersection
might be problematic I'm I'm sorry to
interrupt can we just establish the date
of this meeting please uh it is February
the 9th
at around 12 10 pm
so so Rito and Sussex from the start of
the arrival of of the Convoy uh was a
contentious and volatile I would
describe it um intersection
um the the people who were there the
protesters or the the people who were
there were
um
they seem to be operating mostly on on
their own
they were known to us as the farfatas I
believe they were a group that was
originally mostly from Quebec from the
Quebec area I'm not sure exactly where
and they were
um
I would say the ones that were they were
antagonistic
over the course of the Convoy you know
when people were trying to leave they
were the ones I would say intimidating
people saying Hold the Line you're not
going anywhere those types of things and
because of the location where they were
that was a major intersection that we
were trying to gain back and their
presence there certainly contributed to
the Rito Center being closed which was
obviously one of our major businesses in
the city and was suffering as a result
and we were trying to open that
intersection up to be able to get you
know there's obviously access to Quebec
that comes with that and and the byward
market
and what was the plan that was discussed
at that meeting so they
um were planning on and it wasn't so
much actually I think it was discussed
at this meeting superintendent Patterson
presented his plan after we uh I gave a
presentation on our concept of
operations and he uh described how he
planned on taking that intersection and
it was involving public order units a
number of troops or a number of sections
as they're called uh were going to be
employed in in taking the area making
arrests and then holding that that area
consequently
now we're going to hear from Supreme
super superintendent Abrams later today
as I said and we expect him to you may
say that it was quite critical of this
ops plan he thought it unsafe
um and he thought also in that
discussion that uh
superintendent Patterson might have
misrepresented the PLT involvement what
is your perspective on that I would
agree with that
I believe he told the team or the the
people at that meeting that they were
engaged when superintendent Abram
specifically asked him are they aware
have they been engaged to this point and
and have they exhausted all other
measures and I believe superintendent
superintendent Patterson's response was
yes they had
right
so that meeting between the ops command
team and the integrated Planning Group
took place at around noon and then at 1
40 PM the ops command team had a
debriefing you remember that
um vaguely so um
if we go down to the next page 139
so do you see Ops debrief
from meeting with the opp RCMP meeting
and it recorded the chief as saying as
far as I consider
keep going
nothing has changed until I hear
something different coming from the RCMP
and OPP
so I just want to be clear here because
at that meeting right at the meeting
with the integrated Planning Group
there were at least two things being
discussed one was the degree of
integration
um there there was the ops plan 3.0 and
I understand that the RCMP uh and and
chief party they were also starting to
prepare a kind of plan to uh support
what the Ops had yes they were right so
there were those two plans
um and then there was these Rito Sussex
discus discussion at the same time so
just to be clear when the chief said
here as far as I consider keep going do
you recall
the context was he referring to
the integration issue or was he
referring to the real Sussex issue I'm
actually not sure that I was at this
meeting
um these are I believe are legal
um
our Legal Services notes so I don't know
that I was there and heard that okay so
it may not be fair for me to comment on
what it is that he was saying if on the
face of it it looks to me like he's
talking about that action that we were
planning
okay
um
all right
now um
moving on to the next day
February 10th
at 11 A.M
now I can take you back to your notes
and that is Ops 3014479
if we go to page 75 please
so do you see the first bullet Patterson
said the opp want to make sure
this stays in Ottawa
and
and had no interest
in resolving this
they only want to negotiate
and not do any actions on
um and then the next line says I
disagreed yes tell us about that
Exchange
so this was in relation to the actions
on at Rito and Sussex
um and
this was our daily briefing so there was
a number of people on that call and this
was
um
superintendent Patterson had
not got the plan approved and had it had
not been carried out in the overnight
hours as they were hoping and so he was
he was updating the team as to what
happened and his his perception of what
the OPP's I guess uh ultimate goals were
and at the same time there were things
happening across the province
now when we spoke about this uh about
this day uh during our interview back in
the summer uh you said February 10th was
probably the worst day in your
professional career that's correct why
was that
um so this meeting this was you know as
you were showing here this is a series
of uh discussions that I'm having with
both the event Commander who's reporting
to me and former Chief slowly about the
approach that I I felt we needed to be
taking and as the major event Commander
I was trying to drive in that direction
um
and was continually getting pushback
some of it very public and some of it
you know behind closed doors
um and this was a meeting when we got to
this point uh superintendent Patterson
was also very frustrated and he was you
know presenting his point
um to the group and so there was a
comment made during this meeting where
he
um in my estimation maligned one of our
most seasoned critical incident
commanders on the decision that he made
not to approve this plan and he chalked
it up to him not being involved and not
knowing enough and that's why he uh he
didn't approve it
and so at the end of the call once we
did all the checks that we we did on
these briefings go through
Communications through you know what's
the update how many people on the hill
those types of things
um once that was completed I had asked
for a number of people to stay on the
call
um so you know a corporate communication
folks would have dropped off and some of
the other players uh but the chief was
on superintendent Patterson was on I
don't know all of the people who
remained on the call but are legal uh
Christian you know was um on that call
as well and I started by saying I want
to clarify the role of The Incident
Commander in this case it was uh
superintendent Burnett who had not
approved the plan that Patterson put
forward for actions on on at Rito and
Sussex and he had his reasons for it and
a lot of them related to
um safety of our members and it was
involving Pou teams from other police
services who had also expressed their
concern about the safety of this action
to superintendent Burnett
and
um so I wanted to clarify that and to
say that
I didn't believe that these types of
actions were going to that that they
were a good move at this point in time
if we had said we were going to
negotiate which is what we agreed to
with the opp just yesterday when we
presented her was yesterday when we
presented that plan then that's what we
had to commit to and I didn't feel we
were doing that and I felt we were doing
a disservice to everybody involved and
not to mention you know putting pressure
um
and and putting our members at risk
um they had been swarmed by Men by
protesters at this location before we
knew they had that potential and so this
of all of them was probably the most
dangerous of all the intersections that
we would take on so I expressed that
and then you'd probably see conversation
back and forth between myself and
superintendent Patterson and the chief
weighed in and then at one point in the
meeting
superintendent Patterson asked here and
you see in my notes if Christiano know
who was our legal
um our lawyer was on the call and she
said I'm here and he said I want this
for the notes and then he made uh you
know I would say an attack on my
Integrity
um on on behavior that he felt that I
was engaging in that was unethical and
at that point in time I you know
indicated that I didn't think
that no one said anything so I I said I
I don't um you know I think this is
going to really be difficult for me to
move forward in this uh position I feel
like I'm a fly in the ointment that's
going on right now and that I'm fighting
on on two fronts and that I wasn't
willing to do that anymore so I said to
the chief at that point if if you need
to remove me in order to be able to
go ahead and carry out your plans you're
going to have to do that but I cannot I
fundamentally disagree with the the way
we were going
and that
um I couldn't put our members at risk in
that way
so that was pretty much the end of the
of the conversation and that the meeting
ended at that point
and what decision did the former Chief
made after that
uh he came to see me and we discussed
the situation and I you know in his
um defense he didn't know me very well
uh he didn't know my history he's come
to the organization as an outsider but I
assured him that the behavior I was
being accused of was not in fact what
was happening
um and it involved you know myself and
my husband colluding my husband at the
point was working with the PLT team
uh and that I was getting you know
information that I shouldn't have been
having at that point was really the
accusation uh and so I suggested to the
chief that if that if he really believes
in the direction that he is suggesting
then I'm not the person to be the uh the
commander of this event
um and so he said he would think about
it
um and at the end of our conversation he
ultimately said uh I will keep you as
the event Commander but you must promise
me that you are going to take some days
off that you need a couple of days of
rest not event Commander strategic
strategic Commander yes
um that and at that point time you know
I had been working a number of of days
in a row it felt a little bit like
um I had gotten emotional and he walked
into my office right at the tail end of
that meeting and and I was frustrated
and I was angry
um so it felt a little bit like he was
saying you know you you need to go home
and get some rest
um he was probably right but I was a
little bit frustrated by that and and
I'm frustrated in hearing that it sounds
like I was sent home because I was on
the wrong side of things
um as charadines uh said yesterday that
that was not the case
um I think it was it was out of concern
for you know
for where I was at certainly I was I was
angry frustrated and upset and he said
Deputy Bell will take over for a couple
of days
go home get some rest because I need you
healthy for the long run right
so you did take some rest I did on the
11th and the 12th that's right and then
you came back on the 13th yes now um
when the chief made the decision to
remove uh superintendent Patterson
who stepped in
so at that point in time
it was superintendent Bernie who was
requested to come in were you involved
in that decision I was the chief and I
discussed it as to what what options we
had and uh superintendent Bernie was
ultimately the decision at that stage uh
why was he selected he has lots of
lots of experience in the public order
world but also in planning and in
[Music]
um
specialized events that type of thing he
has been you know Incident Commander
event commander and and has worked in
that world quite a bit
now before I before we get to your
return on the 13th I want to show you
another document it is one that I've
shown you before during our interview
if I could call up
the document number opp404283
if we can just
look at the whole first page let me do
that
so
um this appears to be a draft document
prepared by the integrated Planning
Group and these are the
the services involved right the RCMP OPP
TPS is Toronto police
yrp York Regional Police and what's PRP
peel Regional Police
all right so uh this document is a draft
dated February uh the 10th can we go
back to the title please
uh smiak proposal what is that
um smeak is a term that's used in both
military and policing and it's basically
situation Mission execution and the C
can stand for command or communication
but
now um if we go to
um
section 3.1 of this draft
proposal
it appears that the group was trying to
get a sense of where things
were at uh as of that time on February
the 10th it seems to be an assessment of
the current situation that the Ops had
to confront with and these are
well we see the list can we go down the
list I don't mean that I don't mean
scrolling down but I mean w Chief can
you
tell us look at each bullet and tell us
your perspective on whether this list
accurately reflected the state that the
Ops found itself in as of the 10th of
February
so not intelligence LED I think that's
fairly accurate we were not
really relying on the intelligence to to
formulate the actions and the things
that we were doing
does that include the pre-planning phase
or are you referring strictly to the
February 10th uh I'm thinking just of
the state that we were in the ninth
tenth when I'm assuming this was drafted
up okay yeah
um participants have the initiative
this was in fact something that was
becoming we were becoming aware of this
there were retired police and and
Military members in the protest and they
knew a number of our you know police
tactics and and they had a chief of
security and they were really
um you know keeping themselves in in
those types of
um I guess command
so I think that is that is true
um
reactive tactical aggressive and taking
risks I I would agree with that some of
the actions that they were seeing us
doing whether that was the introduction
of fuel
um those types of things that that the
chief was hoping for us to make some
some Headway there without include the
Rito Sussex fearu action yes it would
uh poor Communications no communication
strategy I think that's fair
um
there were some good Communications and
I I should I shouldn't paint everybody
with that brush but certainly at uh I
know that our our intelligence folks who
are working with OPP members and that
there there was communication going on
there and some people were more
effective at it than others but I think
it's a fair assessment step
um unclear and vague command and control
I think we had a system in place but we
had players who were
um
you know jumping up or jumping down the
the our incident command structure
um
unqualified trained leadership
we had lost a lot of our subject matter
experts in the four or five years
leading up to this uh we used to be
really really strong and and you know
our response to when I think of what
happened here in 2014 the shooting on
Parliament Hill we were subject matter
experts and we had leaders in that area
and a lot of that had had gone with
retirement and because we hadn't had any
big events you know with covid with no
presidential visits none of those things
we hadn't flexed those muscles and so
this was
um obviously unprecedented in terms of
it its uh its size and and the type of
thing we were dealing with
um so I don't know whether unqualified
is uh is fair I would think there's some
people in that chain who would say that
they very much are qualified but
um I think from an opp or somebody
looking and maybe would see that
uh no poor no or poor partner
collaboration I would agree what does
that refer to well I believe at this
strategic level their their the
relationship was strained
um and whether that was Chief to Chief
um or chief with with some of the city
Partners some of the you know political
people who needed to be involved
um
we did have I would say good
collaboration kimayot and I spoke fairly
regularly in terms of you know what are
your people seeing and
um what are you experiencing how can we
support how can we help those types of
conversations we're going on fairly
regularly but
um at certain levels we were not seeing
that same level of collaboration
um
focused on local issue only I believe
that that statement that um
superintendent Patterson made was right
and I also recall former Chief slowly
saying I'm not I don't care about what's
going on elsewhere
Ottawa is where I need to you know have
my focus and you know from his
perspective I can understand that but we
did know that when we took actions here
it had Ripple effects across the country
these were very connected
um reactive people
only maintenance and not resolution and
I believe that Ops Focus
that was our focus and a lot of that had
to do with simply the realities of our
staffing situation
the boots on the ground are officers who
were at posts and who were taking on
those those roles and I think fairly
accurate to say low morale they were
frustrated some of them were left out
for hours in the cold without the
ability for them to be freed up or or
provided meals
um
lack of leadership confidence and
command no clear Direction
I think that's we did hear some of that
especially from the PLT folks physical
and I'm assuming that's mental uh
mentally exhausted poor decision making
um
I'm not sure what the longer
is referring to but I think the you know
obviously when we were not our best
selves at that moment and maybe weren't
making the best decisions and the
information sharing was in complete and
unknown command structure
um and the operational plan not being
signed off
okay uh let's take that a bit further
information sharing incomplete and
unknown command structure do you agree
with that
yeah there's we use different command
structures in the opp and the RCMP
um and so I think they were looking to
see us following uh true models they
vary slightly
um but I do think at points we were not
following the command structure and I
believe that you know as I alluded to
before we had people who were jumping
um jumping chains and and maybe getting
down into areas they didn't need to be
to try and speed things up I think was
probably the and in terms of information
sharing did you see that as an issue
um between Ops and external agencies or
was that
an issue within the Ops itself
I I don't think I experienced that
myself that there was a lack of
information sharing internally
um but I'm assuming if they are no I
can't make that assumption I don't know
what they're referring to specifically
um do you recall uh when we interviewed
you back in the summer you described
some challenges to us in terms of the
sharing of intelligence within the Ops
yes yes tell us more about that
so um our intelligence unit gets all
sorts of information obviously and they
they go through it and there is an
analysis piece that takes place with the
information the intelligence that they
get and they will determine often who
that is relates to and sometimes it's
one of those things that is a nice to
know and we will hang on to that and do
up a report and sometimes it's something
that needs to be actioned by somebody
and I think we we were still relying at
this point in time we have since
evolved but we were relying on them
being the keepers of that information
and and it being shared on a need to
know basis and
um
you know up until this point the major
things that they were looking into were
organized crime and were you know
um National Security threats not so I
mean that was obviously the purview of
the the RCMP but those types of things
and so they would share information like
you know the latest
um itac threat and and some of those
pieces of information uh as needed but
it was really a hierarchy and if you if
you were not in that level then you you
didn't necessarily receive that
information
do you think those barriers that existed
back in around January February
um impeded the degree of integration of
the planning and the intelligence in
preparing Ops for the arrival of the
Convoy I think it's fair to say it it
may have had an impact on it I think
what we were missing was that bridge
between intelligence and special events
to operationalize the information that
they had and we were lacking there
now
um and the point about lack of
leadership uh looking back
what do you think you could have done
differently to provide more leadership
um
it's a good question I think
to convey to the people who reported to
me that we are this is you know we are
moving forward in this direction
to express my trust in them maybe a
little bit more vocally to let them know
that you know
they were the subject matter experts
they had all the you know the
information that they needed and we we
needed to come up with a plan I think
again a lot of the the issues were
Staffing and so tried to rotate people
to provide them with a rest to provide
them with the you know uh
the ability to breathe and and focus on
what they needed to and maybe I needed
to be more task uh driven in terms of
you know we need this plan and I need to
buy someone such and such a Time those
types of things
um yeah now I've asked you about your
leadership but uh what about when you
look around uh do you see other
leadership issues
around those those around you
yeah I think
policing and
jetrax a certain type of person to it
and I think there's a lot of very
strong characters and one of the things
that I felt we maybe could have done
better was listening to each other and
communicating better and being a little
more cohesive as a command team
um
and I I think in moments of of stress
and crisis people are not their best
selves and maybe rely on
um
on behaviors that
are not helpful in in the moment and you
know just show kind of the cracks that
that are coming through and it was an
incredibly long
exhausting uh period of time for the
Ottawa Police and uh I think many of our
members are
are bruised as a result if I can say
that uh and and are still you know in
that stage so it had a
a big toll and obviously what took place
um you know in the in the top job and
with the the council
city council showed just how difficult
it was for everyone not just Ops but for
you know the community as well
right now we spoke a bit about
superintendent Bernie who assumed the
role of event Commander as of the 10th
um and so he would have been reporting
to you when you return on the 13th right
that's right yes
um how did you find him as a leader as
the operation Commander
um superintendent Bernie is very intense
as you will likely uh get to know him
and he got right in dug in and and
started to work on developing his plans
one of the con parts of the conversation
I do recall was he said I will accept
this role because he needed some time to
think about it I think he understood
this was a very big uh job
and he said with the the understanding
that I have a liaison between myself and
strategic command and so he identified
somebody who you know he trusted who
would be able to feed information to us
uh in the Strategic
um
sort of command level and and he wanted
to be
unfettered he wanted to be able to
execute the command as or execute the
plan as he saw fit and that it was in
his hands it was very much a I got this
um speaking of unfettered does that go
back to what you said earlier about the
importance of having autonomy for an
operational Commander absolutely uh and
who became that liaison person
superintendent Rob Drummond
okay
um and you said
um
superintendent Bernier insisted on the
autonomy as well as the the liaison why
why was the liaison
um so important
um I think you'll have to ask him that
but my my sense is that he wanted he
didn't want to be sucked into
lots of meetings he wanted to be able to
to work on the plan and
um traditionally up until this point we
had had a lot of meetings where the
event Commander is actually being taken
away from the tasks of doing the job to
talking about plans and this type of
thing and I think that he felt that was
not a good use of his time and
um
I think he he just wanted that flow of
information to go through one person
um well superintendent Bernier will
testify next week and I expect he will
tell us that one of the early decisions
he made was to appoint OPP
uh
superintendent
Springer as his Deputy yes did you know
about that I did
um in my first conversation with uh
superintendent Bernier uh I said what
I'm going to need sort of a backup I
guess if you will
um and I said who do you want build your
team tell me who you want and I will do
what I can to make sure that those
resources are afforded to you so he
identified Dave Springer who I knew as
well and said can you
um see if he will do it and and speaking
with
um at the time inspector Springer he he
agreed I had a phone conversation with
him he just said can you please you know
give my boss a call to make sure that
they're okay with it which I did and uh
and he joined the team at that point in
time
right
um tell us about the
the degree of integration uh in the days
uh after uh your return so you you took
two days off and you came back on the
13th what did you find when you come
back
so by that point in time
um people had their sleeves rolled up
they were all working at one location
all that um
that you know sort of that level of the
uh superintendent
um Bernier Chief superintendent Carson
party uh Chief superintendent Phil Liu
was also on the team there was a room
full of planners who they had brought in
there were experts in our traffic in
public order everybody was working at
the same location
and I believe at that point in time I
might be wrong on the date exactly but
superintendent Bernie was beginning to
set up what he called his integrated
table and so each of the units that were
needed to be involved that were in an
incident command structure had a spot at
the table and that could have been an
opp officer it could have been an RCMP
officer it could have been
Ottawa Police
right so um
I understand from
interviewing superintendent Bernier that
um a plan that he worked on with the
integrated Planning Group was signed off
as between him and the other members of
the group
um but it appears there might be some
confusion around that time just as to
what extent
um
additional review or approval may or may
not have been required from
strategic level commanders including
yourself or the former Chief so I want
to take you to an email change and see
if you can help us clarify some of those
confusion
um
can we call up
document
opp401547 please
so if we go down to the very bottom to
the beginning of the email chain
so deputy chief you see that this email
began with the former Chief
sending you an email is a request he
said please send me the latest version
of the operational of operations plan
that I approved on Wednesday February
the 9th now which operations plan uh did
you understand him to be referring to I
believe this was the 3.0 the 3.0
and then he also asks also please advise
if the plan has received all official
approvals signatures Etc as there seems
to be some concerns about this from the
RCMP
tell us about this
so I'm not sure if this was um at the
Chiefs level whether it was commissioner
lucky or
um or where that the concerns were
coming from within the RCMP but we did
have
um Chief superintendent or
superintendent Bill Lou from the RCMP
involved in our uh plan at that point in
time
um I do know that in Ottawa there's the
national policing side and then there is
is the operational policing side for the
RCMP and so I don't know if there was a
disconnect there in terms of of that
communication but uh superintendent Lou
had been working on the plan the plan
was moving forward
and had been
built out from what we had supplied at
the 3.0 that's what they had been
working on from that date forward from
the 9th of February to the 13th on these
plans and superintendent Bernie was
receiving these plans reviewing them and
then approving them
so in this one email he seems to be
referring to two different plans
yeah okay so if we go further up
we see your reply
at 5 58. now by the way in between the
request and your reply did you speak to
anyone that you remember
I don't recall okay
um so let's take a look at your reply uh
good evening Chief in checking with Rob
Bernier he finally had a chance to
review the plan from the integrated
planning team and has sent it back with
his comments he would prefer that it be
completed and signed off and will then
share the plan as he is the final
approver of it
S4 3.0
Ottawa truck demo 22 February 9 22
it looks like you attach that 3.0 plan
so
were you responding to both requests and
trying to like I'll let you tell tell us
what you were trying to do it would
appear I'm talking about two different
plans
um and
I don't believe I had seen these the
integrated plan uh not before
superintendent Bernier had signed off on
that so I think what I'm saying is he's
he's had a chance to review the plans
it's a it's a large document lots of
pages involved in details and and uh
superintendent Bernie wanted to go over
all of them
um and he's obviously done a first
review and sent it back with his
comments to the people who were
developing the plan uh and he he's
saying he would prefer that he's he's
had a chance to really make sure that it
is tight and he's happy with it before
sharing the plan
um and as he is the final approver and I
was making that point to say that that
it is up to him to approve the plan up
to up to superintendent Bernie to
approve the plan okay
um
and uh
in you said in checking with Rob Bernie
does that refresh your memory yeah so I
suspect I had a conversation with him
um probably over the phone about where
things were at and what was going on
okay uh so if we go further up
this is the former Chief replying to
your response
he said thank you for the clarification
I was not aware of this delay as I had
approved the plan last Wednesday now
this is February 13th uh and when he
said I had approved the plan last
Wednesday would that have been the ninth
um I appreciate and support
uh
the need for
sorry uh
yeah I appreciate and support the need
for
um Acting Superintendent Bernier to make
adjustments to the plan that he
inherited
what did you understand the chief to be
saying here
adjustments and the plan that he
inherited that he was simply building
out the 3.0 plan I think that's what the
chief was assuming
so were you left with the impression
that like I like what did you understand
like because we started with are you
explaining that there were two plans uh
what did you understand the chief to to
mean when he said this
uh I think the chief was looking for
what what the plan was and that it was
based on that
that plan that we had presented to the
the the integrated the 3.0 yes so he
appeared to suggest that there were
adjustments made to the 3.0 yes when
what I think superintendent Bernier was
doing was tasking the planners with give
me a a full robust plan which we
eventually see is the is the
demobilization plan that we worked off
of so while superintendent Bernier was
asking for
um action on the integrated Planning
Group plan he wanted to to to to have it
move ahead the former Chief was asking
about the 3.0 I believe that's what's
going on here yes and then he said that
said please ensure that the plan is
fully signed off as the earliest
possible opportunity as this is a
priority need expressed by our
integrated partners
the plan in this third paragraph or
fourth paragraph to ensure that it's
fully signed off what did you understand
which plan he was referring to now the
3.0 or the integrated book plan
I believe it was the the the integrated
work plan the one that superintendent
Bernie was working on and that as I had
alluded to superintendent Bernie wanted
to he'd made some comments he'd sent it
back and when it came back to him the
way he wanted it he would sign off on
and approve that plan
so help me understand here were were
there simultaneous work being done on
two plans as of the 13th I don't believe
so I think the chief was under the
impression that 3.0 was being worked on
but it was not it was concluded and I
believe that's what I sent him was the
final document with his signature on it
that was from
the the Wednesday prior
um and what I knew was that
superintendent Bernier was working very
hard tasking his people to come up with
plans traffic plan you know public Order
Plan PLT plan all of the plans that that
form his ultimate demobilization plan
now when you were responding to the
chief's request
on this day have you seen the integrated
group plan yet no I have not right so
his last paragraph to you as such please
communicate via email to the opp and
RCMP the reason for the delay in the
approval
uh
ID the the current plan along with the
timeline that they will receive the
approved plan
copy Christian and I on these emails
Christian is the lawyer right that's
right yeah what did you understand his
request to be was he asking that
the integrated group plan be actioned on
I think he wanted the final plan to be
sent to the RCMP and the opp and to make
sure that he and Christian were copied
when that was done and I'm not sure if
that was because he wanted to
you know take a look at it as well and
have Christiane over look it over
because that had been his practice
before we had he had asked for Legal
Services to look over plans to make sure
that they were meeting
you know that they were legally sound I
think was would have been his uh his
thought process on that
um so I think he wanted
me to make sure that our OPP and RCMP
Partners were provided the plan as soon
as it was signed off on and that he also
wanted to have a look at it but I don't
know he said once the plan has been
approved so
I think he understood at this point in
time he was not the approver of the plan
okay and you speak about the lawyer
reviewing uh documents as a practice but
we're talking about an operational plans
here correct so the practice includes
having legal review of operational plans
it did for former Chief slowly it
doesn't in the ICS model it's not part
of the and in your experience
um at the executive level uh was that
the practice of other chiefs no
what did you understand to be the
significance uh or uh the reason that he
wanted to have these kind of legal
review
I'm not quite sure as I said I think
maybe because he wanted to make sure
from her perspective it was legally
sound but these were operations and so I
think she would be the first one to tell
you that she has no place in in that and
was it understood that the action the
the plan could or could not be actioned
on before the review legal review was
completed
that I'm not sure I'm not sure
all right can we go further up
it's okay so this is your
response the plan that was sent to you
just now
is one that both party and Lou worked on
to include the additional and necessary
parts to ensure it met everyone's needs
so you're now sending the form achieve
the new integrated groups plan right yes
both Carson and Phil were aware of the
reason for the delay as they had been in
regular contact with Rob yesterday and
into today the plan now has the proper
signatories on it and will be the one
referenced moving forward I thank
everyone for the patience and so on so
was that the end of it for that day for
you
I believe so uh if we go up to the top
uh we see that
um the former Chief
um
forwarded it
uh to
the RCMP and OPB commissioner
please be advised our operational plan
was updated per the integrated model
with the input of your respective
representatives and has now been fully
approved and we go further up
we have the commissioner
karik thanking the Ops chief what was
your understanding as to the status of
this plan the integrated groups plan
that at the operational level it had
been signed off and this was simply a
notification to to the Strategic level
that this was the plan we were going
forward with
all right now um
were you aware of any subsequent delay
after the
this is all on the 13th
I think there might have been some
further
conversation about it
um
but I don't have any independent
recollection of exactly what that was
right now
okay uh how am I doing
[Music]
okay uh if I could now take you to
um the plan that was signed off on the
13th
um
I believe this is OPP four zeros 1851.
if we go to page 22 please
oh uh maybe further down I'm looking for
the organization chart
okay now this is a document that you
didn't see uh until later well I guess
on the 13th you had it and you had an
opportunity to review it uh tell us
about uh
this organization uh was this level of
integrated integration happened uh
ever before in your experience
um
hard to say I I have not been part of
one such as this before so this was my
first foray into this world but it uh I
think what you see are the dotted lines
are you know the the sort of even level
of
um
of command and control and then these
straight lines are the who is reporting
to who in that so you see the event
commit the Strategic command I report to
ops command team which would have been
superintendent or rather former Chief
slowly uh and then when we get down to
the operational level and I think it it
it's making pains to show the where one
ends and the other Begins the the clear
lines in between strategic operational
and Tactical
and so
um
then you see you know superintendent
Bernier as the event Commander with
support from both the opp and the RCMP
But ultimately that the
Ottawa Police event Commander is the
um is the lead on the pro on the command
so you see he's got a straight line down
to everybody else and
um deputies or inspector Springer has a
dotted line
right and we see in one of those blue
boxes uh an executive liaison uh Acting
Superintendent Drummond that's what you
talked about right that's correct
and um
comparing we haven't seen we're not
going to have time to look at the the
contents of this plan but you've had the
benefit of uh understanding this plan
comparing this to what was the 3.0
um can you describe summarize for us the
main differences between those plans and
uh which one was Superior
the level of detail that's involved in
this plan that makes it different to
this this is a a true plan
um and and it encompasses all of the
boxes that you see in there it's got
plans subplans from each of those
categories and this is the superior plan
um
I I expect that we will hear uh more
evidence from members of the integrated
group uh who did not consider the 3.0
and adequate plan the kind of plan that
would enable uh the proper allocation
and deployment of resources what's your
perspective on that yeah I would agree
and I I can understand from their
perspective they were sending resources
they were they were providing us with
um with bodies and they wanted to know
what what's the impact that we're
looking to achieve what is our goal and
I don't think 3.0 maybe necessarily laid
that out as clearly as they needed to be
able to invest
um the resources that we were asking for
and what was stopping the Ops from
developing this kind of plan uh earlier
is had more than two weeks yeah these
plans take a long time to draft up and
what we've benefited from was an influx
of of members from like who people who
are true planners
um that that's their their one and only
job to come in and assist us and do this
sort of a 24 7 basis our planners had
been trying to you know they they ex
they came up with a plan and then they
had to go and execute it as well so
um
Staffing I think a some leadership and
some subject matter experts
superintendent Chief superintendent
Carson party is a guru as it pertains to
these things and has done numerous
protracted events and plans and
demonstrations and so those key players
to be able to have around the table and
tap into lessons learned that they've
already had before was was key and
crucial and we did not have that
capacity before this time
so looking back
having regard to all of that the
citizens of Ottawa had to go through
during those three
and a half weeks what could the Ops in
your view have done differently or
better to have shortened that period to
resolve the the incidental protest
earlier
I think
we had a period after that first weekend
where
I say we were orienting ourselves I
think we were floundering a little bit
in terms of our staffing in terms of our
ability to to really take stock of what
was going on and and then move forward
and come up with a plan to get out of it
and I think we lost some time there we
lost some time with some of the yeah
you know actions on that were being
taken that were setting us back we we
didn't have a a
way a clear pathway that we were working
off of and there was a number of
different
um views obviously on on what we should
be doing so I think that set us back
and finally uh there may be a debate as
to
whether the the plan should drive the
number or the numbers should drive the
plan do you know what I'm asking yes I
do and I believe it's
is common that the plan drives the
numbers why do you say that
well because you are
identifying what the outcomes that you
want to achieve and then you work back
from that how do we then build a team
that's going to assist us in in in in
achieving that and I think when you
start with
um just a number then there's no
strategy involved in that and there this
does really need to be laid out and
saying that we need you know 10 public
order sections to achieve this goal so
how many is that that's 50 that but it's
more about
um what is the outcome that we're we're
looking what are our goals and
objectives and how do we staff to that
okay thank you those are my questions
thank you uh the first up in
cross-examination is the opp
thank you commissioner I'll set my clock
here and try my best to stay within my
allotted time
all right good afternoon a
superintendent my name is Christopher
Diana I'm counsel for the opp there's a
few areas that I want to ask about just
to get to more clarity to your evidence
and I want to start with kind of what
was known before the Convoy arrived
in Ottawa and I want to start by the
basic proposition that
Ottawa is very experienced at dealing
with protests and large events this is
something that Ops deals with we've
heard some evidence about the frequency
but this is not an uncommon event right
uh it's not uncommon for us to manage
protests this was an uncommon event
right sure sorry and sometimes the
events are large sometimes they're small
sometimes they're predictable for
example you know Canada Day and other
large events often kind of follow a
certain pattern where you kind of know
what to expect and you can plan
accordingly correct I would agree
but regardless of the nature of the
event whether it's large or small
the Gathering of intelligence is really
important to planning the proper police
response correct yes
and we heard from superintendent Morris
yesterday that intelligence has certain
limits would you agree with that I would
I believe he said that when it comes to
numbers for example you never know
exactly how many vehicles or how many
people are going to show up until the
day of the process itself correct that's
true and that's just something that's
inherent in intelligence there are no
guarantees that's true
but that of course doesn't mean that you
don't plan you make do with the
intelligence that you have available to
you yes and in good planning the
intelligence that you have should drive
the way an event is planned correct
yeah I would say intelligence and
information yes of course there's a
difference and I don't want to get into
that okay at this point I don't have
enough time
so when the Ottawa Police Service
heard about the Convoy leaving western
Canada I expected the Ops would have
immediately started planning for how to
deal with it is that fair I think that's
fair
and as a starting point that requires
collecting and reviewing
information and intelligence to know how
to respond
yes
at that time I believe you said you were
not familiar with project tendon I was
not no of course In fairness you were
not in the intelligence Bureau at the
time correct no
I believe it was with the chief Bell who
was a deputy who was involved in
intelligence at the time yes he was and
he was head of the bureau
um so he was a deputy in charge of it
but there was a superintendent who was
in that position right and I don't know
if you heard superintendent Morris's
evidence from yesterday but he gave a
number of names of various individuals
within
Ottawa Police Service who would have
received copy to the Hendon reports
including for example superintendent
Patterson achieved slowly uh and as an
inspector bride and uh and others
correct that sounds right
now I believe you indicated that you
didn't even know you received a copy I
believe on the 27th or 20th of January
you didn't actually
become aware of the hand that project
tendon until somewhere February 4th the
6th is that correct I believe so yes the
best in my recollection
and I take it that when Hendon crossed
your desk in late January since
intelligence was not particularly your
area you probably felt that others would
kind of deal with that yeah I think in
in my position as a strategic
um you know kind of advisor in this role
I was not reading those reports per se
what I am interested in though of course
Intelligence being as important as it is
for planning were there any meetings of
senior command to discuss the state of
intelligence before the freedom Convoy
hit Ottawa
I believe it had been mentioned in in
some of our meetings in terms of what
Deputy Bell was doing with his team that
he was they were chasing down as much of
the information and intelligence as they
could but
um Beyond as a senior command did we sit
down and talk about it I don't recall
that okay so in those meetings then it
would be Deputy Bell that would have
been responsible at the time for kind of
bringing forward that information yes
and no one at the time said anything
about the hand in reports during those
pre-arrival meetings I don't remember
were you aware during this period of
time that as early as January 20th that
OPP intelligence had indicated that
there was no exit strategy for many of
the protesters
from now I was not them
and would you consider that as the
Strategic Commander would that would
you've considered that important to know
I believe it would have formed part of
how we evaluated our plan for sure
and did you know about the OPP's
Intelligence on fundraising that was
raid that was brought forward in the
ending reports I knew about some
fundraising and I don't know where that
was sourced from but I do recall
inspector Lucas keeping me up to date
saying this is this money has grown
exponentially in the day or two before
they arrived all right and of course
that's important to know because it
speaks to the potential support of the
Convoy correct yeah I don't know that
you can necessarily draw the conclusion
that it means they're going to stay
longer I don't know what that money was
was laid out to do it might have been to
be funding other initiatives so one
could you know make an assumption out of
that but may not be accurate right did
you know that the opp intelligence was
reporting that many of the protesters
will not leave until their demands are
met
um I know that now but I don't believe I
knew that then and again that would have
been important for you to know as a
strategic Commander because it speaks to
their intent yeah
did anyone at these meetings speak about
heavy equipment being brought in
um
this is difficult I'm not sure when I
was aware of that information I do know
at some point in time you know there
were reports on the convoys and whether
that was shared through us through PLT
team or through reports I don't know how
I came to know that or when I came to
know that and of course that will
obviously would be important to know
yeah I would say that you've
now since then have you had a chance to
go back and look at any of the engine
reports yes
and would you agree that those reports
provided important intelligence
they provided a lot of information some
um was consistent with what we saw some
was not consistent with what we saw
there were some some statements that you
know said they would do this and they
absolutely didn't so
um
yeah to answer your question I I we have
had a number of events here since and I
have since moved over from community
policing to what former
um Deputy Bell was working on so I'm
very much alive to Hendon reports and
anytime they show up on my inbox I read
them right away now and of course no
intelligence was generally 100 but for
as a planning tool would you agree that
those reports would have been useful to
have been known at least of the basics
of those reports as part of your
planning process
uh yes I I think there was also though a
lot what we've found is a lot of
misinformation disinformation huge
volumes of information and I think
Hendon has done a great job of sifting
through that as much as possible but
there's still a variety of information
that is presented on those and some has
come to fruition in past events and some
has not right and that's kind of the
challenge right of intelligence
gathering is to take the information put
it through the lens and then come up
with a product to assist in the planning
process yes and that was the very
purpose of hand incorrect yes
foreign
there was a plan in place to deal with
this event before the Convoy arrived
correct yes there was and it was a plan
that was predicated on a weekend-long
event yes
and is it fair to say that was based
more on previous experience than it was
on actual intelligence
I don't know if that's fair to say
because I don't know what our
intelligence folks had in the way of of
information and how much of that fed
into the plan I think
you know traditionally 25 years of
planning here with fairly similar types
of protests uh experience was definitely
something that our team was likely
relying on but do you think that might
have been part of the challenge here is
that Ottawa was so Ottawa Police Service
was so used to dealing with certain
kinds of protests that perhaps you know
the template plan was dusted off a few
revisions were made and presented as
being something that will be appropriate
for this event
I don't know that any Services across
the country would have anticipated what
we saw arriving at our doorstep so I you
know how do we have plans and do we use
you know some of the same ones and
change dates and names and and you know
build upon them yes we do uh in this
case I don't know that that's exactly
what happened no but I guess the reason
I'm asking is just because you know
asking whether there may have been
complacency and we're trying to
understand what happened here and how to
prevent these things are you concerned
that maybe there was a failure to
appreciate what may actually happen here
and there was just too much Reliance on
what was done in the past I think there
was definitely a failure to appreciate
if we can bring up
opp3531 please
actually sorry like Ops 3531
got one of the letters wrong
all right so this is the operational
plan I believe that that you're aware of
this document correct yes
and would you have approved this
document as a treaty as a strategic
Commander
I would have seen it but not approved it
okay can we turn to page six please
and scroll down where it says threat
assessment do you see that where it says
threat assessment
I take it that's an area that would
typically provide relevant intelligence
to help guide the response yes
and would you agree that there's no I'll
put to you that there's no reference
obviously to the hennen reports in that
assessment would you agree with that not
from the portion you're showing me I
don't know if it goes on hey we can
scroll down to the end of that section
please
that's good
and I guess the point I'm trying to make
through this is that that section on
threat assessment does not reference
Concepts that were in the handling
reports such as the fact that there was
no Exit Plan there is nothing about
fundraising nothing about the intentions
of the protesters to stay until their
goals had been met nothing about heavy
machinery
all that was an independent report and I
guess the point that I would put to you
is that that was all important
information that should have been in the
threat assessment would you agree I
would I do note here that they say that
they
um you know investigate existing
intelligence pieces into liaise with its
Federal and provincial partners for any
indicators of possible disruptions to
the Convoy should this change with new
information it will be updated
accordingly and disseminated so I gather
they didn't
have any additional information no would
you agree then that with the proposition
that this plan was not an intelligence
elect plan it was just more of a traffic
plan based on experience than one that's
truly led by intelligence yes I would
agree that
I'd like to ask about the integrated
planning team that came to Ottawa
you've said some positive things
obviously about about Chief uh party and
others involved in the plan might take I
believe they arrived on or about
February 8th is that about your
recollection that's right yeah
and I believe your evidence was that you
fully supported the concept of an
integrated planning team yes
yes you were aware of course that
Toronto police was involved York peel
U.S subject matter experts from a number
of police services yes
and would you agree that this was not
the B team right no I mean these were
highly regarded incident commanders
excellent planners PLU experts and
people that were top in their field
correct correct and they were all coming
to get to Ottawa to help the Ops kind of
resolve the situation correct and I was
very grateful for them yes
but is it fair to say that your
enthusiasm or your support wasn't shared
entirely by all members of Ops senior
command that's
and is it also fair to say that that
lack of initial buy-in caught some delay
in the ultimate uh agreement on the plan
and the execution
that's fair to say
and one of the it's problematic in the
sense that the the planning team can was
brought there to assist Ops correct yes
with the Ottawa Police Service was a
police Earth of jurisdiction so unless
it until Ops agreed with it there was
really nothing that the team could do
correct that's right
a few questions about PLT again you said
some very favorable things about the
provincial liaison team
the in the Ottawa it works different I
believe in the Ontario Provincial Police
than it does in the Ops it's obviously
OPP is a much larger Police Service my
understanding is that in the Ottawa
Police Service PLT members are all
part-time is that correct that's right
they were I think at this point so in
other words I guess just the weather is
going to understand like being a PLT
member is not their full-time job that
as the need may arise then they can go
and they can do PLT duties if asked they
would be freed up for that yeah
and so that the implication of that is
that PLT is only engaged if commanders
feel that their involvement would be
helpful or necessary
uh I believe I would say that depends on
the The Incident Commander I think the
current Cadre we have and had at that
time were very uh aware of what PLT was
capable of and and engaged with using
them yeah and that was actually I mean
you were able to know what my next
question was but not because it very
much depends on The Incident Commander
as to their own personal view of the
effectiveness of that style of policing
or their own knowledge about how PLT
Works correct in DTS and when you
consider that a bit of a you know a
problem in terms of lack of consistency
and approach I would
and is it fair to say that in January
2022
there were very few and Ops senior
Commander at higher command levels that
really understood the potential value of
PLT
I agree or that understood the national
framework put out by the Canadian
Association that Chiefs the police
definitely
and I believe you're in your evidence in
Chief you said PLT is an amazing tool
and I expect that that's kind of the
attitude you bring towards use of PLT
yes it is
but would you agree that in reflecting
upon Lessons Learned here that PLT was
misused by Ops in this dispute I would
agree and finally on the point of
jurisdiction
once the Convoy arrived in Ottawa you
would agree to the obvious proposition
but it's worth repeating that Ottawa
Police Service was the Police Service of
jurisdiction correct yes we were
which meant that at that point it was no
longer the obp's responsibility
jurisdictionally yes yeah it was ours
and in fact it would have been improper
for the opp to try to step in and kind
of take over policing correct agreed
that there's no legal mechanism for the
opp to take over unless certain
scenarios are met correct that's right
but the police services act sets out
very specific circumstances where the
opp may take over command of a certain
incident or area yes
and one of those would be if a formal
request would be made from the OPF Chief
to the OBP commissioner correct I think
that's how it works yes
although no such request was made in
this case correct
I would have been surprised if it was I
don't know though for sure so I didn't
hear you I I don't know if it was made
or not so but did you say it would you'd
be surprised I would have been surprised
if the request was made why would you
have been surprised because I don't
think that that's what um former Chiefs
Lily was wanted why
I think you'd have to ask him it was
clear to me that he was pushing back on
on that
oh I'm asking you though because you
have a lot you've had a lot of dealings
with Chief slowly so why in your opinion
and in your experience do you believe
Chief slowly uh would have refused to
consider or would have would not have
entertained the possibility of asking
for formal assistance in that way I
don't believe he wanted to give up
control I think he felt that this he was
the chief in the in the police of
jurisdiction and he wanted that to be
maintained
when it came to providing assistance
would you agree that the opp did
everything it was asked to do by the
Ottawa Police Service yes they did
uh thank you very much I appreciate your
evidence thank you
thank
you
next is uh
former Chief slowly's Council and it
looks like it'll be like yesterday
you'll be split in two if that's
agreeable you'll do uh 10 minutes before
uh lunch and then
can finish after lunch
good afternoon good afternoon
foreign
acting Deputy at Chief Ferguson at you
were just introduce yourself uh for the
record yes Rebecca Jones for uh former
Chief slowly
um
acting deputy chief Ferguson uh you were
the mic for the freedom Convoy right
that's right
and as mic you had overall
responsibility for the ops's planning
and response to the protests
and
your testimony is that you weren't
reading the Hendon reports though you
knew that they existed right as of the
28th of uh
of January when I think I was forwarded
one right okay and your role though you
were the mic with the overall
responsibility
um you were working with deputy chief
Bell who had overall responsibility for
intelligence right
um yes yep
and I take it you were relying on the
intelligence team to provide you with
the information you needed from the
intelligence report to input into your
plans I think my team was yes I wasn't
writing the plans but yes you yourself
weren't writing the plan no okay
and
you weren't writing the plans directly
and you weren't reading the intelligence
reports directly you were at a higher
strategic level that's right okay and
similarly uh there would be no
expectation that the chief of police
would be pouring through the Hendon
reports and trying to reconcile the
different pieces of intelligence right
no I don't think that would be realistic
okay and the chief of police would be at
an even higher level relying on his team
for operations and intelligence yes
um
and
one of the the things that you noted was
that you did not believe that the
initial plan the the January 29th plan
um was intelligence-led
um and I just want to suggest to you
that Chief slowly's expectation for his
command had been from when he entered as
chief that all operational plans were to
be intelligence-led
yes okay
um
now for this initial uh January 29th
plan
um I take it that she slowly's
involvement in the process is as you
would have expected
yes
so he did not direct the planning unduly
not at this point nope didn't interfere
nope
um and in fact Chief slowly did not even
see the plan or a draft of the plan
until the morning of January 28th when
it was provided to him for the first
time right that's possible yeah okay
and
um
he said looks fine to him and the team
proceeded with that plan that's right
and he would have been looking in uh
when looking at that plan he would have
been considering the intelligence and
operational details that had been
provided to him by his senior command
team
I think that's fair yes
now if we pivot forward a few days to uh
Sunday night January 30th at that point
your evidence is that it became clear to
the Ops that the people were not going
to leave
and that there needed to be a pivot in
the plan
yes a pivot in our response anyway pivot
in your response okay fair enough
and you as the mic were responsible in
that pivot right yes
and that required
um Evolution significant evolution of
the January 29th plan
because the January 29th plan had been
based on you know a big boisterous uh
traffic impeding protest
but not an occupation that's right
and as of January 30th
um I take it that you agreed with the
assessment that that the Ops was now
facing an occupation yes
now you were taken to
notes
um from February 3rd
uh and we can perhaps put them up Ops
one four four eight four
page three please
and uh for everyone's benefit these are
February third notes of Chief slowly
and he's referring to a meeting with you
and deputy chief Bell correct correct
um and he refers in the first line to
I've advised that we've had two days
since the POU meeting on Tuesday so that
was a meeting that took place on
February 1st right yes that's right and
chief slowly had made very clear in that
meeting exactly what you said there
needed to be a pivot and the plan had to
be significantly evolved to deal with
the situation
yes okay and at the point of this
meeting now two days later and
four days after the determination that
this was in fact an occupation that
required a new plan
um he had not seen
a new and I shouldn't say a new plan
I'll go back to what we have spoken
about an evolution of the plan he had
not seen an evolved version of this plan
right
correct okay
and what he was looking for here was a
specifically a public order unit plan
not not the wider plan okay and that
that would be part of the evolved plan
right there would be a public order a
component of the of the plan to try to
figure out how we're going to
resolve the situation with the the
people that were occupying the city
there would be public Order Plan there
would be a PLT plan there would be a
traffic plan there would be an
investigations plan
um all of those things wanted to plan
but he was fixated solely on this one
well the word fixated is about loaded
um so he was interested in a public
order unit plan yes in fact I met with
them in person and met with them in
person
um but to be fair to your former Chief
he also expected that there would be a
traffic plan and a PLT plan and all of
those other plans were evolving at the
same time yes he just didn't meet with
any of those other groups I think he
might have met with the PLT when there
was some Discord that he'd heard about
that they were
unhappy
um but this was the only group that he
met with and I take you're not being
critical of him for not meeting with the
other groups no not at all okay because
it's a bit hard to be cheap slowly
sometimes I think in terms of criticize
for being too involved versus criticized
for not being involved enough right yes
okay so here on this day
um this you were taken to this document
um but you weren't taken to the very end
of the document
if you can scroll down a little bit
more keep going
um oh sorry go up a little bit end of
this paragraph the paragraph at the top
of the page I directed once again acting
deputy chief Ferguson to ensure that
Sergeant stole and he was uh staff
sergeant stroll I apologize and he was
um involved in the poe Pou component of
the plan correct it was yeah okay
um that he got the resources he needed
to make the assessments slash final
recommendation
yes right okay so staff sergeant stole
the chief wanted to make sure he had the
resources he needed to put the make the
inputs into this plan yes okay
and now if we can go please
to uh doc uh Ops 7355
and we looked at these uh notes earlier
today February 5th uh these are notes uh
scroll up a little bit okay so it's
actually an email from former Chief
slowly uh to you copied to
um many people on the team
um and this is the document if you
scroll down
um
where Chief slowly sets out some general
priorities
um for planning purposes correct
he's directing the plan but yes that's
that's what he said out here are his
priorities for that okay and you felt
that this was directing the plan yes
okay and your suggestion is that that
was
somehow too directive yes okay so I'm
going to return to that but when we look
at these priorities I'm going to suggest
to you they're pretty high level
surge contain and enforce demonstration
fully Implement plan
shut down secure enablers for unlawful
and unsafe protests fuel fun those are
much more in the weeds
okay but this isn't you're not
suggesting this is some sort of tactical
level plan
there there are portions of it that
certainly look tactical to me
so you've contradict in in the fuel
specifically and that was one of his his
things on a number of occasions sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt the fuel in
particular was an issue of a lot of
public attention in Ottawa right okay
so
and I'm almost at a time for lunch so
I'll just ask you to agree with me about
this
if you step back and try to put yourself
in Chief slowly's shoes we are now on
February 5th
we are now seven days after a
determination had been made that the
city was
that the plan needed to be evolved and
he hadn't seen an evolved plan correct
correct okay so when we talk about how
involved uh would expect a chief to be
or how involved how much autonomy you're
supposed to be giving your team this was
an exceptional circumstance right
yes it was it was an exceptional
circumstance and he was trying to get
his team to move forward with the
evolved plan right but without the
resources to do so that was the the
impediment to us at that point in time
for those seven days that's exactly what
we were struggling with I could not
agree with you more and we can return to
that after the lunch break okay
okay so we'll take a an hour for lunch
and come back and continue this thank
you thank you
thank you the commission is in recess
for one hour
how are you
foreign
order unload
okay
the commission is we convenient
I want to turn now uh we will get to
Resources by the end of my
cross-examination but I'm going to turn
first to the PLT which is something
we've heard a lot about this morning
um the PLT is one of many important
groups that within within the law
enforcement uh
efforts that was working to resolve the
issue of the Convoy right yes
and there were other very important
groups such as intelligence people that
were doing enforcement at Pou all also
had a rule correct agreed
and some people may favor a bigger role
for the PLT and some people may favor a
bigger role for enforcement
right depending on the circumstance yes
right
um and reasonable people could disagree
about how much emphasis to put on which
law enforcement tool you have yes it's
always a balance
and is it fair to say that you and your
partners with the opp
favored the more PLT type approach here
I think that's fair okay and and others
um you felt such as Chief slowly and
superintendent Patterson you felt they
favored a more enforcement-based
approach
that was the impression I had yes okay
um and but I just want to return to one
thing which is that February 1st uh Pou
meeting at that meeting were you aware
that she slowly ensured that the PLT was
there yes okay so making sure that the
PLT was integrated with the POU when
talking about planning right yeah and
that's a good idea I believe so yeah
okay but this
sort of tension existed between how much
enforcement to do versus how much
negotiation through the PLT to do yeah
and just as a slight aside to that is it
fair to say that the public frustration
was focused in large part on what the
public perceived to be a lack of
enforcement
yes okay that's fair and and I'm not
asking you to weigh in on whether or not
you agree
um there was a lot of complex
considerations that were going into all
police action at the time right there
um but you'll agree with me that public
confidence in police
is itself a crucial public safety issue
yes I think that's fair okay
okay
um this tension between the more PLT
type approach or an approach that also
Incorporated enforcement really came to
a head on February 10th right and you've
talked about that yep and that is the
meeting where you and superintendent
Patterson had a dispute yes
and in that dispute superintendent
Patterson suggested that you favored and
I'm not using the right words but the
overall uh gist of it was that you were
favoring a PLT driven strategy
um in part because your husband was
leading the PLT right
I don't think that's what his
um
and maybe I'll ask you to reframe or to
repeat it if that's true I felt or if
that's what he was saying and and if I'm
characterizing it incorrectly please
feel free to to clarify my understanding
was that superintendent Patterson
um made a suggestion That You Were
Somehow favoring a more PLT driven
approach
um in some way related to the fact that
your husband was a team lead for the PLT
I don't know that that's what he was
insinuating but I can tell you that that
was not the
um
that was not why I was favoring PLT I
favored PLT because I had seen it in
action before and my husband was
actually not normally with PLT but was a
crisis negotiator so placed in that
position
and I'm not I just want to be very aware
I'm in no way suggesting that that's
what was happening okay okay
um but just that there was a dispute
about your husband's role in PLT and
whether that had any influence on your
favoring of a PLT strategy
yeah I I'm I don't know that that's what
he was trying to say superintendent
Patterson I want to put words into his
mouth I didn't unders I didn't take it
to be that
um angle that you're you're suggesting
so I don't want to agree to that because
I don't know that that's what he was
okay so and so please feel free to to
clarify what you think he was suggesting
about
your favoring of a PLT strategy and your
and its relationship to your spouse
I think he was insinuating that I had
communicated with my spouse about this
particular operation
and that that had undermined his ability
to
um to proceed with the operation ah I
got it okay fair enough
um
inappropriate suggestion yes okay and it
was very upsetting to you I imagine yeah
it was okay and you spoke to Chief
slowly who supported you right yes Chief
slowly understood why you were upset yes
and chief slowly removed superintendent
Patterson from his position within the
incident command after some discussion
in my request yep yes and and and that's
appropriate right to ask you what you
want to do yes right and then he
supported you yes he did okay
um and this is just a very small point
but
um my friend spent some time
looking at the mission statement of the
February 9th uh plan do you remember
that yes yep and I just want to to be
clear for everyone the the
upshot of that was that you wanted the
role of the PLT or negotiation to be
stated explicitly in the mission
statement and she slowly said it's
implicit in the mission State yeah I
wanted the word negotiation right there
not necessarily mention of the PLT but
that we we are doing this through
negotiated methods right and chief
slowly said yeah I think that's implicit
I don't think it needs to go in the
mission statement that's right okay
well he said no first sorry pardon my
Interruption he said no first and then
he said it's implied
and then he said it's implied yes okay
um
one other point before we turn away from
the PLT which is
um you you referred to the fact that you
did not feel that senior command
necessarily had great facility with the
national framework for police
preparedness right yes and it's fair to
say that you as well became familiar
with that National framework during the
freedom Convoy I had seen it before when
I spoke of the group that asked to have
more members trained post the there was
a demonstration at Nicholas and Laurie
and they came back and provided me
feedback and they shared the framework
with me at that point in time I looked
at it you know supported what they were
trying to do and then put it you know on
the corner of my desk so it was
refreshed of its existence certainly
during the Convoy okay and I'm going to
suggest that uh the language that you've
used as you became familiar with the
national framework during the Convoy yes
okay
okay um
I'm going to turn now to uh the
integrated planning
group
um you gave evidence that the integrated
Planning Group support arrived on
February 8th yes and your evidence was
that at Chief slowly was um I think you
used the word suspicious of the group
and he was worried about politics right
that's your evidence yep okay and were
you aware on February 8th of the motion
that had been passed by city council the
day before on February 7th were you
following the Motions at city council at
this time I don't know which motion
you're referring to specifically so fair
enough on February 7th the motion was
Broad and passed by city council to have
the city ask the federal government to
assume responsibility for Public Safety
in the Parliamentary Precinct yes I'm
aware of that one okay so you were aware
at that point that something quite
political was happening right oh there
was lots of politics right okay
um and of course that never happened
because the motion uh was entirely
without jurisdiction right yes okay but
when again to be fair to Chief slowly
when this integrated Planning Group
arrives and you perceive him to be
somehow resistant or suspicious or
whatever words you're using
this is within 24 hours of emotion to
have the RCMP take over policing in the
Parliamentary Precinct right
yes okay yeah and so it's fair to say
that she slowly was dealing with a lot
including at the political level at this
time no doubt okay
I'm gonna ask you now
about uh this issue between the February
9th and the February 13th uh versions of
the plan
and
I'm going to ask if we could put up uh
email at
opp1547 please which is an email we
looked at this morning
foreign
if we scroll down to the bottom please
okay
um so you were asked about this email
and uh this is an email where Chief
slowly asks you to send him the latest
version of the operations plan that I
approved on February 9th right yes and
when you were giving your evidence this
morning when when first asked about
this email and this operations plan you
explained that this operations plan that
had been signed off on on the 9th had
been been taken by the integrated
planning team and they were refining it
and adding to it and making changes to
it right yeah I think they were building
it out they were building it out okay
and I think your evidence just got a bit
confused about the suggestion that there
was confusion that there were two
different plans right there there
weren't two different plans there was a
February 9th plan and it evolved into
the February 13 plan is that fair
um
they're two very different plans in
their final States so to say what was
happening at this stage in the game
would be unfair I think superintendent
Bernie could probably tell you that
piece in in Greater detail but the
commissioner shouldn't be left with the
impression that there were two
independent plans floating around and no
one knew how to reconcile them right
that wouldn't be fair well I think
further up I sent him the plan that he's
talking about and then the conversation
carries on about this integrated plan
that is being developed waiting for
signatories in that piece so it would
appear to me that there are two plans at
this stage but one may be the
predecessor of the
second right and and the difficulty in
this email that that I'm going to put to
you is that you had not been following
the status I shouldn't say you weren't
following I'm sure you were following
but you had not seen the February 13th
version or at this point
um yes the February 13th version yet
right I had not so what you sent Chief
slowly back was the one that you had was
the one that he signed off on on the
ninth and that you had yes right because
you didn't have the February 13th I did
not okay so
and I'm going to just take you uh now if
I could to Ops
at one zero four seven zero
and if you scroll down please
and this is sorry if you go up just a
little bit this is an email from
superintendent Lou I believe it is at
the RCMP that's correct
um and uh superintendent Lou refers to
the fact that he is working on the plan
and in the second sentence obviously
this plan originated with your plan
which We examined bolstered and
strengthened right yes and that was
consistent with your understanding of
what was happening yes
I'm going to turn now
um
to
the relationship
between the police service and the board
um
and Council you attended several board
and Council meetings with Chief slowly
both before and during
um the Convoy right I did
and when questions came up about
operations often Chief slowly would
defer to you and you would provide an
operational update yes
yes
and
it's fair to say that you and chief
slowly did that work and updated the
board together right yep and you were on
the same page about what sort of
information the board should have as to
the status of operations yes
foreign
I only have another minute so I'm going
to be fast I'm going to ask you now
about resources
um ultimately it took the additional
1800 officers that the Ops determined it
needed to clear out the occupation right
I think it actually took more than that
but yes okay it took more than that and
this was done without any Serious injury
or loss of life that's right
um and in partly in doing this the the
police used the powers given to the
police by the emergencies Act
yes I think it assisted
um I would say Grease the wheels of the
plan that we had in place yes okay fair
so it assisted you in executing the plan
yes
um because you use powers such as
threats of seizure of vehicles right yes
at threats of seizures of bank accounts
yes it helps you get tow trucks yes uh
it prevented uh it allowed you to
prevent assembly in the Red Zone yes
um so that things I think we can say
fairly resolved more quickly and more
safely because of those additional
powers
yeah and superintendent Bernie may have
more details on this I understand that
we did we had secured some tow trucks
but I would say you know in terms of the
plan that we had in place it allowed us
to
um to move with
with further confidence than we would
have had say without it we we may have
seen more challenges later on in court
but we were going ahead with that plan
anyway perfect and before the over 1800
additional resources arrived you'll
agree with me that the Ops did not have
sufficient resources to end the
occupation well agree with you okay
thank you I have no further questions
thank you
okay thank you
next uh up are the Convoy organizers
good afternoon acting Deputy Chief and
as I have been saying first thank you
for your service and thank you for your
forthright testimony already here that
you've given today I just need to
pull one very small thing before I begin
I'm just scrolling to it in my own
disclosure if you could first introduce
yourself oh yes I speak up a bit please
yes sorry sir uh Brendan Miller I am
counsel to Freedom Corp which is uh
Incorporated entity that represents the
protesters that were in your city in
January and February of 2022.
um so beginning
first uh with the area that I want to
chat with you about is the Hendon
reports
um
you said in your evidence in Chief that
acting Chief Bell's unit at the time
which I believe was Intelligence that's
right uh they were the ones that would
receive the Hendon reports correct yes
yes
okay
and it's fair to say that it would have
been now acting Chief Bell's
responsibility to pass those reports
onto the office of the chief and the
Chiefs and chief slowly that's who would
pass them on to him
I think what he would be passing on is
the products of what that unit worked on
to share up I don't think it was his job
to pass it up to the chief but
um the information would be assessed
analyzed and then passed up the chain
now we heard yesterday that Chief slowly
had to get the Hendon reports from the
opp directly in January of 2022 and
superintendent Morris found that odd
because the opp had been providing those
reports to Ops since project Hendon
started in early 2021. to your knowledge
where the Hendon reports not provided by
now acting Chief Bell or his Department
to Chief slowly
I don't know you don't couldn't comment
on that my understanding is that the
chief was receiving them as part of an
all chiefs sometimes that's how the
initial there's there's two separate
levels so he might have been receiving
it in that that's generally one of the
ways that the uh that information is
disseminated across the province
um but whether Chief Bell was getting
them and when he got them I don't know I
couldn't agree to that and so it's fair
to say that we'll have to just asked uh
Chief Bell or acting Chief Bell that
it's fair to say then that these Hendon
reports they went to someone likely in
Chief Bell's unit but not necessarily
Chief Bell yeah that's fair and then
that individual whomever received them
or group would then put together their
own product and then provide it to
either Chief belt and then Chief Bell
may or may not provide it to Chief
slowly fair fair okay thank you I just
want to get that clarified because it's
an important point
um I want to talk to you a little about
to the media reports and some of the
misinformation that was spoken about uh
yesterday
by a superintendent Morris
the media through reporting at times and
statements of elected officials reported
that the residents of Ottawa were
experiencing unprecedented violence do
you remember reading that I don't
remember reading that no all right
can you agree with me that there was not
an increase in violent crime or events
of violent crime in the city of Ottawa
during the protests before the
invocation of the emergencies Act
I don't think I can agree with you on
that I do believe we saw an increase in
in violence
I don't have the exact measures or the
the stats but I do know that we did see
some increase in violence and acts of
violence as a result of
the protest in town right and so I
understand that prior to the invocation
of the emergencies act between January
27th and February 14th
there was a total of only 13 charges
laid as against the protesters can you
agree with me on that can you repeat the
dates please between January 27th and
February 14th the invocation
so that charges were laid during that
time charges may have been latent in
terms of once the information was all
gathered then charges were laid after
and my understanding is there somewhere
upwards of 400 charges that were laid in
relation to the Convoy right and those
charges I understand the great majority
of them arose after February 14th with
respect to the enforcement
it wasn't for things that happened
during the time period prior to the
invocation is that fair no I think they
were acts that took place during that
time period when the Convoy was in town
but that the information was only able
to be solidified into a state where we
were able to lay charges right so would
acting Chief Bell be able to provide us
an accurate number for this commission
with respect uh to that question
I'm sure you could if he knows the
question now okay so well hopefully he's
able to do that because I believe that's
an important point
now I take it that during the protests
of course that the Ottawa Police Service
though they weren't at times enforcing
uh bylaws or weren't enforcing
provincial infractions they were
enforcing the criminal code in full
force and effect right
uh no I wouldn't say that I think we
were struggling to be able to do that
you're struggling but if a police
officer
saw an individual assaulting another or
there was a report of an individual to a
police officer that they had been
assaulted that was investigated yes
those individuals after that
investigation if it was appropriate
charges were laid against them yes in
many cases
now did Chief slowly at any time advise
you that he had been advised by RCMP
commissioner Brenda lucky on January
31st 2022
to not have the city of Ottawa get an
injunction because it's an official
movement to another stage this will
involve the whole country and anything
official will spark a national response
did he tell you about that
I was part of a conversation with
commissioner lucky and commissioner
karik I believe at the time I don't
remember those
facts specifically but I do remember
commissioner lucky
saying that it was it was a bit of a
double-edged sword getting an injunction
because
um you know then you would need to be
enforcing it and if you don't have the
resources right now to enforce all the
criminal codes and other offenses that
were being broken here then to get an
injunction sort of sets the expectation
for the community that you were then
going to be able to actually come down
and and enforce it and we didn't have
the resources there so there was
conversation for sure about it but I
don't know what her specifics what
you're saying whether that was
attributed to her or not right so I just
want to go through again you had
mentioned in your evidence and Chief and
under examination from my friend's
Council for Mr Sully that there were
certain Provisions with the emergencies
act order the ordering Council that
assisted removing the protesters I want
to deal with each so first is the threat
or the freezing of bank accounts all
right so I'd like you to turn your mind
to that
how many individuals whose bank accounts
were frozen to your knowledge
immediately exited the downtown of
Ottawa
all right
do you have any information that these
individuals who had their bank accounts
Frozen couldn't leave because they
couldn't pay to get out of Ottawa
anecdotally through the media some of
those stories but I'm not aware of any
specifics okay so with respect to that
can you agree with me that it was only
about 58 or 59 individuals who had their
bank accounts Frozen I can't actually
agree because I don't know those figures
I'm sorry and
dealing with some of the other
enforcement provisions
of course you can agree that the
emergencies act order did not
order an increase in officers for you to
remove the protesters
no would it
what it was um
there were some legislative things that
it was able to we were able to get our
CMP members here without swearing them
all in which was a bit of an
administrative
hurdle for us we were you know
struggling with that throughout the
Convoy with with the emergencies act
they were able to come and just be
police officers here without that step
okay and so that is one of the things
that sped it up but can you agree with
me that if there was an order once you
got the resources in place
if there was an injunction in place that
had the terms of removal
inside of it
that
these police officers could have done
the same thing couldn't they
yes they could have I think we had most
officers across Canada here right
so I just want to touch on them we've
talked a little bit about misinformation
and you know the evidence from
superintendent Morris yesterday was very
interesting he talked about
misinformation uh in detail and
misinformation in the media and it was
very enlightening and of course there's
still some misinformation going around
and you know even we have misinformation
we don't know what's true and what's not
so I'm going to ask you some questions
here I don't know what the answer to
this is going to be but it may or may
not be misinformation
did you tell any of your friends and
colleagues with an Ops that at some time
prior to you giving testimony here today
that you were approached by someone who
wanted you to give certain evidence that
was not true
no thank you
now I take it uh that you prepared in
advance for giving your evidence in this
proceeding in the sense as a police
officer would before they testify in a
trial or any proceeding yes I did right
and unlike regular Court proceedings
this proceeding is unique and there's no
exclusion of witnesses orders and in
fact the proceeding plays out online and
live on TV I take it you're aware of
that yes I am uh did you have the
opportunity and privilege to listen to
the evidence of uh superintendent Morris
before testifying today his was the one
I missed because I was intensely
prepping for today so
all right well I'm not going to ask you
about his evidence then and ask you to
confirm it if you haven't heard it but
can you agree with me that
superintendent Morris is the most senior
intelligence officer within the
provincial government in the entire
province of Ontario
I don't actually know that I believe
that but I don't know that that's
percent and you know he works hand in
hand with the Canadian Security
intelligence service the communications
security establishment and the Royal
Canadian Mount police you're aware of
that yes
yes and if anyone in the province within
the provincial and you know even
Municipal apparatus knows anything about
threats to the security of Canada it
would be him wouldn't it
I I don't know how to answer that I mean
I think that's speculative but uh he's a
very learned uh colleague in this regard
for sure yes those are my questions
thank you very much
thank you I'd like to denial call on the
city of Ottawa
good afternoon good afternoon my name is
Anne tardief I'm one of the lawyers for
the city of Ottawa
um
this morning acting deputy chief
why the Ottawa Police Service did not
proactively lock down Wellington and the
downtown core before the first trucks
arrived you recall being asked that
question yes in fact I think you were
asked several times In fairness to you
um are you familiar with the farmers
protest that I believe occurred in or
around 2006 peripherally yes okay and
you're aware that certain large farm
Vehicles like tractors came up and
protested on Wellington in front of
Parliament Hill I am aware of that yep
and my understanding is they came and
they left without incident is that in
accordance with your understanding as
well yes it is
and I expect that we will hear evidence
that Chief Ramer and I am I pronouncing
that right I am thank you Chief Ramer of
the Toronto Police Service
um that he's indicated that using Ottawa
they locked down the city of Toronto and
that had Ottawa not happened Toronto
police servic tactics would not have
been accepted and this was in relation
to tps's decision to lock down the area
around Queens Park after the convo had
arrived in Ottawa are you aware that
Chief Raymer has said that I am yes
and In fairness to you since In fairness
to you and the service I should say
since the events of the freedom Convoy
my understanding is that the police
working collaboratively with the city of
Ottawa have in fact locked down the area
of Wellington exercise their authorities
to close streets to prevent the event
from recurring is that correct that is
correct and I'm thinking for example of
Rolling Thunder yes yeah
and I think there was also a veterans
event around Canada day you're familiar
with those I am yes yeah
thank you
now
um I take it you're also aware that
during the freedom Convoy community
members in Ottawa were being harassed by
protesters in areas such as Kent Street
for example yes those are reports we
received okay
and for those who aren't quite familiar
with the geography of Ottawa fair to say
that Kent Street is on the periphery of
what later became known as the Red Zone
yes
and I also understand that while the
city and Ops were generally successful
in maintaining emergency lanes open and
clear there were some issues in that
respect is that fair there were um I
think probably after the first weekend
we struggled with that keeping them open
my understanding is that Kent Street
never had an emergency Lane open no it
didn't and that Wellington Street the
intended emergency Lane was in fact lost
during that first weekend yes it was
obviously that represents a public
safety concern you'd agree with that I
think deputy chief yes
so I just
raw timeline perhaps you can help me
here I think I've got it now the let's
start with the first weekend so the
first truck rolled in on January 28th
which was a Friday yep and that first
weekend January 28th to Sunday January
30th ops's plan the police services plan
focused primarily on traffic management
is that fair I think that's very and
you've described how on Monday January
31st when a number of the trucks did not
in fact leave
um the service pivoted and considered it
now the event that is to be a critical
incident
yes and an occupation an occupation
in other words not merely a traffic
event right
and you described this morning how by
February 4th that's the Friday of that
first week Ops still did not have a new
or evolved plan is that correct that is
correct
I think I I heard you say this morning
that during that first week there were
times in fact when the service was
floundering that's the word you use is
that fair yes it is
and by February 6 that's the date that
Chief slowly former Chief slowly pardon
me asked for 1800 additional resources
or officers is that correct I know he
made the ask I'm not sure of the date so
if you're saying the sixth then does
that sound about right yes yes I think
that's the evidence the commission has
heard to date
um
and I think I heard you say earlier that
in fact you believe more resources than
that were effectively needed to end this
Convoy occupation is that correct I
believe in the end it was somewhere near
2200 okay
um that same day February 6 the events
that you described at Coventry took
place yes in Pou that's the public order
unit they conducted some enforcement
there yes that resulted in arrests yes
and they did so without as I understand
it advising the police liaison team
that's right yeah came as a surprise to
police liaison team members
and that team I think you said felt
betrayed yes and the result of course
was a breakdown in the trust between the
police liaison team and the protesters
to a certain extent at least yeah there
was that impact these are you do think
there was I think that was yeah
and again for those of us who are uh
still learning about police operations
and don't have the experience you do is
I understand it that police liaison team
is the group that is primarily
responsible for communicating and
negotiating with protesters yes they are
so the breakdown in trust would be a a
significant event I would
categorize it as that yes okay
moving ahead February 8th we're now 11
days into the Convoy yes
we still don't have the almost 1800
resources that former Chief slowly has
requested no
and that turned out to be necessary
you'll agree with that yes we still
don't have if I've understood you
correctly a final operational plan no
he's not one that's been approved we're
working on it yeah or sorry or which
we're working on it you're working on it
fair enough and
um I think you'd agree with me that by
this time the force
it's probably exhausted yes mentally and
physically yes and you'll agree with me
that Ottawa residents particularly those
living on the periphery of the red so
those facing harassment noise pollution
so on so forth they're also frustrated
yes and they're also exhausted yes
and it's not an understatement in the
lease to say that things were dire by
that point I don't think that's an
understatement
you're aware that on February 8th the
Ottawa Police Service reached out to the
city manager whom everyone in this town
calls Steve K yes
to ask him to meet with protesters yes
and they felt your service felt it would
be a win for PLT to gain trust with the
truckers
I think we were looking for a win in
terms of movement of the trucks I don't
know if we were
positioning it as a win for PLT per se
oh sorry I guess what I meant was it's a
win in terms of re-establishing trust
with the truckers between authorities
and the truckers so that you can get to
a negotiated Solution that's fair right
I think you said earlier that um
you know that was the goal you in fact
had wanted to see that in the mission
statement that a peaceful negotiation
was the best outcome overall yes
yes
um Steve K agreed to work with police
and PLT and to meet with the protest
leaders
and then I understood that you were off
on February 11th and 12th did I get that
that's right so I won't ask you about
the events of those days and we'll we'll
jump ahead to February 13th I understand
that Steve K brief police about the
negotiations on February 13th is that
right yes you did
and he told you that we needed the
police at the table uh to confirm where
the protesters should Park what what
locations yeah for Logistics sorry which
for the legit for Logistics yeah that's
probably a better word
um and so he he wanted the police
because you were the police says who's
going to need to execute this on the
ground Fair yes Fair
and he wanted a senior Ops member
involved at that stage yes and as I
understand it uh former Chief slowly
assigned superintendent Drummond uh to
that task that's correct and that
meeting occurred on the evening of
February 13th I believe so with
superintendent Drummond at the table yes
I know we'll be hearing from him next
week so I'll I'll pick it up with him
there thank you very much acting death
thank you
thank you if I could Now call on the
Ottawa coalition
foreign
thank you commissioner
um good afternoon deputy chief Ferguson
my name is Paul champ I'm the lawyer for
the auto Coalition for residents and
businesses and I want to thank you very
much for coming today to answer some of
our questions
um I want to start uh deputy chief
Ferguson asking you about
uh the decision to allow the heavy
trucks to come downtown right at the
outset now we've heard previous evidence
from the city manager Mr kanalakos and
the mayor and and sure Deans that uh the
the police were telling them that that
it was the opinion of the auto Police
Service that you could not prevent the
heavy trucks from going downtown because
of the charter rights of those truckers
was that your understanding of what the
Auto police were telling the city of
Ottawa officials yes and uh was that a
legal opinion that the Ottawa Police
obtained
I don't remember if we obtained a legal
opinion on that
um I believe this was based on Decades
of of past you know experience in
managing events and that we have allowed
it in the past and we're going to again
in this case
notwithstanding the dramatically larger
scale on the larger number of like heavy
trucks
yeah I think we have had uh trucks and
as previously alluded to tractors in
that area of the downtown it's obviously
the sought after spot where people come
to protest
and this idea of vehicle protests or
Vehicles associated with protests you've
told us the Auto police services had
some experience with that before
um has the Ottawa Police uh is sought
input or guidance or expertise from
other police services about how they
manage large vehicle protests
not to my knowledge no that's possible I
know there is a whole network of
officers who
um you know go to conferences on public
order things and and I've been to one of
those so there there may be a network
and that might have happened already
there might be Police Services reaching
out to Ops now after this event I'm sure
yeah
um
deputy chief uh on January 26 we know
that you gave an interview to global
news is that right do you recall that
that's possible yes and you made a
comment uh to the media at that time or
global news that you expected the Convoy
protests uh could go on for a prolonged
period do you recall making a comment
like that I do and um by that uh you I
understand you're later suggesting that
by prolonged period you just meant like
the long weekend yes uh but isn't it
true deputy chief that by that time
there were in fact all kinds of I would
suggest a glaring indicators that these
protesters were coming here for a very
prolonged period isn't that fair
so there were indicators was I aware of
them at that time on the 26th when I
made that statement uh I I don't believe
I was but prolonged in my experience
being you know police officer in the
capital for 27 years prolonged was a
weekend for a protest
but this one was different deputy chief
you had a very very large number of
trucks that were coming from a long
distance right from from western Canada
correct yes and we'd had a similar one
um
believe in 2019. yeah some of the same
folks involved I think yes you might
hear about that later uh in these
hearings but nowhere near the numbers
correct well the numbers were something
that was fluctuating as they traveled
across the country and even right up
until the you know the three days prior
to them arriving in Ottawa my
understanding is the Hendon reports had
three different numbers
somewhere in the four high 400s then
five and a half and then uh ultimately
1300 I think was the last number that we
had prior to them arriving here
this one was also different I would
suggest Deputy uh Chief because uh it
was known and very publicly known that
they had in fact raised an enormous
amount of money to support this journey
uh and perhaps more given the amount of
money raised that made it different did
it not it did without knowing what that
money was going to be used for whether
it was going to support truckers who
could no longer work because they
couldn't cross the border or whether we
you know we could speculate as to what
that was for we didn't automatically
attribute it to being to support the
people who arrived in Ottawa well you
knew from the the GoFundMe page it said
for raising money for fuel and lodging
and uh and food for the protesters in
Ottawa you you're aware of that I didn't
know that no okay that might have been
the intelligence folks might not have
shared that
and um
also that the protesters had no exit
strategy you weren't but you weren't
aware of that at the beginning
uh no not at the beginning and and you
know to be fair I think there were
comments saying that they were planning
on leaving after the weekend and then
other ones that said the fourth I think
was given as a date and then there was
also information that there was no exit
strategy for some of them were planning
to stay but you would agree with him
deputy chief there were some indicators
that they were prepared to come here for
a number of weeks perhaps
I would agree yeah
and
um at the time of the first weekend at
least at that time unfortunately the
auto Police Service did not have a
contingency plan about how to manage
that for several weeks if we had a few
hundred trucks parked in downtown Ottawa
yeah we did not we were crossing our
fingers and hoping for the best at that
point and I don't mean I know there's a
lot of armchair quarterbacks the stage
deputy chief but um it was it was a bit
of a traumatic event for a lot of folks
downtown now
um
at one point the deputy or Pardon Me
Chief slowly said this is no longer a
protest it's an occupation and you've
told us uh today that the the protesters
have begun to entrench themselves and
you'd mentioned they had set up tents uh
but they also were started creating
wooden structures correct yes a number
of them at different locations yes there
were there were kitchens that were set
up
it's outdoor kitchens uh we know they
had uh different Fires at different
locations to keep the more multiple
locations I heard that yes
um they had Supply chains of fuel and
food from the the staging age uh saging
area Coventry to bring food and fuel
regularly downtown correct that's my
understanding yeah well the Auto police
was monitoring I gather those Supply
chains yes and you're also aware that uh
the the Convoy protesters had very
strong Logistics and and and uh
experienced people managing those listed
Logistics you're aware that they had
retired military and police managing
those Logistics yes
so over time it became quite clear the
auto Police Service was a serious
problem that they could well be here for
a very long time yes
and on uh the impact of downtown uh
there there was is it fair to say deputy
chief a fair amount of lawlessness in
downtown Ottawa at that time yes
aside from just the bylaws the parking
the idling open fires everywhere and
almost every intersection and so forth
correct yes uh fireworks were shooting
off banging off buildings and so forth
I've heard that yes large numbers uh
large numbers of propane tanks and Jerry
crowns were around downtown yeah
uh people were ignoring Public Health
regulations on masks
yes
and um we heard some questions around
other more uh serious
um crimes uh they're about assaults
um there were reports of assaults during
the the course of the protest there were
now those would have been I gathered
deputy chief difficult crimes to
investigate because they weren't uh in
situations where the victim and the
perpetrator don't know each other and
it's at a random place in the street I
gather that's very challenging for
police to investigate yeah sometimes to
identify the the subject or the accused
in the subject in the in the event yeah
right and in many cases isn't it fair to
say deputy chief that uh for uh
Ottawa citizens or residents who are
calling in saying they were assaulted
and making those reports the police
unfortunately couldn't do much more than
just take down the information correct
that's fair and that's that's really
what happened with the vast majority of
those cases I don't know if it's the
vast majority but I I would suspect
there's a large number that that is in
fact the case and there was also a large
number of people reporting threats being
threatened by the protesters correct yes
and in many cases when there wasn't
actually assault the police weren't even
necessarily taking uh police reports on
those because there's so many is that
right
I don't know that we weren't taking them
not everybody was calling us and we were
by the the second weekend we were
imploring people and in the press
conference that was done to please call
us we we would like to know about this I
know we had an influx of of calls around
the protest time but not all of them
were reporting some of them were
threatening our staff some of them were
um you know espousing their views on the
Convoy positive or negative so our lines
were were pretty jammed and it might
have been difficult for some people to
actually make those reports right yeah
this protest was kind of affecting
Ottawa on many levels uh we were our
public officials were receiving serious
threats as well correct correct that's
those are things that
Ottawa Police resources had to had to
deal with
yes as much as we could as much as we
could we also obviously we had the the
Deluge of fake 911 9-1-1 calls and uh
call bomb threats to our hospitals those
things happened yes making it difficult
on our ottawa's police resources yes
and uh deputy chief as well our uh the
police officers you've already told us
how exhausted they were working around
the clock uh some of them were also
reporting they were having concerns with
uh the sound uh and the diesel fumes
correct yes we actually
um engaged our Police Association
and got some
tools that were measuring the noise that
our officers were were being exposed to
along with air quality things so some of
the officers were wearing them on their
uniform so that we could assess just
what sort of impact it was having on on
their health because many of them were
complaining as it went along about how
loud it was and so yes yes
now just the final area deputy chief
about the the Ottawa Police and what was
happening with the Auto police at that
time now this this significant event it
occurred at a very difficult time for
the Ottawa Police Service as an
organization is that fair to say very
fair and you've you've indicated that
that there was a lot of retirements and
resignations at the senior levels at
that time yes
um we had a deputy chief who had been
suspended for a prolonged period of time
yes the deputy chief position that you
were occupying that was that was deputy
chief jaswell's spot yes it was and uh
for the previous two and a half years
there were rotating people through that
spot a number of different officers
inspectors McKenna Ford Burnett uh I
think rayon Dunlop Drummond all of you
occupied that position for some period
of time
um
McKenna Ford rotated back and forth over
several months at a time for a period of
I think probably about 18 months and
then yes superintendent Dunlop was was
there I think he was the only those were
the only three
and and other senior officers had
resigned or retired at that time so
you'd lost some of some of the normal
robustness that this knowledge and
subject matter experts yes right
and there was also the issue was that
not deputy chief that there were some uh
there was a
a lot of uh people within the auto
Police Service who who dislike the chief
and were not not very happy with the
chief's leadership is that fair to say
um
there was definitely some dissension and
I don't know what all the reasons for
leaving were but it was a
time where I would say we were pretty
divided exhausted and I don't know there
was as I said a number of people who
left but they they were able to because
they had their years in and it was a
good time with pandemic restrictions
lifting I think a lot of them went on to
do whether it was travel or do other
things so right well we know in the
midst of this a deputy chief though of
this Convoy not only did did Chief
souley end up resigning but prior to
that there was a CBC story that was
coming out uh critical of his leadership
that apparently came from those within
the auto Police Service you recall that
I do I think it was Convoy related
though like it was it was from incidents
that occurred during the Convoy and and
prior but do you think that those who
leaked that information they were trying
to undermine uh Chief solely or wanted
to see him fail
I don't know what their motives were but
I think it had that impact
okay
and just the last last thing here uh
deputy chief now you've testified you've
given us evidence that you yourself had
some concerns with the decision making
and actions of Chief slowly at times yes
I did and uh your concerns about that
grew over time as the Convoy progressed
yes I think that's fair and you were
aware that the and we're going to hear
evidence of this that the opp and and
others from the other uh police services
also had some concerns in that regard
yes and now did you discuss these
concerns with deputy chief Bell at any
time like as the two you know executive
command uh under the chief did the two
of you discuss these concerns that were
being raised into your own observations
about Chief slowly
um
um I remember deputy chief bell saying
make sure that you you know keep the
chief informed that's going to be you
know the best way to make sure that he
is you know satisfied with what is going
on so make sure that that communication
um goes to him as as often as possible
and that was more of a sort of
you've stepped into the deputy role
here's here's what's expected I don't
know that we had much conversation about
the chief per se I mean we were both up
to our next in in operations and things
so
um so it never got to the level of
concern that the two of you were
expressing concerns to each other about
your confidence and the the chief's uh
decision-making abilities at that time
no I don't think so
um and if you had would that what would
you have done uh was that something that
you and deputy chief Bell could have
perhaps raised but the uh the Police
Services Board perhaps
yeah I guess if that's where we were
if we'd had that conversation them or
ocpc I think would be Terra civilian
police commission yes yeah and uh just
finally on um the integrated command uh
once the integrated command occurred
that's when the resources really began
to flow correct yes so it seemed that
there were some concerns by other police
services that they they didn't want to
provide significant resources when it
was under exclusively the command of the
auto Police Service I'm not sure what
their reluctance was
um but when we did start to work you
know collaboratively with the other
services the flow of information and the
requests were much quicker and so deputy
chief is Affair to say that had there
been a shift to the integrated command
much sooner
uh in this event
perhaps the actions that were finally
taken to clear out the protest could
have occurred sooner is that fair that's
fair thank you very much deputy chief
thank you next is the government of
Canada
hi my name is Carolina verzia I'm one of
the council for the government of Canada
um
you uh mentioned in your witness summary
that uh
Ops would not have been able to manage
the or resolve effectively the Convoy
occupation in Ottawa uh without the
invocation of the emergencies act
correct
so I think my my at the time of my
statement I was under the impression
that things like tow trucks that was the
only way we were going to be able to to
get them
I may be corrected by superintendent
Bernier I think they did have some lined
up and they were on their way just prior
to us beginning our our actions but I
think
as I stated before that I think the
emergencies act
um
made us more confident in in the
approach we were taking and enabled us
to
um you know get get past uh the issues
of whether it was the seizing of assets
I think that was helpful in terms of
setting a tone for some of the people
who may be deterred by that and the tow
trucks specifically was the the piece
that I remember being very helpful and
you know the Red Zone we were we were
moving in there regardless but the
emergencies Act was helpful excellent
one aspect of that I want to further
develop develop with you and it um uh
Builds on what you previously said about
PLT and its role in managing uh protests
and in this case an occupation
um
there was a lot of talk or or actually
things written in the final plan that
was approved on February 13th about PLT
negotiation but also there was a focus
on the uh objective of shrinking uh the
footprint of the protests and occupation
that that assessment is correct that is
yes
and um
uh
my
understanding is that shrinking the
footprint would in and it involves
having people leave on a voluntary basis
before for example pous are brought at
the Forefront to remove forcibly remove
people right that's correct we were our
PLT team was engaged in a notification I
guess campaign you would say where they
were advising people that you are now
breaking the law we you will be arrested
if you stay you are being you know
provided the opportunity to leave and I
think we did that over a series of you
know 12-hour periods increments
increments and then eventually moved in
and it did it was somewhat successful in
shrinking the footprint okay and to just
let let's stay on that notice of
protesters for a little bit there
um
in that notice Ops did provide
information about if you're staying your
vehicles and property may be seized or
towed correct that's quite possible yes
and um uh building on what you just said
but also referring to your witness
summary uh it seems like you were
convinced at the time that uh
communicating that information to
protesters would be would have the
effect of of of deterrence or convincing
them to leave voluntarily because you
thought that people would not would not
want to have their vehicles or property
seized and if I
um uh I don't think I have the quote and
I won't take the time to do it but I I
it's you said it was their life Lifeline
or
very important there in their life and
so it would move them if they knew that
there was a very real Prospect of
actually being able to tow the vehicles
and seize the property right yes for
many of them it was their livelihood
their truck yeah and uh also for
deterrent purposes these notices
contained information about the
prohibition to travel to or within the
restricted zones which was designated as
unlawful demonstration demonstrations
right that's right yeah
um there was also something about anyone
traveling to Ottawa for the purposes of
taking part in the Ottawa Convoy
occupation would actually be breaking
the law right yes
um
the notices to protesters also included
language clearly telling protesters that
if they stayed their personal or
business accounts may also be subject to
restrictions right that's right yeah and
uh
and the uh the question about bringing a
minder to protests was also included and
and some of the these notice to
protesters actually stated that if you
brought a minor to this unlawful Pro
protests uh you could be fined up to
five thousand dollars and potentially
spend five years in prison right uh that
might be true I don't remember details
yeah
and um just circling back to what you
said in the very beginning of my
examination but you you agree with that
St with the I you would agree that uh as
of February 17th the the the size or the
footprint of the protest in Ottawa had
significantly
uh uh been reduced yes I would thank you
no
no further questions okay
thank you
and democracy fund
um at the outset here I'd like to ask
for uh lee read a sentence from the
witnesses interview summary I won't do
that right away but I figured I'd ask
now so as not to disrupt whatever flow I
can muster well I think I think that
would be fine it's been entered in
evidence so all right if if she needs it
that can be brought up sure
um good afternoon acting deputy chief
I'm Rob kittridge Council for the
Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms good afternoon
um as I understand your testimony
earlier there were only two ways in
which the invocation of the emergencies
Act was of use to police in ending the
Freedom Movement protests one it
bypassed the requirement to swear in
officers from other jurisdictions which
saved a bit of time and two it helped to
procure the services of heavy rig tow
truck operators is that uh Fair
characterization of your testimony of my
testimony yes I do believe though the
seizing of assets was also helpful they
uh can you expand on that so the threat
of seizing assets of oh right bank
accounts and Rigs and things like that
okay
useful but not necessary
yeah useful but not necessary
um how much time did not having to swear
in officers from other jurisdictions
actually save
I don't know could you give uh would it
be on the order of hours or days or
um
probably hours uh and I don't know how
many of them we had already done at that
point in time but a number of hours
administrative uh probably you know
people being involved in that and filing
paperwork right so it sidesteps and
paperwork and headaches and a few hours
yeah all right
um I'm interested in what steps were
taken by police to obtain towing
services prior to the invocation of the
emergencies act can you describe the
efforts made by the city and police to
procure towing services before that date
I don't have all the details of that I
think probably uh inspector Lucas would
be able to assist in that potentially
superintendent Bernier the information
that I had at the early stages we didn't
think the tow trucks were going to be an
issue until we looked to try it and
procure some uh and we have contracts
obviously with with some companies in
town and when push came to shove they
refused to uh to engage uh and so at
that point in time I don't know what
stage we were in the Convoy if this was
after the weekend or leading up to the
weekend
um and so when we looked at what our
options were for heavy uh tow I I do
recall a number of conversations about
that and that we believed OC transport
might have had a couple of heavy tow
trucks that we could potentially use but
I think that was it
right
um despite the fact that your answers
may be that you weren't aware of the
details I'm going to walk you through a
series of uh carefully crafted questions
here that I don't want to throw away
um how many uh towing service providers
did the police contact I don't know
um we've heard that some towing services
were concerned about driver safety did
you offer to ensure that police would
accompany Towing operators to ensure
their safety I don't know what offers
all right we've heard that some towing
services were concerned about damage to
their vehicles did you offer to
compensate them for damage to their
vehicles I don't know what options all
right isn't it true that pursuant to the
and I it occurs to me that I'm probably
torturing the sign language interpreters
um so I'll slow down uh isn't it true
that pursuant to the highway traffic act
police officers do not require a license
to operate any motor vehicle in the
performance of their duties
oh I don't know about that I'm not sure
I'll put it to you that it is true okay
um
if uh so in other words if you're not
going to be able to answer this but I'll
put it to you that if police officers
you could try and focus on questions she
can answer I mean I I appreciate you've
prepared them but sure you know all
right not sure it's it's helpful to the
commission all right
um
so I guess uh I'll skip right to the end
here and say you stated earlier that you
did have tow trucks lined up and that
they were on their way to Ottawa prior
to the invocation of the emergencies act
isn't that true yes
um and your interview summary says that
uh Ops knew that if it arrived with tow
trucks many protesters would leave
because the trucks were their home and
livelihood do you stand by that
statement I do all right those are my
questions thank you
thank you next is the Ottawa Police
Service
good afternoon Deputy Ferguson good
afternoon uh you obviously are familiar
with me but for the record my name is
Jessica Barrow and I represent the
Ottawa Police Service
I only have a few things that I would
like to cover with you this afternoon
okay so I want to start by talking about
some of the comments that were made by
you in response to questions with
respect to those protesters that came
the ones that stayed and the ones that
left
um is it your understanding that Ops has
filed an Institutional report in
relation uh to this commission yes
are you familiar with it I am
are you prepared to adopt the content of
that report yes I am I would like to
pull it up uh the numbers ops.ir dot I
believe it's seven zeros one
and if we could turn specifically to
page 13.
what do you understand this chart to
represent
so that looks like the
um the number of vehicles that rolled
into town and the dates
um
and
the people
and where they sorry it's I think it's
just the vehicles
um and and the areas that they were
whether they were at Parliament whether
they were on Wellington
um an Elgin burrito
I think if you read uh para f44 as well
it may assist in understanding uh what
specifically is set out in that chart so
I yeah I think the individual protesters
are the ones that are under Parliament
um
and then the
Vehicles yeah so the vehicles are listed
in the thousands and and the people are
estimated at five to six thousand on
January 29th
so we've heard a lot about the vehicles
in particular
um and the fact that they had not left
um what do we see as between January
31st and February 1st in terms of the
number of vehicles that are listed
starts to dwindle from thousands to six
however High 600s and down to as low as
481
and then builds back up
would you say that this chart aligns
with your experience at the time in
terms of the Ebbs and flows of of the
trucks I would yeah
could we now please turn to page 33
I and I'm bringing this to your
attention in response to some questions
that we heard earlier what do you
understand this chart to be so this is
our the total Char charges that were
laid and the types of offenses that were
charged during the Convoy or that
occurred during the Convoy if we scroll
to the bottom of that chart does this
demonstrate how many charges in total
arose out of the events of the Convoy
if you go I guess it's still on the next
page actually yeah
yeah
yes
as well does it demonstrate how many
charges were laid per day it does and if
I'm sorry if we could go back to the top
of the chart
does it demonstrate how many charges
relayed in relation to Violent offenses
yes it does
so the assaults
um
the
yeah the assaults of carrying weapons
it's a variety of different offenses
obviously in the list here
and can you see whether charges were
laid During the period of the beginning
of the Convoy through to when they
ultimately left
yes I could see that for example the
weekend of the 17th 18th 19th which I
believe was when we were doing most of
the clearing of the streets 11 piece of
public officers were assaulted during
that time
great thank you
I want to turn to another issue that has
been discussed with both commission
Council as well as Council for former
Chief slowly and that is the request
that was made by Chief slowly for a PLU
plan do you recall that evidence yes
and do you recall evidence in relation
to a meeting that occurred on February
1st with respect to that plan yes
did that Pou plan materialize
ultimately it did not
from the people who he was initially
tasked with right and you spoke earlier
in your testimony about Pou being one
part of a larger plan yes I have that
right that's right can you explain uh to
the commission a little bit more about
how Pou would fit into a larger
operational plan
so um it's one component obviously if we
get to a position where we are no longer
able to We Shrunk the footprint as as
much as we can through negotiations or
just through whether it's threats of
charges and people have decided that
they've had enough when they're leaving
then Pou would be they would have a plan
to the approach that they were going to
take you know in this case they had six
or seven intersections some large ground
to cover so how they would go about
doing that and it was you know the plan
ultimately that they had was down to
line by line as to you know what time
they would move in which direction of
travel they would be going in how they
would contain it
um
the first of February the chief two of
the PLT sergeants and myself met with
these Pou commanders who had been in
um in Ottawa and I'm not sure if some of
them were left over from the weekend
because they had their teams here but
these were commanders who
um had some expertise in in executing
Pou actions but not necessarily in
creating plans and so when they were
tasked with at that point in time what
was a colossal
area to cover I got the sense from the
group that they were and I certainly
know I
communicated back and forth with our
staff surgeon that it was
um
mind-boggling I think would be a good
term they just couldn't uh you know this
was would have been the largest public
order movement in Canada and that's
actually what it turned out to be
and they said when we initially spoke
with them how do you think we could
execute this and they said we would need
every public order unit or section in
the country to be able to clear the
streets the way they are now and that
was in the first of February so I think
senses that they struggled with trying
to come up with a plan on its own in you
know just
six of them sitting around a table and
at a hotel in Canada I think was was
troubling for them
would it normally be the case that a Pou
plan would be created in isolation from
other plans no
would it normally be the case that it
would be created in advance of all other
aspects of the plan no
be in concert with the rest of the plan
can we turn please to document Ops 6085
and if we could just scroll down a
little bit there's an email there
from superintendent dhamma to yourself
as well as a few others right yes and
you can see it's dated February 2nd and
perhaps you could just take a minute to
read that and my question to you in
relation to that is what did you
understand the concern to be at this
time from superintendent Dunlop
so he was tasked with being a bit of a
liaison with the POU and PLT teams and
um
I had been asking at the behest of the
chief for this plan and were they
willing to come and present to him what
they how they foresaw this this
occurring
um and so this I think was in response
to another one of my asks saying uh
where are we with the plan are we uh you
know any issues and so his response here
was saying that he met with him all
afternoon and this would have been the
following day
um and I'm not sure what the
recalibration he's referring to but
um he's recommending that we meet again
and discuss the approach and when he
talks about neighborhood issues I think
he was talking about some of the things
that our our communities were facing and
whether that was
um you know noise pollution there was
you know people were were defecating on
lawns those types of things and he was I
think his approach here was if we can
focus on those and improve that
situation for those people
um that would probably go a long way to
reduce you know the the impact on the
communities
after this email or perhaps before I
suppose
were the concerns in relation to the
scope of the ask that was being directed
to them raised with Chief slowly
yes I believe it was
um
he
the uh one of the commanders had asked
for a mission statement they really
wanted to be able to understand what it
was he was asking because again I I
think it was that mind-boggling enormous
task that that he was expecting of them
and I I don't want to speak for them but
I don't know if they knew where to start
with that
would it normally be the case that um a
plan such as this would be drafted by
the people that were being asked to
draft it
um no I think it would be in conjunction
with people who are who are excellent at
planning and writing plans with being
fed the subject matter experts
earlier in your testimony in response to
a question from Council for former Chief
slowly you referenced the request for a
Pou plan as compared to other types of
plans and use the word fixated when
describing uh Chief slowly's attitude
towards the POU plan can I ask you to
explain a little bit what you meant when
you used that word
I think that he valued this plan
and anticipated this plan more than any
other is is what I would
say to that
I'm going to move on now uh to the
expectations of the committee community
and city council and we've heard some
evidence about that you've been asked
some questions about that
we heard Evans in relation to the level
of communication or perhaps the lack
thereof in some people's minds between
the police and city council can you tell
us about the extent to which the police
and you personally were in touch with
City councilors
so I was contacted on a number of
occasions by a counselor Fleury he had
my phone number he texted me fairly
regularly sought for the opportunity to
meet he requested I attend his Bia
meeting almost every evening during the
sick of the Convoy and many times I was
in fact I don't think I ever made one of
the meetings we did communicate back and
forth but we did have a superintendent
and inspector who were designated to be
Liaisons with the counselors they also
had their Community police officers who
were very present and very engaged with
all of that so
um on a one-on-one basis councilor
Fleury was was somebody who I
communicated with a fair bit
and then the council meetings we were
obviously all present for those and some
of them lasted for hours and many
questions posed of us and some things we
were able to answer and some things we
weren't and and some of it was just a
venting session I think and explaining
that they were they were very frustrated
with the situation in in the city
kind of along those same lines we've
heard from multiple witnesses that there
was a feeling from the community uh that
there was insufficient presence and
enforcement by police officers during
this time period
and we've also heard some evidence about
some enforcement actions that were taken
what was the impact from your
perspective of enforcement actions that
were taken by police during this time
um I think we were doing them to
um try and show the community that we
were we were present and we were in the
communities I think it was very
difficult for us because it sent us in a
variety of different uh directions where
if we had been able to
um
really come that that straight path to
get to the plan and get to those things
so our Frontline officers we were still
policing the rest of the city
and we were trying to figure out how to
position people here so that there was a
presence and people felt uh somewhat
safe but there was lots of things that
our members were being tasked with and
and responding to you know fire barrels
and things within the the zone of uh you
know the red zone
um
so I think you know things like
interdiction of Jerry cans of gasoline
um that was
very
troubling for you know in terms of the
reaction of of the people in there and
it was difficult for our members because
in order to be able to do that
effectively you needed a number of
officers
um because they were getting swarmed
they were getting
um you know intimidated they were they
were you know sometimes hundreds of
people and I I watched it happen on a
few of the street cameras to see it
happening and it was frightening and so
our members were not comfortable doing
that and I respected the fact that they
they had the discretion and and on
occasions they said this puts our our
people at risk and we are you know
there's not enough of us out there to be
able to to do this effectively
uh those are my questions thank you very
much Deputy thank you
any re-examination no more examination
thank you
well deputy chief thank you for coming I
I just have a couple of very quick
questions I'm just trying to understand
a bit
about plts that you talked about and uh
would I be correct in in saying that
they are intended to stop the
lawlessness and
turn the
protest into something that is
legal or not disruptive it would be an
objective of PLT that could be one of
them when I talked about places where
there's antagonizers and agitators
we would go to the PLT to to say you
know this person is is causing your car
it's creating issues for your cause in
this case we were hoping that they would
be able to do that prevent people from
honking and and all of those actions
that they were taking but also to leave
so twofold
and to leave I.E leave where they're
disruptive yeah yes now in terms of the
the process here and
I think I saw somewhere in your
testimony that
by the Monday you you called it an
occupation it moved from a protest to an
occupation yes was there any discussion
or thought given to
how to allow the protests to continue in
some form because as opposed to it it
seems and I'm not putting words in your
mouth like it was from black to white or
white to black however you want to call
it it was a protest okay you're okay
till the end of the day Sunday but
now it's an occupation do you understand
what I'm trying to get at I do
understand and um
I'm not sure if there was any
conversation about that from our some of
our site managers and PLT teams so uh
inspector Lucas may be in a position to
be able to tell you what was going on
there I know from a command and
strategic level it was that they're here
and now they're entrenched and they're
not leaving so that's where it switched
from
from a protest to occupation
so there was no part of the plan
to allow a continuing or to encourage
the protesters to in some way
and and I realize that there are a lot
of trucks a lot of problems but to move
towards something that was because as I
understand it there were there were a
lot of people who were protesting who
weren't violent and were not problematic
would that be fair
um I think that would be fair yeah I I
I don't want to speculate I don't know
whether those conversations were
happening
um and the PLT may have been engaging in
those and saying like if we if we bring
it from you know Metcalf to wherever on
Wellington is that sufficient I do know
there were a number of trucks who were
in other parts of the city who very much
wanted to get to Parliament Hill they
wanted to be on Wellington and they were
upset because they tended to be some of
the trucks that came from
Far West and they were the last ones to
get here and the good spots were taken
and so I know there was conversations
with
um some of those uh folks Convoy
organizers who said you know we've been
cooperating with you this whole time and
then all of the great spots were were
taken but we weren't you know taking
names and reservations for spots on on
Wellington so
okay well thank you very much thank you
for coming and thank you for your
testimony
I think what we'll do is take the
morning break now and or morning break
I'm sorry
I'm I'm hinting you're going to be here
a long time but no that's uh that's a
just a slip of the tongue sorry so we're
going to take the afternoon break so
we'll take 15 minutes and let the
everyone have a uh get their stand up
and get a little exercise so 15 minutes
please
anyway says for 15 minutes
order a lot
the commission has reconvened the
commissioner prom
okay good afternoon everybody
just before we call the next witness uh
just to give you an update
for Council and for those who are glued
to their computer at home uh we're
planning to go ahead with the next
witness who
I believe will be two hours or so and
then we'll adjourn for the day so we'll
give you an early day
uh tomorrow at the moment it appears
it's not going to go very late it will
be a bit shorter than normal for those
who want to make arrangements so just to
update you on
on the plan so far so with that
introduction uh go ahead thank you
commissioner for the record Eric bruso
commission Council and the commission
would like to call its next witness OPP
superintendent Craig Abrams
foreign
[Applause]
superintendent Abrams will you swear on
a religious document or do you wish to
affirm I swear in the Bible please
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Craig Abrams a r a
m is in Michael S is in sand
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God
principles
if I could have a document WTS six
zeros13 please
superintendent Abrams I'm showing you a
copy of your interview summary from when
you attended an interview this summer I
take it you've seen this document I have
okay and you reviewed it when you signed
off on its accuracy I did okay and it
remains accurate to the best of your
knowledge it does okay thank you and you
have no Corrections or additions to make
to it I have no Corrections okay thank
you
um
and superintendent I I take it you have
more than 20 years of experience with
the opp is that right 27 years correctly
seven okay could you just very briefly
in a couple of minutes walk us through
your your background certainly um I
spent
um 12 years at Detachment central region
five years in uniform seven years as a
detective constable
two and a half years as a detective
sergeant in our Professional Standards
Bureau in east region
nine months as a detective Sergeant at a
local crime unit at Brockville Ontario
and then with our provincial criminal
investigations Branch I spent three and
a half years there as a staff sergeant
and executive inspector and then
transfer to east region criminal
operations for a couple of years and
then became a superintendent in my
current role for the past six years
and your your current role is
superintendent of operations operations
for the east region is that right
correct made a minor title change we're
all called field operation
superintendents now okay and in that
current role you were in that role at
the time of January and February 2022.
so I apologize yes at the time I was
director of operations yes and what does
that role entail specifically So within
each region we have a chief
superintendent and two superintendents
we have 16 detachments
um so I took care of eight attachments
operationally and took care of their
needs I also took care of criminal
operations as well as traffic in this
period of time and who did you report to
at that time Chief superintendent Carl
Thomas
and I want to ask you about
a critical incident command
um I take it you're not formally trained
as a critical incident Commander is that
right that's correct I'm a trained
Incident Commander I've not taken the
critical instance Commander course okay
you've um
you've sat in on it I believe I have
most of our critical coincident
commanders are of the inspector rank so
as a superintendent I signed in on one
of their courses so I could understand
what they were being instructed on so
that's how I obtained some of that
knowledge in observing those courses
okay
um and before the the freedom Convoy
events what was your experience in
policing wide scale protests
um at various ranks of it was involved
in at least a handful of different
protests or blockades primarily in the
titanaga Milwaukee area I was a
strategic Commander for the Titan anger
rail blockades in 2020. and then
strategy Commander for this current
event here for the opp
okay and I was going to ask you about
sort of what that means to be strategic
Commander for an event if you can
describe that for us
certainly like you heard the witness
this morning she very eloquently
described the structure system as how it
works you have a strategic operational
and tactical so in my role as a
strategic Commander my role is to help
facilitate the critical incident
commanders that are at the operational
level if they have exceptional needs or
resources they'll come to me and I'll
try to make that available to them my
role also is as a to create situational
awareness for OPP command and brief OPP
command regularly as to what's occurring
it's
I also have some oversight on the
command and control just to make sure
that what our mission we're trying to
accomplish is going to be successful so
I oversee that command and control and I
also um
look at those areas try to mitigate any
risk that might be involved in our
operations many of our critical incident
commanders are obviously very focused on
the jobs they're doing but may not be
aware of what's occurring around the
outside of them and that's my job to
make sure their understanding of
any political issues or other issues
that might be going on outside that
could affect what they're operating on
it's kind of my job to bring that to
their attention
okay and you had a significant amount of
sort of decision-making authority over
this event I take it not in an
operational capacity
um I had decision making Authority in
relation to
when this event started this was a
traffic event for the opp so my job was
to create an instant command team to be
able to represent their OPP on the
arrival of the Convoy Vehicles so that
was my role initially as strategic
Commander to make sure that the
organization was well suited and
prepared for the arrival of the trucks
okay and you use the term traffic event
there can you
um describe that for us certainly so as
we saw it
um as we've heard in evidence I mean new
vehicles are traveling from across the
country from the East and the west and
from Northern Ontario
to converge here in Ottawa well to get
to Ottawa you have to travel through OPP
jurisdictions primarily
So within east region we have many
jurisdictions on Highway 17 provincial
Highway 417 which are OPP responsibility
I had to make sure that those small
communities were prepared for the large
influx of Convoy vehicles and protesters
so I had to create a team that could
support those communities and then also
how to create a traffic plan as to how
we're going to manage the vehicles on
the highway as you heard I think from
superintendent Morris there is that
concern or there's are they gonna
blockade highways that are going to be
damaged to highways possibly so we need
to have a strategy in place to manage
that if it was to occur so we used our
provincial Highway blockade strategy I
had an Incident Commander create
operational plan to prepare for the
arrival of the trucks and as part of
that plan we communicated with the city
of Ottawa Ottawa Police Service to
figure out how can we support them in
that because they obviously had a plan
for where they want these vehicles to be
and since we controlled the 417 and the
on and off ramps they needed our support
and so we had to work together on them
okay and and we'll get into that um but
just to go back to one thing you said
you talked about uh assisting smaller
communities sort of along the way are
these communities that are policed by
the OPP or would they have their own
Municipal Force yes please buy us so
specifically the communities of our
Empire and Castleman Castleman to the
east arm prior to the north we knew that
they're overnighting in those
communities and we did have situations
where there was attention at some
restaurants were Convoy participants
maybe not comply with the mask mandates
at the time
so we had business owners calling asking
for OPP assistance so I had to prepare
my members to be prepared okay this is
what you may see
um so do we have a system in place to
help support the citizens and make sure
that they remain safe and uh
we know that they're only going to be
there for the one night but we needed to
make sure we had bolstered members to
assist in that capacity okay
and I also understand that you set up or
to use the police term sort of stood up
the Emergency Operations Center can you
describe that for us correct many times
in these major events you have to have a
command post you have to have somewhere
to work out of So within east region
headquarters which is located in Smith's
Falls Ontario we have a room which is
called Emergency Operations Center and
so we have a place for all the parties
that help participate in these events so
traffic Services PLT media relations
criminal operations incident command
scribes that all sit in that room and
focus on that one task of completing the
mission and that's kind of where we try
to have a unified command sitting in
that one location and I'm available to
them when they need me
and you mentioned that you were
coordinating with various police
agencies but I want to ask you about the
Ops now when uh when did you start
coordinating with the Ops
to plan for this event right and January
24th I was asked to be the Strategic
Commander for the opp in relation to the
traffic event and then I would see at
least that day or the day after I called
Deputy Bell and said this is my role
what can we do to assist you and then we
had
intersect calls which I can explain if
you like what what intersect is and on
those calls we discussed where Vehicles
would park and how the OPB could support
the influx of the vehicles later in that
week I I do want to ask you about
intersect I also just
um I was reminded that I I wanted to ask
you just to slow down we have
interpreters and translators so I will
make an effort to speak slowly and they
appreciate that as well
um and so you mentioned intersect so if
you could describe that for us sure it's
a multi-jurisdictional all hazards
emergency preparedness group that
focuses on the national capital region
it's been in place for for many years
now I've been part of intersect for over
four years
and there's over 60 clients that are
connected to intersect and we talk about
many different pillars Health cyber
terrorism law enforcement and we have
regular monthly meetings and phone calls
and there's also subgroups of intersect
one of them being law enforcement where
we meet and have discussions
I want to say it was January 24th I
emailed um
I apologize I'll go back quickly the
intersect program is chaired by the
Ottawa Police Service co-chair by Ottawa
Police Service this set did you go back
and the RCMP and currently they have a
civilian kind of a programmer that runs
the program that Ottawa Police provides
her name is Kim stirrup
so he emailed Kim earlier in the week
because I'd heard about
um I unfortunately was away from the
workplace for two weeks prior to the
24th and I knew that we regularly met
when major events were coming to
national capital normally we would talk
to each other and I hadn't seen an
invite for a meeting so I emailed her
and said I think we should get the group
together and have discussions about how
we're gonna because this is all going to
affect us so she generated that
a meeting invite and we had a meeting
um shortly thereafter okay and
going back to the 24th start of the the
coordination like what did that look
like in terms of coordinating with Ops
what were you doing
so I was I spoke with uh Deputy Bell and
I also worked with my I had my traffic
inspector connect with the Ottawa Police
traffic inspector to say okay you guys
need to work out a traffic angle and
then report up to to myself as and The
Incident Commander as to what we can do
to facilitate the traffic
right you have to come up with a traffic
plan so that inspector Dave tovel is the
one who wrote the operational plan for
the opv response to this event that was
supposed to occur over a single day
and um he worked with his counterpart
with Ottawa Police to make sure that we
were supporting them in the way they
needed it
um
that you say the opp response was you
know it was planning for a single day
event
um why is that
I should back up sorry obviously it was
a multi-day in our purposes because they
were stopping overnight in our prior the
night before so it was more than one
night but we expected the majority of
the vehicles were going to make their
way into the city of Ottawa on one
particular day so that was kind of the
day we wanted to make sure we had all
the resources available to prepare for
road vehicle stoppages Road blockages
those types of things and our
provincial liaison team as the
commission has heard about they were
engaged with many of the Convoy leaders
and they talked about roads or routes
they would take and they would only take
up one lane of 417 it wouldn't take up
all the lanes and then Ottawa Police
told us what off ramps that they wanted
us to have them go off at so we work
with our partners with the MTO and
ourselves to make sure we had those
ramps ready for their arrival
okay
um and so maybe I just I want to make
sure I understood you correctly when you
say a one day event you're talking about
one day where a lot of vehicles will be
converging on Ottawa
correct is that correct the majority
arrived in The Villages of our parent
custom in the night before they
overnighted there and the plan was the
next morning to make their way into the
city of Ottawa right right
um and I believe you uh you were
familiar with Hendon reports it was
um as superintendent Moore spoke about
Hendon originated many years ago not
just because of this event and because
of my involvement in many of the
indigenous protests and my role I have
been on the end in email distribution
list for many years so I received all
those sending reports not only for this
period of time but also in the past okay
and were you reviewing them as they were
coming out yes like I said for the for
the two-week period of January 11th to
the 22nd I was away from the workplace
and when I returned I reviewed my emails
and caught up on my ending reports upon
my return from work
um but yes I've reviewed the ending
reports as they came in because they
directly impacted our planning I saw
what we were going to do to make sure
that we had all our angles covered in
case something from the report indicated
that there might be a problem in the
village of armpire or there might be all
into intelligence indicates there might
be problems in castlemen those are
things I needed to know and my Incident
Commander needed to know so we reviewed
them religiously okay
um and I understand Castleman and arm
arm prior are sort of very areas under
OPP jurisdiction where you would
have a particular attention but did you
have an understanding or a view of what
was going to transpire in Ottawa based
on those reports and the week leading up
to the Convoy I certainly based on the
report saw many different views of what
might happen in Ottawa we saw social
media reports that said there might be
34 000 vehicles that arrive in Ottawa we
saw other reports that might be only in
the hundreds I think as recently as
January 24th Hendon report one of the
intelligence gaps that's indicated on
the report says unknown exact number of
vehicles that we'll be attending Ottawa
so even as late as the 24th we weren't
100 sure on numbers so we had a intense
range from social media saying 30 000 32
000 to
in the hundreds
um did you discuss the Hendon reports
with anyone at Ops in your sort of role
of coordinator
I did not discussed and indirectly with
anybody at Ottawa Police Service no yeah
um now I want to ask you about an
intersect call uh on I think it was the
morning of January 27th do you remember
that call I do could you describe it for
us
yes it was part of the regular intersect
call normally they do Round Table this
is more specific to this event so we
kind of opened the floor to Ottawa
Police Service and they spoke about
their event and they spoke about their
plans
um to manage the cowboy vehicles that
were traveling to their City okay and
what um were the plans that were shared
on that call
um the there was no um written plan
shared on the call it was all verbal
they indicated that they had a plan and
had a capacity to accept 3 000 vehicles
in their city and then they set about
describing On what streets those uh
Vehicles would park in in my notes I
made notes of the call I noted the
streets I just don't have the streets
and the exact vehicle numbers but they
had you know sir Johnny McDonald Parkway
X number of vehicles could park there
Wellington Street X number of vehicles
could park there they spoke about how
the Convoy leaders agreed to only take
three of four lanes on Wellington Street
and leave one lane open for emergency
vehicles other vehicles would take up
side streets off of Wellington and keep
the curb Lane open for emergency
vehicles that's how they described their
interactions with the Convoy leaders
and prior to this call were you aware
that they the Ops was planning to allow
the trucks into downtown
Ottawa this was the first I'd heard
about how Ottawa planned to do with the
vehicles that were traveling into their
City okay and did you have any concerns
about that proposal
I didn't as much as I'd seen hidden
reports like we just we've heard
evidence here that obviously motivated
individuals traveling from East Coast
and West Coast very well funded
indications that they may spend multiple
days some in their reports have three
days but certainly
um it looked like multiple days
but
um I think superintendent superintendent
Morris talked about being in your lane I
had to stay in my lane and I had a lot
of experience working with the Ottawa
Police Service and with other major
events and seeing their abilities very
professional organization and it wasn't
my place to question whether they were
ready I had to make that assumption that
they were ready they were talking calmly
about what their plans were they felt
that it was going to be successful and
it was not my place to question them I
assumed they had that plan in place and
my job was there to support to support
them
okay uh and and I understand that and
the the whole sort of stay in your lane
mentality but
um did you have any concerns even if you
didn't voice them did you have any
concerns about that number of maybe
heavy commercial vehicles in downtown
Ottawa
I didn't have concerns it certainly was
unique not something I've ever
experienced on large Vehicles I've
experienced a large number of persons
but not that number of vehicles
but once again I had to rely on that
Ottawa Police had that experience they
were the police of jurisdiction and it
was just not my place just to question I
had to assume that they had to sell the
plan and we were just there to support
sorry no sorry
um did anybody else on that call any of
the other participating agencies raise
any concerns or question that plan
I don't recall it I just recall
conversation about how you know Vehicles
traveling from Quebec could impact
facility to go back got no police
we just talked about impacts that
traffic flow would have but I don't
recall anybody questioning
um
what Ottawa Police was speaking about
okay
um
and there was also discussion of a plan
to have vehicles kind of Park further
away and protesters sort of bust in do
you remember that
I recall discussions about you know
could we have the vehicle spark at the
Canadian Tire Center the hockey arena
and have them shuttle bust down to the
downtown core
um in my view that's more difficult if
you're a truck driver and you've driven
your truck multiple days and weeks
across the country you're likely not
going to be happy to park it at the
Canadian Tire Center but
so I know some areas were opened up by
the city to allow some overflow parking
but those ideas I didn't believe came to
fruition
okay and based on your participation in
this call what did it appear how long of
an event did it appear that the Ops was
planning for
the the weekend at the most okay and was
that
um consistent with what you understood
at the time
it's very consistent in what context
did you also believe it would be a
weekend-long event yes
um because I was relying a lot of police
believed it would be weakened events so
who was I to question that it wasn't
going to be if they believed it I
believed it and uh we were Partners in
it and as much as Hendon did say those
other things I had to I'd take some
faith in Ottawa had the plan and that we
would be done on Sunday evening maybe
Monday morning at the latest well you've
anticipated my question because
superintendent Morris was was very clear
yesterday that um the hinden reports in
the week leading up used the word long
term and sort of made it clear that
protesters would be staying so I guess
I'm wondering if you were reading them
why you weren't left with that
impression as well
there was
there was more engine report there was
more Intel that indicated they were
staying longer than staying shorter for
sure there was
and I decided to assume that Ottawa had
a capacity to manage what may have been
a longer term event that there must have
been a a plan B let's say for lack of a
better word that yeah if these people do
stay after Monday then we pull out plan
B and we activate Plan B those were just
assumptions I was making that because we
all knew and we all had access to those
kind of reports we knew that possibility
could be longer there must be a
contingency plan in place if Monday is
still locked up right was there
discussion of that of that contingency
plan or Plan B on this intersect call
there was not
um who if anyone at the opp Did you sort
of report back to after this intersect
call about the plan to let the vehicles
into downtown
um I reported to my chief superintendent
Carl Thomas about what was occurring I
reported to my Incident Commander of
course because he wasn't on the call it
was inspector Scott sempel he was the
instant Commander at the time to say
that I had this conversation this is
what ottawa's plan is for the vehicles
and um
that's when I asked my traffic inspector
to connect with their traffic inspector
and just filled my a series my Superior
you know what I'd heard on the call
um and
ultimately there was a plan that dated
January 28th or 29th I believe that was
put together by the Ottawa Police
Service did you did you ever see a copy
of that plan I don't recall seeing a
plan for that weekend though okay
um did you ever ask for a copy I did not
no would you
normally see a copy of a plan for an
event like that
not as much not and it's another police
of jurisdiction unless it had ties to
OPP operations in the plan I wouldn't
normally see it
because it didn't impact me
or my service
um we've heard evidence and I expect
we'll continue to hear evidence that
this was a fairly unprecedented event
would you agree with that assessment I
would agree all right on many levels
unprecedented in size
um
the vehicles used lots of unprecedented
Natures to the event for sure
um if we could pull up
um OPP
50773 please
showing you another document this is
um the will say that I believe you
prepared in connection uh with attending
the the interview this summer is that
correct actually
um
within a week after the end of the event
I just felt because of my role that the
organization would likely want to hear
from what I experienced so I created it
will say then I there was I didn't even
know that a commission was coming or
that interviews may be coming several
months later I just did it because I
knew the facts were fresh in my mind at
the time there was
so many things that happened that
most made it into my notebook but
there's so many things that were
independent Recollections but I didn't
want to lose so both myself and chief
party created these type of documents
around the same period of time okay so
that's that's helpful to know so this
was created in we're talking late
February maybe early March yes right and
no no later than two weeks after the end
of the event
okay
um and so I'm I won't take you to it but
I just wanted to understand the
circumstances under which it was created
and so it references a conversation with
an inspector Ferguson on January 29th
who who's inspector Ferguson
um
that's inspector Don Ferguson she's a
touch commander of a Renford attachment
but she's also a trained critical
incident Commander so it's part of our
planning for this event because it was a
traffic event on the 417 the national
capital regional Command Center was
stood up and most of the policing
Partners were housed there MTO Ops got
no police
this was important for us to have a
leader there to be able to help direct
the traffic and have better
communication flow between all the
agencies so I asked her to to be there
and be able to report back to The
Incident Commander at the EOC which was
inspector simple and myself they both
fell under myself and her role there was
to kind of monitor how things were
occurring and how the vehicles were
traveling into the City and report back
at what was occurring with our partners
okay and she did report back to you on
the 29th she did what was that report
um I want to say it was around
mid-morning 11 47 I think that the time
was I may be mistaken on the time
but she indicated that she was
experiencing dysfunction within the
ncrcc specifically to the Ops commanders
on Specter Lucas
he was yelling profanities not only at
her but we also had a staff sergeant
there Lisa Nicholas and also the
revealing profanities at each other and
they had Fairly seemed to her had lost
some control over what was occurring
and didn't have a way to figure it out
and they were trying to offer assistance
to them in the form of officers to help
if they had calls for service in the
city of Ottawa they weren't able to get
to because all their members were tied
up downtown that we could provide some
of that service but they weren't able to
get kind of any communication back to
say yes we could use that or not
okay and what um
specifically what type of
assistance was the opp offering at this
point we offered everything from public
order unit assistance
um
rapid response team qrt teams we we kind
of use that term we have Quick Response
teams if they had an armed robbery let's
say in Canada and everybody was tied up
with the Convoy downtown we could rally
members together to help them out with
those major calls that they're obviously
stretched to be able to get to
okay
um and I think you will say includes the
phrase this event was clearly beyond
their capabilities is that and they're
being Ops was that a view that you had
formed already on January 29th that was
the term inspector Ferguson used to me
okay because obviously I wasn't I wasn't
experiencing it that's that's what she
was experiencing and that's how she
described it to me okay
and did inspector Ferguson relate to you
or did you have a view of kind of what
was going wrong what was uh overwhelming
I guess the Ops at that point just a
lack of what to do there was no real
plan as to who did who do we send where
uh what do you want me to do lots of
questions about where the resources
their resources were supposed to go lots
of confusion in that aspect okay
um and I understand that you spoke with
deputy chief Bell on that day as well
correct I did okay can you describe that
conversation for us sure essentially was
an agreement that we would be the
contacts with each other uh throughout
this event obviously they're going to
have to have a contact with the opp so
we agreed that we would be each other's
contact if he needed something from the
opp he would call me and vice versa so
we'd arranged that process early on okay
um did you offer any assistance on this
day in particular I'd have to check my
notes I know I've offered assistance I
just can't remember if it was this
particular day okay which day I can look
quickly here I have my notes with me
we can pull it up it's OPP uh five
zeros774 and it's at page 12.
thank you
that's the entry at 16
just above 1642 I think advise
DC Bell 18 at
Correctional advice on that we had 18
members at our Canada Detachment which
is our Ottawa Detachment including two
surgeons that could assist if required
he acknowledged and stated that he would
relay that information to his instant
Commander
and um
we waited there was no real reply and
then at 1830 I can contact it and made a
final offer for assistance to the Ottawa
Police Service
and in 1900 they advised us that there
was really no help required and that was
through staff sergeant Nicholas who was
in the ncrcc
okay and so you offered them some point
in the afternoon uh didn't have a
response and then at seven o'clock we're
told we don't thanks but no thanks
yeah there's just there was no we never
heard back we just we called again to
say we made the offer it uh just after
four o'clock do you still need these 18
officers and there was just no reply
back to say they wanted them and then
um finally at 1900 they stated that
there was just no help required
okay and what uh what type of officers
were these 18 officers they were just
Frontline constables that we would have
pulled from Detachment operations Within
45 minute hour radius to Ottawa as soon
as we could get members there to help
support without critically damaging our
ability to to police the communities
they were serving
it was strictly just members who were
currently on duty that we could pull we
have a regional mobilization plan that
kind of has a set number of based on how
many you're working on this day this is
how many many officers we could move to
other locations in an emergency
so we were able to dictate okay we can
survive with pulling 18
if they need it
and so it was 18 the the most that you
could sort of put together in that short
order that's the most I could summon in
that short order each region is a rather
large region but within an hour of
Ottawa that's the most I could muster at
that period of time
um and did uh did the Ops ultimately uh
take you up on that offer at some point
I believe the next day they agreed that
my uh inspector um
Luke Duval indicated that they had
members that were prepared to to go to
Ottawa and they were sending they had 18
but I think initially they were going to
send 10 and they sent 10 downtown to
Elegant Street
to be deployed mainly in a traffic
service capacity helping out with
traffic control closing streets
and then shortly thereafter I heard back
from my Incident Commander inspector
Ferguson that only two of those members
had been used and the rest had been
sitting there for over I believe it was
four hours and they were on day shift it
was late in the day and I said told them
from Elgin we can't let them sit around
there any longer
so they reached out to Deputy Bell to
just let him know this is what's
happening and uh and he indicated that
he apologized and said there was a lack
of communication with in their Bureau
within their service and that he would
Rectify it okay
um and did you
did either you offer additional
Assistance or did he ask for those 10
back or additional officers at that time
um it's hard to recall because we spoke
so often but there's certainly there was
the offer he knew that he was going to
have to ask for more assistance
inspector to file indicated that through
inspector Lucas that there was going to
be a formal ass coming
for more assistance from the opp it was
unknown what that number was going to
look like but it was likely going to
come and so Deputy Bell and I would have
that conversation to say the kids coming
we haven't figured out the exact number
yet but there's going to be further
request for resources coming
and that was going to be Chief to
commissioner Chief slowly to
commissioner karique in a formal way it
would do that but
um Deputy Bell could call me to say I
need 30 people and we would
operationalize that right away the
formal paperwork can can take its time
and move its way from Ottawa to Aurelia
but we're not going to wait for the
formal paperwork other partner agencies
we're going to help them in their time
of need and I would have mustered those
members and got them to Ottawa prior to
any letter being signed by the
commissioner okay
um
but if that's the case why uh why pull
back the officers that you had sent who
were just in your words sort of sitting
around doing nothing I mean they were
there and they could have been activated
mainly because of the hours they've
already been working they'd already be
working over 12 hours that day so
they're on 14 hours if they were then
just starting to work it would be unfair
to those members to work past the period
of time they were working so that's why
I pulled them
okay
um in this first weekend sort of January
29th January 30th can you just share
with us any other observations about
what was happening on the ground what
was going well what was not going well
it was certainly not going well
um I was getting lots of reports from my
members of the ncrcc there was lots of
dysfunctions to lots of yelling lots of
unknowns of what they were going to do
on the 31st of January I had a
conversation with Deputy Bell where he
basically said we're planning for a
protracted event and we really don't
know how our way out of this
so that was the first indication to me
on the 31st that we were going to be in
for a long haul to assist them so I had
to prepare my incident command team
to kind of switch to say okay now we
have to switch operations to supporting
the Ottawa Police
and I'm not 100 what the numbers are
going to look like yet
but
it's clear through talking to Deputy
Bell that it's going to be protracted
they don't see a way out and they're
going to be relying on us and other
services to help them okay and we'll get
there but
um first I'd like to pull up an email
it's OPP four zeros1593
we can go to the bottom email the one
from Joseph Varga he's an inspector with
the opp correct yeah zizak
critical instant Commander a major
criminal Incident Commander okay and
what was his role uh at this point
um early on there was discussions within
our own organization as to you know how
are we going to structure the support
for Ottawa with
inspector varka come down and act as the
MC to help direct OPP resources to
assist Ottawa
what was the command structure looking
like because there was
um concerns over what the Ottawa Police
command structure was going to look like
so was it just a lot of General
discussions about how best can we insert
ourselves and integrate ourselves and
provide the support that's required a
lot of that conversation resolved around
that okay and I think this email kind of
touches on some of that regrouping so
inspector Virgo writes superintendent is
you are aware Oppo direct supports to
PPS will conclude this evening at the
request of Ops in the ncrcc command
group OPP Pou has now been requested to
support Ops with the ongoing Pou
deployment in the city of Ottawa
so what assistance had the opp rendered
to the PPS being the Parliamentary
Protective Service during that first
weekend
uh within Ontario a lot of the services
have a public garden public order unit
Hub and they communicate with each other
when they require services so this
request wouldn't necessarily have gone
directly through myself Pou and Poe
commanders reported to me indirectly but
I certainly didn't direct other
operations because they're trained Pou
commanders they would tell me when the
request comes in so I recall that a
request from PPS came in for support and
we discussed about where is this support
is it at PPS or is it with Ottawa who
needs to support the most
you know as agreed amongst the PLU
subject matter experts that they would
begin supporting the Parliamentary
Protective Services first and then if
required transition to support Ottawa
and do you know why that agreement was
reached
I didn't ask specifics because it was in
my subject matter expertise I relied on
their expertise to say that something
what PPS told them that you needed to to
protect them and support them first and
then always be available to Ottawa if
they required
okay
um if we could just scroll down a little
bit inspector Varga shares
plan for the next three days this this
concept of operations is anticipated to
utilize oppou in conjunction with all
other assisting agency Pou
OU units in the following timeline and
then it sets out what was going to occur
on Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
including a possible injunction of the
injunction uh
and then the injunction would be
enforced so at this point on January
30th which is the Sunday
um
it was is everyone planning to basically
wrap this up by Wednesday of the coming
week
I can't see that that's the case because
I wasn't engaged in these conversations
with public order
um my role was on a Frontline capacity
we call them soft hats so
it's your normal police officer you'd
see on the street that was my focus
public order command was separate to me
so they would have their conversations
and if they felt they needed to add
public order to Ottawa they would do
that on their own and just notify me
that it was happening I was providing
around 30 office 30 officers a day at
this period of time to Ottawa Police 15
on days and 15 on nights primarily to
just do traffic Services traffic
enforcement just at intersections
closing roads and I let the incident
commanders like Joe Varga and his public
Bar unit commanders who work out what
system they felt they needed to do with
their public order Partners in Ottawa
and other services
so the 30 uh were traffic officers under
your command and then inspector varia
had PLU units that may have been in
Ottawa as well that's correct
okay and this this is a Pou plan so that
you weren't involved in uh preparing I
was not there would have just been a
phone call to say
um superintendent there's going to be
Pou in Ottawa supporting PPS and Ottawa
Police and I would get General run
ground today we got this many on ground
doing qrt or this meeting on ground
doing this but that was the extent of
the notifications I was receiving
okay and if we just scroll down a little
bit the the next paragraph a review of
the shift of Opp Pou support from PPS to
Ops has resulted in a reevaluation of
required OPP Pou resources
and you see it talks about the the
release of 14 bodies back to their home
location further eight Pou members will
be returning to their home locations and
so my question is
it's it's January 30th it certainly
doesn't look like the the protest is
ending on Monday morning but Pou members
are leaving the city of Ottawa and do
you know why that is I can't say it and
that's the the um kind of the essence of
the command structure as a streak as a
strategic Commander I'm not going to get
necessarily into the weeds I trust my
subject matter experts incident
commanders PLU commanders to know what
they need to do
we had many other priorities going on
around the province with other borders
Blue Water Bridge Ambassador Bridge
we had to project our
international border crossings so they
may have been redeployed to those other
areas but
kind of the nature of that major
critical incident command structure is
for a person like me in a role I was in
did not get too far into the weeds so
that's why I would necessarily not
necessarily have been advised okay
um You referred earlier to a discussion
with deputy chief Bell on the 31st where
he indicated they're now planning for a
four-week extended occupation
how did you react to that that timeline
I was concerned I really
thought and hoped that we could resolve
it prior to that
period of time because as as for my
experience with other blockades the
longer they go the more people that are
attracted and the more people you now
have to deal with and it makes the job
of a police service not much difficult
not much more difficult to be able to
manage
so I was hoping that we could develop
something between the multiple groups at
the table to be able to deal with it
prior to four weeks but that was that
was a surprise to hear that early in the
game that they were already looking four
weeks down the road
and based on that did you escalate that
within the opp did you change anything
about your own planning when you heard
that uh anticipated timeline well
certainly I had to reach out to my
inspector my chief superintendent but
also my inspector incident commanders to
say okay now we have to start scheduling
for four weeks so let's try to figure
out how we can provide the resources
that Ottawa needs
we're going to expect that they're going
to expect more than 30 a day as the days
move on so how are we going to do this
we had to engage in our organization we
have an Emergency Operations Center in
Aurelia and that's part of their roles
to help with major planning for major
events
so it was clear that it was going to
start getting out of my ability in a
regional level to staff Ottawa Police
was just Regional people we were going
to have to start bringing in people from
all over the province so that we needed
help in that Logistics so we reached out
to really our Emergency Operations
Center to say okay get ready it's gonna
be an extended event can we start
identifying Regional contacts to start
relaying what Ottawa is going to need
and how many people we can get to Ottawa
and then I had to stand up a much more
robust Logistics team to now plan for
our hotels and be able to staff and feed
and and deploy all these people and most
likely find a bigger command post to
manage it because now it's going to be
growing
um I like to pull up OPP six zeros24
please
this is an email
um
from
I believe it's superintendent alakis is
that correct
I guess he's in our field support Bureau
okay and and what role was he playing in
the response right so as uh
superintendent field support Bureau they
cover
the majority of the OPP's emergency
services so tactical response units
emergency response teams which are
public order units their emergency
response officers and their plou trained
so that falls under their Bureau which
falls under Deputy DeMarco's Bureau so
he would have had and he also his
control of our EOC so he had a lot a
large role to play in what was happening
okay
um so I want to go go down and start
with uh superintendent alakis identifies
sort of three issues says much of the
uncertainty around response and
especially around the utilization of our
resources has resulted from three main
difficulties and so if you could just
help us understand these if you had
observed these just take us through sort
of one two and three sure
um this is the first time seeing the
email say how to apologize and read
through it
um so he has concerns about I guess a
terminology I think we kind of heard uh
with uh with Deputy Ferguson that the
Ottawa Police May refer to their
critical command structure a little bit
differently than us so nomenclature and
naming can sometimes cause confusion so
I think that's what he they're referring
to number one
um
and what whether they need do they need
incident commanders there's any major
critical incident Commanders
and do they understand what the true
function of a CAC is could that be done
with just an Incident Commander so I
think he's just trying to clarify to
them can you go back to them to clarify
what is it they really need because then
we know what we can send them because
there's three levels of command incident
command creative funds command and major
equivalence command
come with many different skills so you
want to try to sorry you want to try to
keep it to the lowest level as possible
and so it before we move on to two is
that an issue
um or a function of the fact that there
isn't a standardized incident command
system across various police agencies
as far as I'm aware there's there's
fairly standardized processes but as we
heard the the term event Commander which
meant Incident Commander so I guess some
municipalities may choose to use
different terminology than others but
from my understanding of the
curriculum command process the naming
conviction conventions are fairly
consistent okay
um and so if you just point to Ops
requests were framed in terms of
specific amounts of resources rather
than in terms of the effect or impact
they wish these resources to impart was
that something that you had observed
correct and that's kind of where the
line divides here so I'm getting a
request from Deputy bill for Frontline
officers and we're very clear on what he
wants them to do and what they're going
to do
they're getting requests from Ottawa
Police public unit command about what
they want them to do so his concern is
what he's hearing from the public order
side of Ottawa please
and I make an assumption too because I
wasn't involved in this email
it's a little more clear on my side
because I can ask those direct questions
what do you want them to do how many
cars do you want them to bring what are
their roles and responsibilities so I
can find those people with those skills
whereas here
um
it seems that the public order the
public order unit request for Ottawa was
maybe a little vague and not as specific
about exactly what they wanted and what
exactly what they wanted them to do and
that can cause frustration for sure okay
but in your view you had a better
I guess relationship with deputy chief
Bell and were able to
have that direct conversation
um in a way that's better than what
superintendent alakis was able to
accomplish initially for sure I mean
along the way there was certain
frustrations about where do you want our
people and when
that was more minor but it was very
clear he needed the most help relieving
his members from the downtown core so
they could get some rest and that's what
is kind of his Focus was on the
maintenance piece first and that was the
easiest piece for us to help him with
because he didn't have to have
specialized skills he said to be police
officers with a cruiser okay
um and then just briefly on the third
point an initial lack of internal
communication and unified incident
command uh which created barriers to
effective information intelligence flow
is that something that you had observed
at that point
I
did
um observed and and I did speak to
Deputy Bell about this as well it just
observed
um
multiple points they had an Incident
Commander at their Green Bank location
they had some commanders out there
Elegant Street headquarters and they had
inspector Lucas at the ncrcc they were
all spread out across the city it was
almost like a left-hand right hand
situation
inspector Lucas may not have been aware
about what The Incident Commander
superintendent was doing at Greenbank
and it wore out in in public market you
didn't work as well so
um I had some conversations with Deputy
Bell about that just to say these are
the frustrations my people are seeing
you recognize that right away he
understood they were trying to do their
best to become more unified I wasn't
telling amazing he hadn't heard or seen
himself I think but we
yeah for the benefit of my people that's
why I was there to protect my people and
when they wanted me to message with
Ottawa Police that was my role and we
did have lots of conversation around the
difficulty we were seeing in their
incident command structures yes okay and
uh was deputy chief Bell was receptive
to
to those comments yeah you seem very
receptive he unders you seem to
understand and said yes Craig we're
doing the best we can
okay
um if we could get OPP four zeros one
three four two please
I want to show you this is
um an email I believe from Pat Morris to
you and others
February 2nd
and if we can just go down there's a
there's an organizational chart here and
I just want to understand and make sure
that this is this accurately represents
um
the
sort of command structure for the opp
for this event at the time
it is exactly how it was at the time yes
okay
um
and what's can you what's the difference
between the ncrcc and then the opp
Ottawa Command Post
um essentially it was the ncrcc housed
all our partner agencies and I felt it
would be a real
we'd be missing out on a lot if we
didn't put somebody there because we
needed somebody to coordinate what was
happening they had access to MTO cameras
they had access to Ottawa Police radios
because Ottawa Police was right there
so they were able to provide a lot more
real-time and quick information to those
incident commanders that was sitting at
the Ottawa Command Post so that's why we
had those two inspectors at those
locations and then inspector Dave
Springer who is a trained um
Pou commander and an MC he was taking
care of the POU command side
okay and they all kind of reported up to
myself
and so this email is from February 2nd
which is also the date
um
of Chief slowly or former Chief slowly
uh you know saying he doesn't believe
that there's a a policing solution or
there may not be a policing solution I
take it you're familiar with that um
with him saying that yeah and so as
somebody who is on the ground and sort
of witnessing what was going on uh very
close close hand from the opp did you
share that assessment of the situation
at that time I did not okay
um why not
based on my experience I guess is the
best example um I hadn't even up to this
point I'd already heard about
issues integrating PLT and into this
process and and all the blockades have
been involved in I've seen nothing but
success from our PLT you're a amazingly
dedicated group of individuals who are
able to establish relationships with
protesters enable able to start
discussions about okay why you here what
are you protesting how long do you plan
to be here can we help you with an exit
strategy there are obviously trained in
the framework that's been adopted by the
Canadian Association of police Chiefs
which I think the commission has heard
about already
and they've done amazing work to be able
to resolve a lot of situations without
having to use
Pou just through negotiation and
discussions and allowing groups whatever
they happen to be exit on their own and
without having to have police
enforcement now we've had to use police
enforcement at times for sure but
I did not see that piece being used in
this situation I didn't see Intelligence
being used to lead a solution I didn't
see PLT being used to lead a solution
so that's why I felt maybe he was being
a little premature that I didn't see
that all these steps have been tried yet
I guess if all those steps have been
tried and every tool in our toolbox have
been used and we're still at Ground Zero
maybe you could think about that in that
way but I just didn't think that we'd
used all our tools yet so I couldn't
agree with that statement okay
um and so
hearing that did that prompt A Renewed
um
extension of support or did you did you
do anything with that to say to go back
to your team and say we have to step up
our assistance because clearly this is a
situation that's getting out of hand
not too long or not too long after the
February second day you might have the
dates wrong we'd already sent our OPP PL
team PLT team to Ottawa to support them
so they're already on the ground trying
to support
so I was already hearing
um frustrations on integration they
weren't able to be integrated they
weren't given autonomy to make decisions
so I was more communicating with Deputy
Bell because they would call me
inspector Bodel which the commission
will hear from who runs the PLT program
he would call me his sergeants would
call me to say sir
we're not getting anywhere here or the
actual Ottawa Police Service teams not
given autonomy to connect with Convoy
drivers make a lot of those concessions
which they do
um and so they were just they were
floundering they didn't feel they had a
role he didn't see a plan there was no
PLT plan which normally there is a plan
for PLT there was none
so
I wasn't as much communicating with them
as they were communicating with me about
their concerns and part of my role as
strategic Commander was deconfliction
so I would reach out to Deputy Bell and
say
Steve this is what we're seeing and
we're hearing from Chief slowly and
other commanders at PLT is important to
the solution of this problem but we're
just not seeing it be operationalized
and and that's not unique sometimes if
you're at a high level like a chief and
you're not seeing what's happening on
the ground maybe that's news to Chief
slowly right so it was important for me
on behalf of my members and for the
Ottawa Police Service to bring her to
their attention and see if they can make
some changes to get them more autonomy
and get them more engaged and try to
stress Upon A WT Bill the successes I've
seen and the importance of using them to
help move this forward
um and sort of generally speaking when
you relay those concerns what was the
reception
positive Deputy Bell agreed he
understood the importance of the
integration and that he was going to
make sure that that was happening
okay
um and I understand that the opp
assigned to planners in the very early
days inspector Union and staff sergeant
Govan is that right that's correct could
you just describe what their role would
have been right so they were asked
um as part of the kind of formal ask
from Chief slowly to come and help their
planners come up with a plan
and I heard from them regularly about
their frustrations they were kind of
given three tasks
number one was
a plan to go intersection by
intersection number two was like I don't
know if mass arrest may be the wrong
word but just another plan another
enforcement plan and the third plan was
kind of a status quo plan how do we kind
of hold the streets for a certain period
of time
there was questions about who they
reported to within the Ottawa Police
Service who's responsible for this plan
who's going to sign off on the plan
and at a certain period one of the Ops
inspectors Marriott came in the room and
said
whatever you were told to do forget it
Chief slowly wants you to come up with a
whole new plan uh your report to me now
and go to work
and they essentially walked away from
the table and called me and relayed this
information to me to say Sir can you
help us
um this isn't working and then I called
Deputy Bell and explained and he
explained no these members report to I
think of superintendent maybe Acting
Superintendent Dunlop and they were to
take direction from him so the planning
table was having its own frustrations
itself
and
but these two OPP planners were working
alongside Ops planners correct yeah
and did that did that group ultimately
come up with any sort of plan
not that I ever saw no
no
um no I understand
there's a bit of confusion also about
the role that superintendent Mark
Patterson was playing at this time as
well
I was clear myself that he was their
Incident Commander in the early days I
knew that he he was the one I needed to
contact if I had instant Commander type
conversations I needed to have I knew he
was the one to call
um so it wasn't unclear to me at that
stage it changed as days move forward it
became confusing because they changed
into commanders fairly quickly but in
the early days if the period of time
we're talking about I knew that he was
the person to contact
okay
did it appear to you I guess based on
this incident that you just described or
otherwise that there was some confusion
in the Ops about lines of authority and
who was
who needed to sign off on what or who
was in charge of uh PLT or the plan or
whatever it is yes very much so there
was confusion
amongst the PLT they didn't know who
they reported to obviously just the
planners didn't know who they were
supposed to report to and there was
confusion about who had authority to
make decisions and uh and move a plan
forward
did you raise that
um within the OPP at all
yes and
um that's kind of the Java strategy
Commander again I talked about
situational awareness it was important
for me to let my command including
Deputy Commissioner and commissioner
Creek be aware of what I was seeing and
the concerns I was seeing
in the hopes that commissioner Creek or
Deputy Commissioner Harkins could have
higher level conversations with Chief
slowly so I had to make them aware of
what was occurring
um
because it in a way we had to protect
our members if we're going to bring more
members into an event that was
dysfunctional and dangerous
that's my job is to protect our members
so I didn't want to do that either
so and that really always the eyes and
ears of the organization for that until
a chief party arrived that was
essentially my role situational
awareness reporting up to senior command
and deconflicting the issues that I saw
with PLT and our planners and just
trying to navigate logistical challenges
that Ottawa Police when they've required
help on the street with traffic
and when you talk about deconflicting
issues you're talking about sort of
direct conversations with deputy chief
Bell
yes so I would hear from my members
either attached to the PLT team or
attached to the planning team they would
Express concerns to me and then I would
commit to them that I would reach out to
Deputy Bell to see what we could do to
try to resolve it
I want to go to to February 4th now and
there was a press conference I believe
at which it was announced that
all off-ramps from the 417 into Ottawa
and the bridges into Ottawa were going
to be shut down closed essentially
remember that press conference I do in
fact I remember it was predicated with
Chief slowly saying that due to new
intelligence
this is what he wanted to do okay yes
um
on the intelligence piece were you aware
of any new intelligence no that's why I
was quite confused I was in my command
post watching the news and I sought to
you slowly and Deputy Bell on the TV
announcing this and it caused me a great
concern
okay uh and were you aware that this was
going to be announced or that this was a
new proposal or plan it was totally of
the blue unprepared unaware okay and
um
why was it concerning or why was this an
issue for you
um the opp was responsible for the 417
and all on ramps and off ramps we had
Partnerships with the MTO
um as you're aware Ottawa has many
on-ramps and off-ramps on the 417.
I certainly also even had a even if we
had the members to do it which we did
not
I still question What DOT does there's
lots of ways to get into downtown Ottawa
you don't have to use the 417 so
um I had two issues number one I
currently did not have the capacity to
do what I was hearing I wanted to be
done in relation to OPP least highways
and I also questioned the intelligence
so I guess three things and then
questioned how would that help
okay so I reached out to Deputy Bell
right away
and how did that conversation go
um I just I I texted him I believe to
say um Steve if this is true we need to
talk because this is going to have huge
digital impacts on me and my
organization and you haven't talked
timelines as you've slowly almost
talking immediately it's never going to
happen immediately and then he called me
shortly thereafter to say no Craig we're
not going to do this and then I asked
what's this new intelligence and he said
obviously there's no intelligence Greg
you're the ones the opp that are
providing us the intelligence there's
certainly maybe csis or another
intelligence Network may have provided
the information that was my concern uh
but he indicated that there was no new
intelligence
and there was no plan to close uh ramps
and I reached out to my Inspector
Inspector Ferguson of the ncrcc she
talked to her
Ottawa Police Service inspectors and
they also had never heard of this plan
and started to become upset because they
were never even notified this was a
Chief's idea okay
um was closing off ramps or Bridges
something that the opp had done as the
Convoy traversed Ontario
um we closed some off-ramps on the
initial arrival just to try to focus
them to use ramps that were open so we
did that and off and on throughout this
whole event we would do that if we saw a
large Convoy wanting to come to Ottawa
we would open and close certain
off-ramps just to get them into the city
in a cleaner fashion and we would
communicate with the Convoy leaders to
make that happen so and the bridges the
bridges
I believe almost every bridge is with
any of the city of Ottawa so the only
time we ever did Bridges was during the
Colvin lockdown when they had the
provincial block provincial lockdowns
and we did Bridges you know computer
restriction by not in the city of Ottawa
but I obviously predated this event
um and when you
closed off ramps at some points was that
done at the request of Ops or was that
just done uh
it was totally at the crest of Ops Ops
was the police of jurisdiction so we are
essentially attached to their hip what
they wanted if they wanted us to do it
we could only do what they wanted we
couldn't read their mind as to what
their plan was because there was no plan
so we we would essentially wait they
would phone us they would say could you
close this ramp for this period of time
for this reason
if we had the resources to do it we
would do it and then reopen the ramp
okay so just help me understand that
though because
um
my understanding is that the the opp or
the place of jurisdiction for 400 series
highways and so that's why they were
asking you to to close ramps because the
Ops couldn't send Cruisers to close an
off-ramp on a 400 series highway is that
is that correct correct I apologize I
mean it came out wrong
um
the Ottawa Police would have wanted us
to close the ramp because of an
operational issue they had so they were
reaching out to us to do it for their
purpose right as the opp we we generally
did not just close ramps just because we
wanted to it would have been at the
request of Ottawa Police because they
had an issue within the city and they
needed our help on the ramp sorry I
wasn't clear enough no that I just
wanted to make sure it was it was clear
for for the commissioner's benefit yes
um
and so as it had been done before
closing of ramps in at the request of
the Ops in this case it just caught you
by uh by surprise oh yeah it's based on
a sheer number I mean obviously
a ramp or two for collisions is is
normal but to hear all ramps was
concerning because that's a large number
okay
um and your witness summary and I won't
take you there but it refers to a
conversation with uh deputy chief Bell
what you characterize as a formal
conversation with deputy chief Bell on
the fourth what can you tell us about
that conversation well that was about
the unified command conversation sorry
that was about Universe okay yes once
again that was triggered by my calls
from my members on the ground still
concerned with not seeing a plan a
unified structure no inability to
integrate no inability to have autonomy
so I wanted to express it to Deputy bill
in a more formal way to say deputy this
is what we're seeing and we need to try
or you need to try to come up with a
more unified structure to make this work
a bit better much better
and the deputy Bell was very receptive
to our conversations understood the need
and then and stated that that's what
their goal was and they were trying to
do that
it was difficult Deputy belovski is a
senior officer to me
I don't want to be seen as trying to
tell him what to do I think he
recognizes himself when we discussed it
but once again as the role of strategic
Commander that was my job I had to
protect my people and when they were
signaling to me they wanted help it was
my job to help them
and during this conversation did either
deputy chief Bell ask for more resources
or did you offer more resources
um I don't recall that happening in that
conversation
more resource requests happened
continually throughout the event but I
just don't know if that happened in that
conversation okay and and so after the
early days the resource requests were
not coming directly uh to you is that
right
um once the incident commanders were in
place at the ncrcc a lot of those
requests would go to the instant
commander and then we would come to uh
to myself or my Incident Commander and
then we would do what we needed to do
logistically in the province to try to
get those officers to the city of Volvo
okay
um if we could pull up OPP five zeros
556
this is an email
at I think if we scroll down I believe
uh inspector Union forwarded to
um you and superintendent alakis an
email and if we go further down this is
an email
which we saw in evidence this morning
from former Chief slowly to a number of
members on his team at 6 30 in the
morning of February 5th do you recall
getting this forwarded email from
um inspector Union
um I recall inspector Union sending an
email as it relates to I think this is
the period of time where
um
it was an email where Chief slowly was
directing a lot of different things that
he wanted to see happen one of those
things
um staff sergeant Goldman was woken up
in the early hours and the request was
for OPP public order unit to help clear
this particular area
staff sergeant gold they handled it
himself and and put them off to say like
no this is not part of our framework
this is not how we operate and was able
to delay that operation
but it was part of a bigger email chain
I believe on that day
and if we could just scroll down to the
general priorities
um last there the number one is surge
contain and enforce which I think gets
referred to as surgeon contain what um
did you have a view on sort of
whether that was an appropriate strategy
at the time or whether there were like
there was a plan in place to affect that
I I certainly had concerns because there
was no plan these were ideas and
concepts of what they wanted to happen
but if it didn't come with a plan I
certainly wasn't going to offer OPP
support to just do that based on you
know one line email I understand that
was their goal but there had to be a
cogent plan for that to happen and up to
this point I still hadn't seen one and
so we couldn't allow it to have OPP
participate in that
and so that um something we've heard and
we will hear from a number of witnesses
I think is the idea that
as my colleague put it this morning does
the plan Drive the numbers or the
numbers Drive the plan and so I think
you're saying you know the opp isn't
going to make more resources available
without a plan that it can review is
that is that accurate yeah I'm I'm uh
you have to have a plan
um to do it's backwards to do it just by
numbers you have to have a plan and once
you have a plan that your subject matter
experts your instant commanders your
mcics all agree on then okay what human
resources do we need to make this plan
uh
effective and successful
okay and is that
standard practices that always the case
that you wouldn't be offering up OPP
resources unless you knew exactly
how the local police of jurisdiction
planned to use them
every situation is different but
certainly my PLU commanders are going to
want to see an operational plan about
what was the intent what are you going
to ask our people to do how many of them
do you need and what is the expectation
of them because they want to make sure
it matches with their framework it
matches with our organizational values
so they want to be able to have answers
to all those things before they ever say
yes so normally that involves seeing a
plan
okay
um
but what about this the view that you
know
if you send them to Ottawa at least
they're there to be to be used when
there is a plan if there's a delay if
it's going to take you two or three or
four days to get 500 OPP officers to
Ottawa then when you have a plan you
still have to wait two or three or four
days
it's just it's not an um
an appropriate use of our resources we
need to have an idea what do you want to
do with those 500 we'll get them going
but we have to have some idea currently
there's there is absolutely nothing that
says what they'll do when they do
traffic control or they do qrt Patrols
what do you have them do I'm not going
to bring 500 officers to Ottawa
literally fly them from Sulu code all
over the The Province try to find some
of them for them to stay
without having understanding of what
they're doing and that's that goes for
Municipal Police Services too they need
to have an understanding what their
members are going to do
we're protecting our members we're not
going to send them several hours away
and say go to Ottawa
I really don't know what you're going to
do I really don't know how long you're
going to be there I don't know what to
tell you to pack just show up there and
we'll figure it out when we get there
that's just not how we operate okay
um and at this point this is February
5th our ins is inspector Union and staff
sergeant Govan are they still embedded
with the Ops Planning Group at the as of
February 5th
I believe they're still there or trying
I don't know that they're sitting around
the table working on it because I feel
that their frustrations had built over
to the point where they just couldn't
put pen to paper at that point okay
um
and did you speak with the commissioner
on uh on February 5th I'd have to check
my notes but I know I had a couple
different calls directly with the
commissioner to advise them of what I
was seeing and what I've discussed I
just have to look to see the date okay
um if you see that today then I believe
that's I believe you spoke with him uh
perhaps twice that day actually but
what what concerns were you elevating to
the commissioner
many of the things you've already heard
the disorganization and ability to have
PLT get engaged in what needed to get
done
concerns with the incident command
structure within the Ottawa Police
and an uncertainty of what role he
wanted us to play in supporting their
operations and was really looking for
him to engage with Chief slowly to have
those conversations to say in case you
weren't aware this is what's happening
welcoming to to try to resolve it okay
um and do you understand that the
commissioner did have those discussions
with Chief slowly yeah I know from the
one recollection the commissioner karik
advised he talked to Chief slowly and
she slowly told him yes PLT is an
important part of our plan we want to
embed it in our plan it's it's the way
forward
and he indicated that he thought that
that's what was occurring
and he felt that there was a productive
conversation okay
and just generally sort of how often
were you in contact in relaying your
observations and concerns to
commissioner karique
in the early days I maybe every third or
fourth day we would have a group call
and update him on what was occurring if
things were stressing to the point
around this period of time things were
getting more stressful
and basically my members inspector Bode
and then we're saying we need to talk to
the commissioner about this to let them
know what's happening then I would ask
for those calls to happen but
okay
um I want to ask you about
the the Coventry Road enforcement so if
you could just tell us
what what happened there as far as you
understand it
so the first I learned about it was in
I've received an invitation to join a
zoom call video call with Chief slowly
in his his command
and um
apparently he had heard that the opp PLT
team was leaving and he wanted to talk
to me about it
I didn't know anything really about that
until I got on the call and then I heard
the story much like deputy chief
Ferguson told this morning essentially
PLT had gone to the Coventry Road site
to try to negotiate the removal of some
gasoline and
um
major instant Commander Patterson and
was aware of this and chose to use it as
an enforcement opportunity and when the
cast was being driven away his members
pulled the vehicles over seized the gas
and charged the members
and that caused
extreme stress amongst the PLT team both
Ottawa Police Service and OPP PLT
members to the point where the Ottawa
Police BLT members just said you folks
you should go home we've lost we've lost
all any Goodwill we were able to reach
with some of the Convoy organizers or
operators was now lost because there's
there's no way they could not have seen
the connection between them trying to
negotiate or remove the gas and then
being arrested
it was too obvious so there was much
concern about that but on this call
I learned that
staff sergeant Ferguson who's in charge
of Ottawa Police BLT didn't know that
that was superintendent Patterson's plan
not long they hadn't communicate it
it was a shock because it was as much of
a shock to him as anybody else okay
um and I think you
transcribed your recollection of the
call in an email so if we could pull up
OPP four zeros one five three two
and if we can go down just to the top of
your email
there we go
um
so the following is a summary of the Ops
video call that inspector Bode asked me
to participate in on his behalf this
evening so so inspector bodan was not uh
wasn't able to make it no
okay
um the next paragraph I can say that Ops
Chief slowly said numerous times that
PLT needs to be embedded and engaged in
operations and that it was mission
critical that they'd be
I sensed however that they just do not
understand how best to utilize PLT
where where did you get that sense from
and where was the the disconnect in the
in the organization I was having
discussions with my own PLT members who
were they had decided on their own to
try to pair up with Ottawa Police BLT
members so they were seeing it firsthand
as you heard this morning the Ottawa
Police PLT program is different than the
opp program ours is full-time Ops is
part-time
and they seem to be being used more as
an intelligence gathering capacity
rather than trying to to make
concessions and figure out what exit
plans are there's more hey who's in this
truck or are you what are you doing here
um
and um
it didn't seem to be that measured
approach that our PLT members are used
to doing it was more hard tech you're
going to get arrested if you don't get
out of here type thing
the next paragraph uh mentions a Dr
Peter Collins who was on the line
what uh who is Dr Collins and what role
was he playing
sure Dr Collins is a forensic
psychologist he has worked with the opp
um for many years mainly in a tactical
capacity crisis and negotiator capacity
I've used him when I was in our homicide
unit if I was going to interrogate a
person that was to have no mental health
problems I would speak to Dr Collins to
get his perspective on how best to
approach a person that may be suffering
whatever ailment they were suffering but
he mainly works with the crisis
Associated side of our organization
I understood at some point he was
brought into this operation and he was
made aware of this incident and um
he wasn't on video I think he was on the
telephone I didn't see his face anyways
on the video call and uh those were the
comments he gave about the impact this
was going to have on the program and on
the members that are in the program
um the next paragraph ops command feels
that there is a silver lining as the
arrests were made away from the Fuel
Depot so there was not as strong a
connection between PLT and the arrests
did you share that that silver lining
assessment
no I mean no
um I have trained PLT investigators that
are getting
um calls from their contacts in the
Convoy saying we're not going to talk to
you again like this just happened why
would you we ever trust you again
so it was clear that
as much as superintendent passion may
have hoped that there was a a
disconnection and then the members could
make that connection
that connection was made right away
um if we go down to the next
paragraph
they then had a long conversation about
Staffing and again she slowly stated
that PLT needed to be embedded in all
they do chief slowly expects all
policing Partners will engage in arrests
for aiding and abetting the offense of
mischief and if they refuse then he will
call that police service's Senior
Management to ensure they do can you
describe for us what what that captures
there
and he was expecting all officers
regardless of who they work for
to affect Mischief arrest for members
who were believed to be carrying
gasoline
that's what he was looking for
okay oh is this just in relation to
um Coventry Road in the gas issue or is
this a larger issue no it was the larger
issue okay
um but at this point on February 6th
um
there's there's no
uh large operational plan that's ready
to be actioned is there there's not
okay
and so when when you've written down all
policing partners that includes the RCMP
the opp any other Municipal agencies
that were there participating
um
when he says all policing Partners I
gotta believe he means all policing
partners and that's who was there okay
uh if we go there the next paragraph I
was not asked to speak on the call at
the end I was asked to confirm the rumor
that OPP PLT was leaving uh I explained
that it was in fact the Ops PLT members
who suggested our PLT folks leave
because the Coventry Road fuel arrests
had made their jobs untenable and there
seemed to be no use trying any longer
using PLT tactics
since the trust was broken so just to be
clear did did opp PLT
leave or reduce their the numbers in
light of this never we never left no
okay
and then you go on to describe two major
operational plans upcoming and I wonder
if you can just take us through one and
two and what what was being planned at
that time sure and she slowly was
looking for Action what's happening what
do you do in superintendent Patterson so
he detailed number one he wanted to do a
dynamic harassment take down at radio in
Sussex
um we plan to do that the following day
but because the lack of assets they
postponed it to possibly Wednesday
and they were going to have a call
tomorrow at nine o'clock
um
that myself and superintendent lacques
were invited on I was advised that they
will work through the top Convoy
organizers and influencers and they will
pick a few and there will be planned
arrests and extractions tomorrow of
those persons and they want a PLT
engaged in that along with PLU teams
okay
um did you have a view on on either of
these two operational plans
and The View on both yes I didn't agree
with either for various reasons
um I didn't see a plan for dynamic
arrests that were supposed to happen
within the next couple days
there's no nothing I could read how they
plan to use the PLU what time a day they
plan to do it I hadn't seen what
intelligence or PLT work they've done on
the intersection understand who was
there had no understanding of how they
plan to get rid of the trucks
remember just a total lack of
information on that call anyway so I
couldn't support that and then
basically what she's describing in
number two are snatching crabs off the
street
which we're normally not associated with
and again he doesn't speak about time of
day and again he speaks about involving
PLT in them how our PLT engaged in
Snatch and grabs that's that's from my
experience that's not what OPP PLT are
involved in so I certainly right away
had concerns for both of those
sorry when you say PLT like the PLT
would actually engage in the arrests
that was the struggle well all I can see
is he he said they want PLT engaged in
one aspect or how
was unknown he didn't go into those
details on on the call
and then I believe you spoke with
superintendent Patterson after the call
if you can just uh describe for us that
second call with superintendent
Patterson yes I had heard because I had
heard that our plou unit had been
engaged as part of this covenantry road
exercise so I contacted inspector um
Dave Springer to say like what are we
doing there he said we're just here to
protect BLT we're not engaged with the
gasoline we're just making sure nobody
gets hurt
and in our conversation I'd understood
that even some of the Ottawa police
detectives were uncertain about their
legal authorities to do what they were
doing
could they seize the trucks could they
seize the gas could they lay the charges
so I wanted to talk further with
superintendent Patterson to say
where are you getting this Authority I'm
assuming you've consulted the crown
attorney what has a crown attorney told
you about this
what is the current attorney told you
about your authorities to have a crown
opinion letter that I could have because
until and if I see that letter
I'm not directing my OPP members to be
engaged in this type of activity until I
can be certain that the crown attorney
supports it once again my role as
strategy commanders to protect my people
from their physical safety but also
their civil liability I don't want them
involved in illegal arrests
it's a difficult thing to make the
connection between gasoline and a
criminal offensive mischief
so there may be a memo out there which
eventually there was the ground attorney
was able to explain that
these type of defenses as long as you
can articulate them correctly can lead
to charges
I had conversations with OBP senior
command either the next day or two days
later once I got the letter
and once they saw it in that
conversation they I said no it's okay
OPP members can participate in this type
of activity so then I had to work with
my incentive commanders to build a
training package for my members to say
okay here's your authorities here's how
to approach it
even down to the basics about what do
you do with the seized gas you just
can't throw in the trunk of your car
down to that level but we had to create
a system for our own members to
understand and educate them
but um as of the evening of February 6th
that
that level of planning didn't exist for
for the the OPP's Pou right
I'm sorry they're planning for the poe
the work that you did over the next two
days to ascertain that you know this was
something you could do and you would
plan for what to do with the gas that
work hadn't been carried out but at the
time that you're having this
conversation with superintendent
Patterson I'm just trying to gather
information yeah
um
if we could pull up OPP
four zeros one five four six please
so this is an email that you sent I
believe that the following day after uh
the call if we could scroll down
you sent it to Deputy Harkins and chief
superintendent Thomas yes Deputy I did
not want to mention this on the call
with the group but feel it important for
you to have this information on my call
with ops command last night she slowly
asked his people to send him their
resource needs they told them that they
need 250 members a day to run things
Chief slowly told them that if they need
a hundred he will ask for 200 if they
need 200 he will ask for 400. he seemed
very comfortable asking for twice what
he really needed he looks at it
that
it the other partner police agencies
can't meet the ask number than Ottawa
may still get more than they really need
it was a very strange call to be a part
of
um
can you sort of tell us how that came
about on the call and why you were
relaying that information to uh to
Deputy Harkins and uh and chief
superintendent Thomas
um it came near the end of the call I
believe the chief had to leave so it was
one of those okay before I leave this is
what I want so his attraction to his
members was I need to know how many
people we need to operate and control
this event
and if you tell me like I I don't want
to repeat the email but that's what he
that's what he's saying
um and that was his rationale uh for
saying it
um I was surprised only because
I I thought he knows I'm on the call he
knows I'm here because he
he welcomed me on the call and we talked
about PLT not leaving so he knows I'm
still here but he's talking about
basically doubling the ask he's going to
ask from other police agencies in
Ontario to support
what's happening in Ottawa
with no plan there's no plan to put
these numbers into yet but these are
just random numbers
so I have found that strange and I felt
it was important for my chief to be in
commissioner to be aware of it because I
knew that higher level meetings were
happening with Chiefs around Ontario
about how they could support Ottawa
and I thought it was important for them
to have in their back of their mind
about what occurred that night
okay
um and did you say anything on the on
the call with Chief slowly and the other
members of the Ops at the time
no he he left a call rather abruptly he
basically said this is my direction and
then he left the call
and there was a bit of that awkward
silence like
you could tell the other people knew
that I Abrams is on this call
which is was awkward
um but we moved forward after that there
was no direct talk about
this doubling of numbers we never
discussed it
um and again going back to the
the issue of numbers driving the plan or
plan driving numbers had that to your
knowledge like had you said it or to
your knowledge that somebody else said
it directly to anybody at Ops like we
don't need a number we don't need a
number that's doubled we need a plan and
you'll get the resources when we have a
plan
that's essentially the conversations
we're having all along with Deputy Bell
is
where's the plan we need an operational
plan and Deputy Bell agreed like yeah we
know we need to play and we're working
on a plan
so really the numbers were irrelevant as
we've spoken about it's about the plan
first and the numbers can come later it
may be it's 1800 as we heard it was
actually more than that
but to ask for all these numbers without
a plan and explanation of what they'll
be used for seemed odd to me
okay
um and I think the seventh is the same
day that Chief slowly publicly requested
1800
officers I thought it was the eighth
only because I thought how could a team
come up in under 24 hours when they were
just told on the seventh to come up with
a number and all of a sudden the number
is 1800 the next day
how did they figure that out in under a
day
I may have my dates wrong but I thought
it was the eighth that the announcement
came of the 1800 okay
um I believe it's the seventh but okay
in any event did you
um
how did you view that number in light of
this this conversation
I viewed it with suspicion
okay
um and so around this time uh the eighth
and the ninth
uh former Chief superintendent party
became involved in in the um in the
events can you describe how he became
involved in what his role was
um I was invited in a call on the
morning of the eighth with the
commissioner Deputy Deputy Harkins is on
the call Superintendent McDonald and
chief party
and the commissioner announced that
there was going to be an integrated
planning team that would attend Ottawa
he gave us a mission essentially the
mission was to help the
Ottawa Police restore trust and
confidence in their service
obviously help them with planning to get
themselves out of the situation that
that's occurring in the city of Ottawa
those were the essentially high level
expectations from this integrated
planning team
Ottawa Police would still be the police
of jurisdiction this wasn't the
situation where the opp were coming to
take over an incident that experts would
be drawn from other police services to
come with cheap party subject matter
experts in public order
major events to help Ottawa please come
up with a plan to see this come to an
end
um I didn't hear
where this idea came from I assumed it
was from higher level meetings that
commissioner Creek was a part of
but
it was told to me because I was the Lone
senior officer on the ground up to that
point that would be important to have
besides Chief party to inform them what
have been occurring because he was he
was a regional commander in North Bay
she didn't really have intimate details
of what was happening in Ottawa
so that's why I was placed on the team
with him and and then he was given
direction to come to Ottawa
um and did you remain part of that team
only for a short period of time I'd say
48 hours at the most once it was clear
that larger plans were going to be put
in place and and at that point OPP was
probably providing around 150 officers a
day we were kind of reaching our
capacity in the command posts we were in
in Canada
and it was expected at a much larger
number would likely come once the
integrated planning team got their work
together and they were under a tight
timeline like they wanted to have a plan
within you know 48 hours if possible to
get this done
um my time was better spent rotating
back to coordinating the logistical uh
challenges of getting all those members
into Ottawa so I helped Chief party out
for the first couple of days and once he
was established with his subject matter
experts I rotated back to my role of
overseeing a deployment of Frontline
officers to the city of Volvo okay
um you just mentioned that at this point
you're at about 150 officers a day up
from 30 a day maybe a week ago you know
basically went 30 60 120 and then
obviously on weekends we always had
surge weekends because more people would
come in a weekend so we have to have
more numbers for weekends we bump up to
156 160 on a weekend
and then back to 120 on a Monday Euro
Tuesday
just because there was always was a
surge of population on a weekend
um we're around that number uh when
cheap party arrived okay
um but so these numbers had increased in
the absence of any sort of concrete
operational plan is that fair to say
yeah that's correct and we're in
because there were traffic points there
were easy to articulate and the reasons
why they needed our people for help they
just they needed to restrict the flow of
traffic into the downtown core
and the traffic points just to continue
to grow and they're running out of
Ottawa police officers to stick on those
traffic points so in a maintenance phase
you don't necessarily need a super
detailed plan to hop out on a
maintenance place or just essentially
holding ground until a plant can be
developed so we are comfortable in
deploying those members because they
knew exactly what they were supposed to
do exactly what their role was and I
could articulate that to our members so
we were we felt safe and confident to
bring them to town to do that okay
um and I understand you attended a
couple of early integrated planning team
meetings as I guess this transition was
was happening what can you tell us about
those meetings
so the first meeting was the evening of
February 8th around the five o'clock
Mark
um Chief party had a scribe with them
and normally my
general rule of thumb is if there's a
scribe in the room and they're taking
notes I won't take notes because they're
religiously taking notes so his scribe
took the notes and we received a
presentation from acting deputy chief
Ferguson about our concepts of operation
that single sheet we saw earlier this
morning with a set of Point sorry
she displayed that to us and explained
that to us and then we had General
discussions about how they felt about an
integrated team and does she think it's
as a value and just had those kind of
discussions about what was happening and
how this integrated team could help them
move forward
okay and
what did you sense the reception of the
integrated team was like on the Ops side
Deputy Ferguson was very much in support
of it I think she explained Chief slowly
was supposed to be on the call but he
had an emergent issue he had to deal
with that night so he wasn't able to be
on the call there was some technical
issues
um being at RCP headquarters everybody
who wanted to be on the call could be on
the call at that time but
um
we gained very good ground we had good
conversations we requested Deputy
Ferguson stated that they were just
finishing up
a larger concept of operational plan it
just wasn't quite ready yet she
indicated it'd be ready the next morning
So the plan was for her to come again
and show us the more broader expanded
plan the following morning on the 9th
okay and did that happen no uh Chief
party called me early in the morning to
say that you'd heard from acting Deputy
Ferguson that it wasn't quite ready yet
they were just finishing it up and that
they would prefer if we attended
downtown Albion Street around the lunch
hour okay and can you describe that
meeting for us
um
certainly
um it was in a boardroom on the second
floor at the auto Police Headquarters
she slowly was President two deputies
were present
um
a few inspectors superintendent
Patterson was President
um
Council Hugh Noll I apologize if you
don't pronounce your name correctly she
was president
and it was myself Chief party
inspector from York Regional Police
Tim's first name I apologize I can't
think of his last name superintendent uh
from the RCMP Phil Loop and Staff
Sergeant or sergeant
Darwin tetral
and we we all sat in one line on one
table she slowly sat the head of the
table flanked by his deputies
they spoke kind of acting deputy chief
Ferguson gave her presentation on the
expanded concept of operations and what
that looked like
after that presentation
Chief slowly turned to me directly which
I was surprised because I just happened
to be the first OPP in the line Chief
party was next to me on my right
and um
in a clearly unhappy fashion expressed
his unhappiness with the fact that the
sister General reported that was 15
interwp officers in his City when fairly
there was not
and he was quite upset about that I
explained to him that I was the one who
provided numbers on the 2nd of February
I was asked by the children's office to
provide
a document to show how many OPP members
were in the city of Ottawa clearly there
was more than just Frontline officers we
had public order officers we had
Intelligence Officers we had PLT members
we had logistical officers
um traffic members so I my team created
a chart daily chart from the beginning
to that period second of February with
um rows and columns delineating PLU and
traffic and then a total for each day
and then a total accumulative I want to
say the cube of total at that point was
8 26 it could be 862. it was around that
number and they stated that each day
moving forward was going to average
about 125 a day
and I submitted that to my chief
superintendent I never saw the numbers
again
so I explained to Chief solely that I
didn't explain to Chief slowly in that
detail I just said I'm the one who's had
been in the numbers
in my opinion I think that
a soul gen media staff or just maybe
crafted a bad sentence the intent was
not to say there was 1500 literally that
day the intent was to say it was
cumulative
um Chief slowly again became upset and
basically said don't explain the
politics of the Sultan's Office to me I
know that was done intentionally
and I just said I'm I can't speak to
that I just provided the numbers and we
moved on
okay and
um was there a discussion about Rito and
Sussex at this meeting as well there was
so we were provided
um I want to say it was a three-page
document by superintendent Patterson
that detailed kind of his daily plan it
was weekly Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Sunday and what he
planned what they plan to do there were
Dynamic actions primarily and one of
them was supposed to happen that evening
at 11 o'clock
so he detailed that and basically just
kind of left it there to say
as if for us to say okay
um
so sensing no one else in the room was
speaking I started to ask some direct
questions to superintendent Patterson to
say
what are you going to do with the trucks
um what's your plan with the trucks it
had two plans with the trucks one plan
was to use retired Ottawa Police members
to drive them out of there
indicated they'd been there for a quite
period of time many of them had been
Chained and altered to kind of make it
difficult to tell them I'm not a diesel
mechanic but a lot you probably need
mechanic skills to get them started
again
and he indicated well if that didn't
work I'd use the Canadian Armed Forces
tow trucks to total
and I said have you asked for an age as
a civil power from the federal
government
and super 10 pass indicated that he
didn't require that that wasn't
necessary
so then I asked because I knew through
those weeks that week I was getting
regular phone calls from my PLT as I've
described about their frustrations of
when not being able to get engaged no
autonomy no connection I asked as PLT be
engaged in this plan this takedown plan
and Super Dan Patterson said they had I
knew they had
so that concerned me
so I told them directly I said I'm not a
public worker unit Commander
but based on what I'm seeing what I've
just heard
you will never see OPP support for any
operation tonight or tomorrow based on
what I'm reading and literally
it's two lines on a page to take down a
whole intersection
there's no idea of no indication anyway
it's a dive meeting is there children in
the car how many people are in each
truck
I wasn't told to us at that meeting
essentially they were looking for us to
agree
and I wasn't comfortable I had to ask
the questions because it was dangerous
for my members
that's what I'm being paid to do protect
our members and our organization and it
was at night time
only in emerging extreme situations we
ever do public order exercise in the
dark we don't operate in the dark it's
too dangerous for our members too
dangerous for the public
so there's so many reasons why I could
never support it as that's why I had to
ask the direct questions I did
and how was it left at the end of the
meeting
then we transitioned then Chief priority
and RCMP members then Pike tend to
basically say to Chief solely maybe you
should pump the brakes
slow down a bit and allow this is Darwin
touch we're talking now
allow he had coordination for public
order unit in the RCP I can get you
bodies here to Ottawa but it's going to
take some time
give me a week
we can get you 400 people here
and I really seem to to trigger Chief
slowly it became very passionate I
raised voice again
and um
basically said that the head of the
Hydra is in Ottawa and we needed to cut
the head of the Hydra off in Ottawa so
I'll back up quickly we also talked
about the impacts around the country
that this isn't just an isolated
incident we have Kutz Alberta we have
Ambassador approach there's more events
that happen and
I think superintendent Morris called it
the rubber band effect or elastic Effect
one event that happened in one part of
the country has a media effect on
another we tried to bring that to his
attention he didn't want to hear that
his Focus was on his city which he's the
chief of the city I can't say I blame
him
um but he was very passionate about he
didn't like to hear that he didn't like
to hear about a delay and essentially
said I want you to promise me that you
will get 400 RCMP or Pou members here or
I will go to the minister
he never named the minister by name he
just called he just said the minister
um did you
speak privately with any Ops members
after that meeting about this uh the
redo and Sussex plan in particular
I immediately after the meeting Chief
slowly left the room rather quickly and
acting Deputy Ferguson she was seated to
my left she got my elbow and she just
pulled me to the side and she thanked me
for asking the questions I asked because
they were
almost the same or very similar
questions that she had been asking all
along and was not able to get answers
for
and then a day later I received a text
message from Deputy Bell
saying that he appreciated my direct
questions and felt it helped move the
issue along
okay
um and then just very briefly
what was your role after this I entered
this was the last of your sort of
involvement in the integrated planning
team is that correct essentially I
returned to the headquarters after that
meeting we debriefed the meeting and we
talked about how how dangerous what we
just heard was how we could never
support what we heard and how there was
a need to start and integrated plan
um but I'm not a public order
uh SME so my role was to get back and
and deal with the hundreds of Opp
officers that I had to deploy onto the
street non-po Frontline members Chief
already had this the smes he needed and
my job was to basically make what he
needed from his plan from a Frontline
perspective happen
so I I moved to our Command Post and
allowed him and his playing team to do
the work they needed to do
okay
um
you know you talked just a minute ago
about sort of uh events around the
country and so I want to ask you a
little bit about Windsor
um you had a few discussions with uh
superintendent Dana early there is that
correct
I don't recall speaking to Dana directly
no okay you don't uh you don't recall
having conversations with her no
okay I recall sending messages of
support to another MC
inspector Needham just about the good
work they were doing in the Ambassador
Bridge I don't recall ever having direct
conversations with superintendent early
okay well I'm uh a superintendent early
has recorded that in her notes so
perhaps we'll pull those out see if that
if that helps you
if I could get OPP four zeros four five
four three
and
I did not
it's it's February 10th and I don't have
the page number we'll have to scroll
down I apologize
third page 33 sorry
oh it may be
uh OPP
four zeros four five four three
pages
she takes quite detailed notes
apparently better than myself
okay there we are
um
call from Craig Abrams to confirm
resources and so I guess we're now 10 21
on February 10th I don't know if that
helps situate you it helps you recall
whether you got a call with her in my
original notes on page 52 on the 10th of
February I just have her name Dana
with a slash I don't have any
information so clearly we did connect at
some point but I wasn't able to to
detail what we discussed
uh and so she records um the calls call
from Craig Abrams to confirm Resources
Ottawa has been sending resource
sheets to EOC
um
advised Abrams Windsor is priority
according to Deputy
um do you recall uh superintendent early
telling you that
I can't say that I do
okay I'm not saying she didn't I just
gave him a call
um
if we go further down
at 10
28 I think you're sort of uh
giving her giving her some advice
Abram's advised oh sorry 10 to 28
advised Abrams Windsor has told us this
is now ours do you remember hearing that
from uh superintendent early at all
I don't know if I heard it from from
Dana but I knew that there had been an
agreement that the opp was going to take
over the operations in Windsor I just
can't say that they heard that from Dana
and then uh the the second entry of 1028
Abrams advised uh that's easier
Ottawa doesn't like PLT nightmare this
will allow you to make your own plan
um
Ottawa is Just Trucks on side streets
not affecting livelihoods is that is
that is she recording what you've you're
saying to her at that point
I gotta assume so it seems pretty
detailed
um
I recall
because the comment about making things
easier certainly is a lot easier as I
discussed we were kind of attached at
the hip with Ottawa please we can only
move forward as fast as they were
willing to move forward as the police
jurisdiction
if she was now in a situation in Windsor
where she could
um
essentially control the event it made
her job a lot easier to be able to just
move forward without having to to work
with the police jurisdiction directly
okay and I want to ask you about that
the Ottawa is Just Trucks on side
streets not affecting livelihoods
um
is that is that a view uh that that you
held or that you had heard sort of
espoused in uh within the OPP yeah it's
it's not a by held because I was on the
street I visited my members on the
street and I talked to are my members
and I talked to store owners who
described being accosted because they're
wearing masks and the difficulties that
we're having in their businesses so I
knew that there was impacts on
businesses whether I had those meetings
with business owners after this
conversation or before I can't recall
for sure
but it's it's not
a position I espoused because there was
clearly
um effect on
the residents in that area I think I may
have been
commenting marks I talked to other
members about this if he drove the 417
through Ottawa or he used any streets
south of the 417 you'd never know what
was happening in Ottawa
Ottawa seem to be functioning as as per
normal outside of that core area
I may have been reflecting on my
experience driving around the city of
Ottawa Kind of unimpeded with you know
no real traffic problems generally south
of the 417 but clearly
lots of effects and impacts in the
downtown core
right okay and in
again just kind of backing up one more
step you're not aware of
um
the opp having prioritized sending
resources to Windsor over Ottawa for I
guess economic reasons I never had
conversations about priorities it was
more about
we have this many members tied up in
Windsor so we can only send you this
many
um it wasn't about
making Windsor a priority over Ottawa
that was ever communicated to me that
I'm aware of okay
um I just want to ask you the last uh
series of questions about
the emergencies act and it's invocation
um
and I understand
you uh you know you learned on February
17th about the creation of the the Red
Zone in Ottawa
yes okay
um and
uh
is it your understanding that that was
only made possible by the invocation of
the emergencies Act
it's my understanding through reading
Twitter accounts and media releases at
Ottawa Police had indicated to the
public that the Red Zone was created as
a result of the emergency act that the
Restriction of movement the the
subsequent stoppage of vehicles to
determine if they had lost authority to
be in that controlled area that they
described
was based on authorities obtained under
the emergency act yes okay and did you
have experience
and had you advised officers that there
were existing authorities you had done
it previously without the emergencies
Act
we had talked prior because prior to
this date on the 17th our members were
doing traffic enforcement and but more
in an observation capacity looking for
criminality that may be obvious or
vehicles that may look like they want to
block our roadway
so we had a formal education package the
emcpa was in uh was in Authority at that
period of time so we educated them on
the the provincial emcpa act I gave them
some authorities
and we educated them on their normal
highway traffic act authorities their
normal criminal code authorities
about their ability to stop traffic
determine what they're doing and the
ability to turn them around to end or
make arrests if they feel the other
reasonable grounds to do so
um
I did a lot of the briefings with the
members to explain their authorities and
I tried to explain it in the simple
terms as I could to say you're all
police officers you all understand your
authorities to make arrests you all have
you understand the concept of discretion
and these authorities are available to
you here just like they are back at your
home detachments nothing has changed
so this is prior to the 17th so they
knew they had those abilities if they
saw something they could act they didn't
need the emergency act to do it
um but then when the emergency Act was
invoked and there was restrictions
placed and
um
guidelines is the wrong word but
restrictions or regulations put in place
about boundaries and certain Street
boundaries and entry into those
boundaries and that members of the
public entering that area had to have
three or four different excuses is there
a lawful purpose a business owner going
to a hotel
um so there's three or four different
areas that they were allowed to so my my
officers were then expected to
essentially do that
so it turned from what was officers
really observing traffic
um to once the Act was invoked I went
downtown to see what our members were
dealing with
and it was essentially a 14 to 15 hour
ride program our members wrote in
horrible weather standing on the
roadside checking Vehicles going through
the list
where are you going what are you doing
why are you traveling here do you have a
reason to go here and then turning
around vehicles that may need to be
turned around
okay and the government
revoked the emergencies act on February
23rd you were asked by by your members
what can we continue to do what did you
tell them right so it wasn't necessarily
an ask so I was sitting in the command
post I saw our prime minister on the
television revoked the act and I looked
on my watch and I knew I was less than
an hour away from briefing 300 post
officers that were going to go on the
street that night and I knew they're
going to want to know what what can we
do boss essentially they could see the
TV as well as I could
um so I had to really consider what are
our lawful authorities to do what we're
doing minus the ACT
emergencies Act so I looked at what we
were doing prior
I looked at our common law authorities
to stop Vehicles it was a very
restricted area we'd literally just
cleared the streets almost less than 24
hours before how could we ever just turn
the Streets back over again that we just
secured less than 24 hours we've got to
have a presence and still maintain some
presence of restriction in some capacity
um so I tried to call cheap party uh he
was my kind of commander and just to run
it by him to make sure I was on the
right track unfortunately he was tied up
I think that announcement caught
Everybody by surprise so the phones were
ringing
um so I appeared before them and that's
essentially what I explained to them
I said use your discretion but we're
going to continue to stop vehicles
until and as such time as I'm told not
to laugh authorities you know doesn't
exist anymore the emergency has passed
and at the end of the day the next
morning that's what had happened
meetings were held and it was agreed
there was no intelligence to indicate
that Conway participants were going to
return therefore a common law Authority
that we base our authorities on
what didn't exist anymore there was no
emergent need there's no intelligence to
support us stopping Vehicles so the
direction was made to now fall back to
an observation mode again
on that first evening when I gave that
direction to continue to stop we stopped
11 vehicles that were Convoy related
according to my members I wanted to get
back into the zone that we just cleared
so I was I was glad that we continued it
that evening they gave lots of excuses
they wanted to pick up an old hockey net
that was left behind but who knows maybe
that maybe that was accurate maybe not
but the count was 11 vehicles that we
turned aside and after conversations the
next day of a chief party and Council we
agreed The Authority didn't exist
anymore so we went back to pre-emergency
act and and developed an observational
posture
um we're almost out of time I have two
final questions for you the first is you
know as somebody who had an early
Vantage of the freedom Convoy and and
the preparations
you know can you give us
a very short list of sort of what went
well and what could have been improved
upon in preparing for the arrival of the
Convoy
from an opp perspective or an out of a
police from your perspective as somebody
who observed him uh coming into the city
um I thought the opp role on the initial
uh Convoy arrival in Ottawa went very
smoothly we had minor issues in our
smaller communities with members not
obeying the the mass mandates
made some restaurants who just choose to
ignore their mandates altogether and but
overall we had no assaults we had no
criminality I wasn't aware of any
charges being laid they said what they
would do they kept a one lane they
entered the city of Ottawa in an orderly
fashion
we had minor issues with supporters on
the roadside on the 417 getting kind
dangerously close to the side of the
highway which was a concern but that
wasn't
Convoy the Convoy participants couldn't
control that they did what they said
they would do and they didn't damage any
highways they didn't cause any
criminality so from that perspective it
was a success in getting them into the
city of Ottawa
from an opp that was our mission that
was our goal for that period of time to
have the Convoy come through OPP police
areas without a blockage of a highway
without assaults or damage and injury to
the public and we were successful in all
those areas
okay and and I guess the reverse side of
that question is what would you say to
the suggestion that this could have been
avoided if the opp had more actively
inserted itself or actively
offered support maybe no strings
attached Maybe here's people show us the
plan later
that that might have avoided your
situation
I'm not a subject matter expert in
public order I'm no subject matter
expert in critical instant Commander MC
ask me for my opinion I'll give it to
you but I'm not a highly trained public
order manager
but certainly if you could go by the
intelligence and do an intelligence-led
assessment of what was coming to your
city
I think there was ways to block streets
movie I don't think you could ever stop
them coming to the city at all that was
a far gone conclusion they were coming
to Ottawa it would have been a matter of
how can we lessen the impact to our city
can we divert them to other areas of the
city that have less impact can you
divert them somewhere and then they go
and they do they um protest on foot as
opposed to protesting and what is
essentially a mobile house
once it's in one in one place it's hard
to move
Monday morning quarterbacking is an easy
thing I don't like to do that
but you asked me a question I think
that's a way that perhaps
just like Toronto did but Toronto
admitted that they learned from the
lessons of Ottawa and that's why they
blocked Rose and and were able to clear
the Queen's Park area the way they did
so effectively
so hindsight is always 20 20.
so that's my humble submission but I'm
not naive enough to know that that is
clearly with hindsight
and knowledge that I would never had at
the beginning
thank you superintendent those are my
questions
well thank you superintendent
that's uh very useful and the bad news
is we want you back tomorrow certainly
uh so we're going to adjourn until 9 30
tomorrow morning and uh if everything
goes right you should be out before
lunch
commissioner
will rise until 9 30.
the commission is a journal commission
surgery
foreign
foreign